welcome to this new video by simply
learn business analysis plays a pivotal
role by pinpointing operational
shortcomings streamlining processes and
guiding well-informed decision making
for organizations through data analysis
and requirement definition it empowers
businesses to enhance efficiency cut
expenses and realize the Strategic
objectives
on an average business analyst earns up
to
$86,000 per year as reported by glass
door to get into the business analysis
domain we bring you topnotch courses to
become a skilled business analyst from
the best universities around the globe
business analysis programs provide the
skills like requirement analysis
planning and monitoring wire framing
solution evaluation chat GPD and
generative Ai and much much more it is
important to have knowledge of tools to
become a skilled professional and with
that being said you will learn tools
like msxl jira powerbi R programming SQL
one year of experience is preferred to
enroll in this course so what are you
waiting for hurry up and enroll Now find
the cost Link in the description box so
before we move ahead consider
subscribing to Simply Lear and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so without any further delay over to
tutors Dynamic world of modern business
where strategies evolve rapidly and
decisions are driven by data the role of
a business analyst plays a pivotal role
welcome to Simply learn and we bring you
a comprehensive Guide to Becoming a
successful business analyst today's
tutorial is based on the business
analyst road map for 2024 with leaving
no Stones un turn we are going to take a
deep dive into the list of skills tools
and principles that Empower you
Frameworks that guide you and
programming languages that enable you to
perform and automate critical verticals
of business analysis the best part of
today's tutorial is will provide
insights on how to gain Real World
Experience Bridging the Gap between
theory and practice and making you a
sort after asset in the job market so
join us as we get started on this
thrilling adventure where you'll not
only navigate the business analyst road
map but also learn how to steer your
career towards unparalleled Heights
ready to conquer the world of business
analysis let's Sail on this journey
together with that said if these are the
type of videos you'd like to watch then
hit that like button and subscribe
button and the bell icon to get notified
whenever we drop a new video also if you
are an aspiring business analyst looking
for online training and certifications
from prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learn postgraduate
program in business analysis from P
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be your Go
to option for more details use the link
mentioned in the description box below
also if you're new to business analysis
and want to upgrade your skill to become
a successful business analyst with
proper training and certification from
experts then we would recommend you to
proceed with a business analysis
master's program that will not only help
you with fundamentals but also take you
through the real-time capston projects
to strengthen your learnings to match
the industry standards for more details
use the link mentioned in the
description box below now without any
fur delay over to our training experts
hey all so now let's get started with
the business analyst road map for 2024
we will get started with understanding
who is a business analyst followed by
that we will go through the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
next ahead we have the list of skills
you need to become a successful business
analyst with that discussed we will
proceed with the top companies hiring
business analyst along with their salary
compensations being offered we will be
wrapping up the video by discussing the
most important part of today's session
that is about the process of becoming a
professional business analyst in 2024 I
hope I made myself clear with the agenda
so make sure to stick to the end of this
session so that you don't miss out on
any of the perks of this session so
first let's get started with
understanding who is a business analyst
a business analyst is a professional who
assesses the organization's business
needs identifies opportunities for
improvement and provides later driven
recommendations to facilitate informed
decision making and enhance operational
efficiency to simplify it a business
analyst is someone who helps a company
figure out how to make things work
better and smarter they use data and
Analysis to provide suggestions for
making the business run more efficiently
now moving further into the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here are some of the top roles and
first understanding business needs
business analysts work closely with
stakeholders to understand the
organization's objectives challenges and
needs they identify opportunities for
Improvement and Define perfect project
goals next requirement Gathering they
collect and document detailed
requirements from various stakeholders
including end users to ensure that
projects align with business objectives
the third one data analysis business
analy analyze data to identify Trends
patterns and insights that can inform
decision making they may use statistical
tools and techniques to interpret data
now the fourth role and responsibility
is about project process MPP
they document and analyze existing
business processes identifying
bottlenecks and areas for optimization
they also design and purpose new
processes where needed now getting into
the fifth one that is about solution
design business analysts collaborate
with technical teams to design solutions
that meet business requirements they may
create functional specifications and
system design documents next ahead is
communication effective communication is
the key business analysts facilitate
communication between business
stakeholders and Technical teams
ensuring that everyone is on the same
page moving ahead we have testing and
quality assurance they often participate
in testing activities to verify that
Solutions meet requirements and are free
of Defense next ahead we have change
management business analysts help manage
the changes associated with implementing
new processes or systems ensuring a
small transition and user adoption and
next ahead we have documentation they
maintain comprehensive documentation
including requirements process flows and
project plans to provide a clear record
of project activities the 10th rule is
project management some business
analysts may take on project management
responsibilities ensuring that projects
are delivered on time within the budget
next the 11th one is training and
support they may provide training to end
users on new systems or processes and
often ongoing spot and troubleshooting
and lastly 12th one continuous
Improvement business analysts promote
the culture of continuous Improvement
monitoring the impact of implemented
Solutions and identifying further
optimization opportunities these roles
and responsibilities can vary depending
on the organization and the specific
project business analysts play a crucial
role in Bridging the Gap between
business needs and Technical Solutions
ultimately contributing to the success
and efficiency of the organization
moving ahead we shall get into the
skills required to become a successful
professional business analyst in 2024
business analysts require a combination
of Technical and non-technical skills to
excel in their rules here are some
important technical skills for a
business analyst first one data analysis
business analyst should be proficient in
data analysis techniques including data
mining data modeling and statistical
analysis tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software for example tab
powerbi are often used next skill is
requirements Gathering familiarity with
requirement management tools and
methodologies is essential tools like
Microsoft viio jira or specialized
requirement management software help in
documenting and tracking requirements
moving ahead we have process modeling
knowledge of process modeling techniques
and tools such as bpmn that is business
process model and notation helps in
visualizing and documenting business
processes fourth one is database skills
Basics database skills including the
ability to write SQL queries and
understand datab structures are valuable
for assessing and analyzing data the
fifth skill is about the programming
languages while not always required
Proficiency in programming languages
like python or rart can be advantageous
especially for handling and analyzing
large data sets while automating some
redundant tasks now the sixth skill is
business intelligent tools understanding
how to use bi tools or business
intelligence tools can Aid in data
visualization and Reporting tools like
tblo powerbi or click wave are commonly
used proceeding ahead we have seventh
skill that is about project management
tools familiarity with project
management tools like Microsoft Project
or agile project management software can
be very beneficial especially when
managing project timelines and TRS the
eth skill is about data warehousing
knowledge of data warehousing Concepts
and tools can help business analysts
work with large data sets efficiently
moving ahead we have the ninth skill
which is about the Erp systems
understanding Erp or enterprise resource
planning systems like sap orle or
Salesforce can be valuable when
analyzing data and requirements in
organizations that use these systems the
10th skill is about Version Control
Proficiency in Version Control Systems
like git can be beneficial when
collaborating on documentation or
working in development teams now next
ahead is business and process automation
familiarity with automation tools and
techniques can be useful for identifying
opportunities to streamline processes
and improve efficiency now the 12th one
software development life cycle or sdlc
an understanding of sdlc methodologies
example agile waterfall is crucial for
aligning business requirements with
development processes remember that the
specific technical skills required can
vary depending on the industry and
organization being adaptable and willing
to learn new tools and Technologies is
also an important skill for a business
analyst as the field continues to evolve
now proceeding ahead we will discuss the
company's hiring business analyst here
are the name of the top 10 companies
known for hiring business analy also
there are number of companies in Tire 1
Tire 2 and tire three and also some
startup companies which are actively
looking for certified and professional
business analysts so before that let's
discuss the top big players in the
industry they are deoe Accenture IBM HIC
and Company Amazon Microsoft Google JPM
J and Co Facebook or meta and RP now
proceeding ahead we will discuss the
salary compensation being offered by
these companies so basically we are
looking at the highest average salary
being offered to business analysts so
when it comes to India an entry-level
business analyst in India can expect an
annual salary ranging from 3 lakhs to 6
lakhs or more depending on the factors
that are based on the company and
location you're working with next if you
are an intermediate candidate with 3 to
four years of experience then you can
expect a salary of 6 to 12 lakhs and if
you are a highly experienced person that
is more than four to 5 years of
experience then you can expect the
salary numbers ranging from 12 to 20
lakhs per an and in USA a beginner level
business analyst can expect an annual
salary of $50,000 to $80,000 per an if
you're an intermediate candidate that
has 2 to 3 years of experience then you
can expect $80,000 to $120,000 per am
and if you're a highly experienced
candidate that is with experience of
more than four or five years of
experience then you can expect around
$120,000 to $160,000 per am based on the
company you're working with and the
location you're working in now
proceeding ahead we have the point which
is the most important for today's
discussion that is how to become a
business analyst discovering the path to
becoming a proficient business analyst
involves a series of strategic steps the
first one is Define your objective start
by gaining a deep understanding of the
RO and responsibilities of a business
analyst explore blogs and online courses
to clarify your goals and interests in
this field the next step is Education
Foundation typically a bachelor's degree
in the initial requirement for an
entry-level business an position
pursuing Advanced degrees such as
Masters can significantly enhance your
prospects in this competitive field
moving ahead we have sharpened your
skills as the next step vital to develop
specific skills the top five essential
skills include Proficiency in business
analytics problem solving capabilities
effective communication stakeholder
analysis and Technical expertise
communication skills in particular play
a pivotal role as business anal bridge
the gap between the various teams and
stakeholders followed by this step you
have the certification earning online
business anal certifications can
validate your competencies and keep you
updated with the latest tools and
Technologies while not always mandatory
certifications can set you apart in your
job market and Open Door for CA next
gain Real World Experience practical
experience is invaluable engage in real
world business analytics projects to
apply your knowledge and grasp the
Practical aspects of the profession this
hands-on experience will not only
bloster your skill set but also depend
your understanding of business
operations now the next one is the
portfolio build your own portfolio
create a comprehensive portfolio
showcasing your practical projects
assignments internships and
certifications this portfolio serves as
a testament to your capabilities and can
significantly impact your job prospects
next ahead we have the job application
once you have acquired the necessary
training and experience it's time to
apply for business analyst positions
tailor your resume to highlight your
achievements and skills making a strong
first impression research and
preparation is the next step prior to
applying research prospective employers
and their specific requirements tailor
your application and interview
preparation accordingly demonstrating
your commitment and knowledge for the
business and its needs so these were the
important steps to become a business
analyst Now by following these steps you
will be well equipped to embark on a
fulfilling career as a business analyst
whether you're aiming to start as a
junior business analyst or aspire to
higher positions continuous learning and
practical experience are your key to
success being a business analyst is a
crucial job these professionals help
companies reach their goals by
understanding what's needed you need
more than just data skills to do this
job well in 2024 in this video we will
explore the top 10 skills that are
important for business analysis these
skills help business analysts come up
with new ideas solve tricky problems and
Lead their companies towards success but
before we begin let me ask you a quick
question so what is the primary goal of
a business
analyst option A is increase company
profits option b is solve technical
issues option C is improve business
processes and option D is enhance
employee satisfaction now you can pause
this video and answer in the comment
section below meanwhile let's start with
the first topic which is who is a
business analyst so a business analyst
plays a crucial role in driving
organizational change by understanding
and addressing business's challenges and
offering solutions that optimize value
for stakeholders they are involved in
all aspects of the business from
strategic planning to developing
Enterprise architecture a business
analyst tool extends Beyond just problem
solving they are enrolled in every tiny
aspect of the business from Gathering
requirements and conducting feasibility
studies to facilitating communication
between different teams they act as a
bridge between stakeholders that is
business stakeholders and Technical
teams ensuring that everyone is on the
same page and working towards a common
goal so this was about who is a business
analyst now let's have a look at the
business analysis skills so let's start
with the first one which is business
intelligence tools so business
intelligence tools like sap business
objects IBM cognos and Microsoft powerbi
are essential for business analysts
these tool enable analysts to create
reports dashboards and interactive
visualizations providing valuable
insights to stakeholders bi tools
consolidate data from multiple sources
revealing patterns and correlations that
may go unnoticed with Advanced Data
visualization capabilities analysts can
present complex information in a
visually appealing and interactive
format additionally self-service
features Empower analysts to access and
analyze data independently enhancing
agility and responsiveness familiarity
with these bi tools is crucial for
analysts to leverage data effectively
and drive business success next skill on
the list is
research research skills are essential
for business analyst as they form the
foundation for finding solutions to
company problems it involves Gathering
relevant information and statistical
data necessary for developing Solutions
business analyst must utilize their it
and technological skills to collect
accurate data and analyze it regularly
they are responsible for providing high
quality and detailed requirements to all
project stakeholders ensuring that their
research can address any questions or
concerns that may arise by conducting
thorough research business analyst can
make informed decisions and contribute
to the success of projects by providing
valuable insights and and
recommendations all right coming to the
next one which is data review and
statistical analysis data review and
statistical analysis are critical skills
for business analy data review involves
examining and accessing data sets
quality completeness and accuracy
business analyst must have the ability
to identify any inconsistencies or erors
in the data and ensure its reliability
statistical analysis is the process of
applying statistical techniques to data
in order to uncover pattern relationship
ship and Trends business analysts use
statistical analysis to gain insights
and make data driven decisions they
employ various statistical methods such
as regression analysis hypothesis
testing and data modeling to extract
meaningful information from the data by
conducting thorough data review business
analyst can uncover valuable insights
identify patrons and make informed
recommendations to stakeholders these
skills enable them to provide accurate
and reliable information that support
effective decision making and drives
business success also if you are
interested in taking your career to the
next level look no further our business
analyst Masters program is your gateway
to becoming a job ready with globally
recognized certification we cover all
three vital aspects of business analysis
planning and monitoring requirements
elicitation requirements management and
communication Etc gets hands-on
experience with the latest tools work on
real world projects and gain invaluable
insights through exclusive master
classes let by IBM experts don't
hesitate seize the opportunity to shape
your future enroll now and embark on a
transformative Journey towards a
successful career in business analysis
finishing the course led to personal
recognition and opened the door for even
more artificial intelligent projects and
it came with a significant pay raise my
I had hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old and
last year I upskill with simp
postgraduate program in cyber security
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my CIS and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course we decided to
take a course in devops from Simply
learn the course proved to be very
beneficial for both our careers yeah I
got a promotion after the course and I
got to hire with a new company at plus I
try to learn from YouTube and then apply
for the job but I couldn't C then one of
my friends suggested I go for a
certification post with simp My overall
experience with simply was very good
within a few days I went three call two
our project manager positions and one in
data science I successfully changed my
career from software development to
digital marketing and simply learn
presented the perfect route I chose
simply learn because of its tremendously
High waiting to be r as one of the best
Education portal online worldwide is
surely promising I switched to a new
role as a digital marketing manager with
this my skill upgraded my salary
increased and my self-confident Boost
alongside numerous other positive
outcomes all right next one is process
modeling and analysis so process
modeling and Analysis are vital skills
for business analysts they involve using
techniques like bpmn and tools such as
Aris or visual to map and analyze
business processes by visually
representing process and identify
inefficiencies analyst can propose
improvements these skills enable analyst
to simulate scenarios making performance
and identify bottlenecks or areas of low
efficiency through process modeling and
Analysis analysts can optimize process
reduce cost and enhance customer
satisfaction next on the list is
knowledge of Erp and CRM
systems having knowledge of Enterprise
resources planning Erp systems such as
sap or Oracle as well as customer
relationship management I repeat like
Salesforce is highly beneficial for
business analysts these systems are
crucial in managing and streamlining
various aspects of a business Erp
systems are designed to integrate and
manage Core Business processes including
Finance human resource Supply Chain
management and Manufacturing
understanding Erp systems allow business
analysts to gather requirements
effectively evaluate the integration
needs and support implementation
projects CRM systems focus on managing
customer interactions and relationships
they provide a centralized platform for
storing customer Data Tracking sales
activities and managing marketing
campaigns familiarity with CRM systems
enable business analysts to assess the
customer needs identify opportunities
for enhancing customer experience all
right coming to the next skill which is
creation of reports and dashboards
creating reports and dashboards is a
crucial skill for business analysts they
need to be proficient in business
intelligence tools like table click View
and powerbi to develop General and
dashboard reports these reports help in
solving decision-making Problems by
providing valuable insights business
analysts should have a profound
understanding of these tools by
leveraging the knowledge of these tools
analysts can effectively present data in
a visually appealing and easily
understandable manner enabling
stakeholders to make informed
decisions next skill on the list is
Microsoft
Excel next Microsoft Exel as we all know
it is a very important skill this is a
fundamental skill that every business
analyst must have Excel is one of the
oldest and strongest analytical and
Reporting tools business analyst can use
it perform several calculations data and
budget analysis to unrev business
patterns they summarize data by creating
pivot tables they make different charts
using Excel to generate Dynamic reports
related to business problem business
analysts use Excel to calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product they even summarize
customer Revenue by product to find
areas where there is a need to build
stronger customer relationships all
these things tell us like how important
is Excel for business analysis all right
coming to the next one which is
documentation and presentation
documentation and presentation are
crucial skills for business analyst
effective documentation involves
recording project insights and outcomes
in a very clear and concise manner this
allows for easy reference and knowledge
transfer additionally business analysts
must confidently present their findings
to stakeholders and clients by
delivering well structured presentations
they can effectively communicate project
outcomes and recommendations furthermore
organized documentation enables business
analyst to bridge the gap between
Technical and non-technical employees
facilitating the understanding of
complex Concepts mastering documentation
and presentation skills enhance a
business analyst's ability to convey
information and contribute to successful
project implementation so this is
another important skill coming to the
next one which is requirement management
requirement management is a crucial
aspect of project development it
involves utilizing tools such as jira
Confluence or IBM rational doors to
proficiently hand requirements these
tools Aid business analyst in capturing
documentation tracking and managing
requirements throughout the Project Life
Cycle by leveraging these tools teams
can ensure that all necessary
requirements are identified documented
and effectively communicated this
streamlined approach enhances
collaborations minimizes errors and
facilitates efficient project execution
so this was about the top 10 business
analysis skills for 2024 so what is
project management now as defined in PMI
PMB project management is application of
knowledge skills tools and techniques to
project activities to meet project
requirements so every project will have
an objective to accomplish similarly the
objective of project management is to
make the final deliverables in a finite
time and budget this involves having
clear understanding about the
deliverables of the project required
resources for the project resource in
terms of Human Resources Technical
Resources Financial Resources Etc
project manager should have a full
picture of those aspects we can call it
as constraints or aspects and manage
those throughout the Project Life Cycle
for which a project manager should have
a full view about a project and what is
that this project has to accomplish that
objective should be clear so as part of
project management the six constraints
which project manager should look at are
scope time quality cost risk and
resources so each of these areas has
very important role to play in project
management the clarity in scope the
clarity in terms of schedule within
which the project has to be delivered
the cost what it incur to that
particular project once it is finalized
one cannot vary when cannot change
without any proper approvals similar to
that we have quality management which
has to ensure the scope the
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organ organization so
organization should assess the risk
associated with the project and
similarly as project progresses various
different risks has to be identified
like Risk related to project management
risk related to technology area risk
related to resources risk related to
financial things so broadly risk
management plays a very important role
so there will be something called
contingency reserve kept for a
identified risk above the cost what is
estimated for various deliverables from
the project so every project require
resources resources may be in terms of
Human Resources Financial Resources
technology resources environmental
resources so all these resources are
used to produce the output of the
project so these resources has to be
managed with the sufficient optimization
and standardizations required now let us
understand the definition of a project
so what is a project PMI defines a
project as a temporary endeavor
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result the temporary nature
of a project indicates that a project
has a definite beginning and end so when
I say product unique product it means
every output it may be similar products
you are producing with the same features
and functionality but the output of
every project is unique because it is
unique in terms of all the six
constraints what we just discussed now
now when I say product it is very easy
for us to visualize it may be a desktop
it may be a laptop it it may be a car it
may be a machine Etc but how do I
visualize a service now project output
is a service now it is it's about
building a capability a project by
through a project a capability can be
built to ensure Services can be provided
that's what the output of project is
service for example if I think about a
taxi services for providing a taxi
services I need a mobile app I need taxi
I need a server I need a data center so
all these are various different products
and services here service example can be
internet service so combination of all
the services and products builds the
capability for an organizations who can
provide the taxes services so building
that capability we say it is an output
of a particular project which is called
service similarly results can be
Improvement of something Improvement in
customer satisfaction increase in um
some specific objectives or specific
results need to be achieved in
performance perspective so output of
every project will be unique product or
a service or a result this we need to
clearly understand so when we say there
is a definite beginning and end every
project starts at certain point in time
and ends at certain point in time so it
has a definite beginning and end that is
the reason it is temporary in nature it
is not an ongoing business activity
right so every project will have a life
cycle a beginning and end so when it
starts till end until the result or a
service or a product which comes as an
output of a project project life cycle
is not ended so interestingly in a
product life cycle or in a service life
cycle you come across many project life
cycles so one Project Life Cycle means
one project is initiated to introduce a
product or Services next project or uh
initiated would be to enhance the
capability of a service or a product
next project initiated after some time
is to optimize something similarly at
the end of the product life cycle
project is ini iated to retire that
product or services so in a given
product life cycle there will be
multiple Project Life Cycle so what is
involved in the Project Life Cycle it
involves five areas five groups we can
call it as so initiation planning
execution monitoring and closure so when
I say initiation it's all about
understanding what is Project giving the
basic understanding of the project
collating the details and having key
stakeholders identified once that is
done one will move towards plan learning
so here in the initiation it is very
clearly one has to understand is Project
is worthwhile of doing so one has to
check the feasibility one has to measure
that particular investment is making
sense and then confirm yes it makes
sense to invest now next planning as we
have a basic understanding of yes this
project has to be done and a discussion
with the key stakeholders have happened
now that moves towards planning now in
planning one will understand the project
in entirety if it is a waterfall
approach one has to have a clear
articulation of entire project a
comprehensive details holistic approach
now if you go if you're going in a
project in a agile way of approach now
in this planning you may have a big
skeleton as you go in each of the
iteration you may go deep dive into
detailed planning if it is a agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear Insight towards what needs to be
done in this project how it has to be
done and what are the results which can
be Achi achieved out of that particular
project so this involves making that
clear blueprint of an project objectives
what we are supposed to achieve so this
will become a reference point throughout
the Project Life Cycle then execution as
you have a blueprint of the project as
the direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and execute the
project execute in the sense
implementation acquiring resources and
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the aables as required you
acquire resources you configure resource
you ensure right resources are acquired
if it is human resource one has to
educate that human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to provide that assignment in
such a way that skills of that
individuals what they should have is
acquired by those individuals so that
deliverables can happen and they needs
to be managed the entire team need to be
managed for that a clear structure has
to be created similar Sly when you do
technology resource perspective those
components has to be tested configured
then integrated again tested for and
check the performances so Collective
action of this results in a deliverable
during the execution so as the
deliverables are happening in the
execution it is quite obvious project
manager has to monitor review control
that particular deliverable and also the
processes tools resources used during
the project even those needs to be
monitored so that they are complying to
the defined processes so during
monitoring there may be a deviation one
can found during monitoring there may be
the project is running the way it is
required so in this monitoring phase it
involves an action from project manager
to Monitor and control the work of the
project so comparing with the blueprint
of plan what is accomplished what is
created during the planning uh phase of
this project and as the execution
happens monitoring and control is
monitoring it and checking is that
activities what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of a projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project
deliverables needs to be accomplished
within the cost what is budgeted for the
project so during the project project
you project manager may find there are
certain deviations which are occurred
there are additional challenges which
has come in so for this reason one has
to ensure continued monitoring as the
execution happens and identify those
deviation and ensure Whenever there is a
deviation there is a correction Whenever
there is an additional things coming in
that needs to be considered carefully
whether that need to be involved as part
of this deliverable or should be taken
it separately so this requires a lot of
conversation with with all the
stakeholders of the project during the
entire Project Life Cycle especially
during planning execution monitoring and
control since they are not the one which
is happening in sequence so planning can
also come back again where there is
something which you may require to
modify so may require to have a change
in the blueprint Itself by adding that
new change which is coming in so you go
back to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand
inand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed similarly all the
process work instructions all those
templates what is given are used one is
complying to those requirement it's no
surprise that business analytics and
business intelligence are two of the
fastest growing markets in the world
organizations today are generating data
at a rapid rate there is a need to use
this business data and make smarter
decisions companies are looking for
methods and tools to turn business data
into actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact-based decision-
making on the other hand business
intelligence or bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data
visualization it allows you to analyze
data with queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively consider this
example suppose you sell homemade
chocolates through an online store
business intelligence provides
meaningful insights into the past and
current state of your business bi tells
you that sales of your milk chocolate
have spiked up in Texas the past 2 weeks
so you decide to manufacture more milk
chocolates to keep up with demand
business analytics asks why did sales of
milk chocolates Spike up in Texas by
scrutinizing your website data you
learned that most traffic has come from
a post by a food blogger based in Texas
who liked your milk chocolate this
Insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States using Cutting Edge
business analytics and intelligence
tools such as Microsoft Excel SQL
powerbi and tblo can enhance customer
experience improve efficiency conduct
competitor analysis and ail business
analyst is a professional who is
responsible for Bridging the gap between
it and business
teams they use analytics to evaluate
processes determine requirements deliver
datadriven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and
stakeholders business analyst is an
individual who is a part of the business
operation and works closely with the
technology team to improve the quality
of the services being delivered they
also help in assisting in integration
and testing of new Solutions growing a
career in a field with high demand such
as business analysis could be a
challenge and competition for business
analyst positions can be intense so you
should have a clear understanding of the
roles and responsibilities of a business
analyst a ba should successfully
identify and recognize the
organization's business objective they
should understand the business problems
and think of a lucrative business
solution they need to understand and
collect the business requirements from
clients and stakeholders allocate the
right resources and improve the existing
business documentation of business
findings is another important key role
of a business
analyst baas interact with the
development team to design the solution
for solving a particular problem they
often need to spend a certain amount of
time in meetings in order to save the
development team from spending their
time and understanding the stakeholders
requirement they often give feedback on
the layout of a software application as
to what all features need to be added
and what functionalities should the
application contain and also implement
the newly designed features that a
business
needs while Bas identify the needs
Define the features right use cases
uncover business rules and manage issues
they should also gauge the functional
and non-functional requirements in a
business business analysts run meeting
with stakeholders and other authorities
hence discussing issues with the client
face Toof face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how datadriven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's
requirements they also ensure that the
product delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally Bas write documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business
insights they also deliver maintenance
reports they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a
project business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often refer to as
soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not not only acquired
through training but through experience
and combined with the ability to
understand situations and the motive
behind the problem so let's have a look
at the top skills to become a successful
business analyst the first skill we have
is understanding the business
objective for a business analyst it is
important to know the goals and
objectives of the business it is advised
that business analyst should have a good
knowledge of the business operations in
his or her
organization a business analyst should
understand the problems related to the
business and come up with the right
solution business analysts should
resolve the problems that have been
identified and not avoid them they work
on individual actions and tasks that
will build towards the achievement of
the goals of the business objectives of
the business can be to expand customer
base in order to increase sales scale a
production so that it is in line with
the revenue growth improve revenue
streams through increasing perceived
product value or increasing marketing
budget according to the revenue business
analysts should have the Natural
Curiosity and determination to continue
learning and figuring out how things fit
together even as business analysts
become managers it is important to stay
in touch with the industry and its
changes the next important skill a
business analyst would have is
analytical and critical
thinking now there is a famous quote by
Thomas Elva Edition which says 5% of the
people think 10% of the people think
they think and the other 85% would
rather die than think business analysts
are paid to think a business analyst
should be able to analyze and interpret
the client's requirements
clearly business analy require good
focus in order to collect and understand
the needs of the client critical
thinking involves evaluating several
options before arriving at the desired
solution in certain situations a
stakeholder may give a requirement
that's not necessarily tied up to any
business value but rather to their own
increased convenience applying critical
thinking demands not taking all the
statements of the stakeholders for
granted
critical thinking allows the business
analyst to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a low priority a business analyst must
be creative in order to reach stated
goals where resources are limited and
the conditions are non-
ideal the third important skill for a
business analyst is communication and
interpersonal
skills understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession if
you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requir requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message business analysts apply
communication skills at every point they
use communication and interpersonal
skills when the project is launched
while Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final
solution listening reading and writing
skills are very critical for a business
analyst this should be capable of
facilitating meetings business analysts
use verbal and written communication to
convey ideas Concepts facts and opinions
to a variety of stakeholders non-verbal
communication skills enable the
effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact effective
listening allows the business analyst to
accurately understand information that
is being communicated
verbally fourth in our list of skills we
have negotiation and cost benefit
analysis being a successful business
analyst requires working with and
interacting with many
people these people include clients
Business Leaders project team members
project stakeholders vendors private
sector Representatives industry leaders
and so forth business analysts negotiate
at every turn during the course of a
project at the initial stage of a
project negotiation skills are used to
determine what should be included in the
vision of the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority as the
project progresses negotiation skills
help to determine the functional design
which fulfill the requirements technical
decisions also require negotiation
skills business analysts also perform
cost benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not business analysts
should be able to achieve a profitable
outcome for your company while finding a
solution for the client that makes them
happy this Balancing Act demands the
ability to influence a mutual solution
and maintain professional
relationship up next we have our fifth
skill that is decision
making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting their
decision or
strategy they must be having good
problem solving skills as well business
analysts should have a act to think out
of the box and find a solution to
problems majorly a business analyst
follows five major steps while making a
decision these steps are Define the
problem find and Define the alternative
approaches evaluate the alternative
approaches make the decision based on
these approaches and test and finally
implement the
solution while some may argue that the
technical team is responsible for
Designing the solution the business
analyst Still Remains instrumental in
ensuring that the design confirms to the
requirements that have been
approved now that we have reached
halfway through the skills I would like
like to ask all our viewers to please
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply
learn moving on we have another really
important business analyst skill that is
idea about programming
languages business analyst should have a
good Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial business analysts can help
solve complex Problems by writing
efficient codes both R and python have a
vast collection of libraries and
packages for data manipulation data
wrangling data visualization and data
analytics some of these libraries are
numpy pandas deer tier ggplot and
matplot lib in addition to these it is
good to understand statistical software
like SAS and SPSS using these
programming languages such as python RN
SAS you can analyze and visualize last
data sets as well as create machine
learning models for making future
business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and
dashboards a business analyst should be
proficient in using various business
intelligence tools for creating reports
and
dashboards reports created by business
analysts can be General reports such as
detail report grouped report cross tab
report column report query report data
entry report Etc or it can be dashboard
report such as visualized Report with
multi-dimensional analysis is based on
display of business indicators dashboard
reports are developed by business
analyst to solve business decision-
making problems different from the
tabular interface of the general report
the dashboard report adopts the
canvas-like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau powerbi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business
requirements now the eighth skill in our
list of skills is database and
SQL business analyst of often work with
data that is structured in nature hence
to store and process this data they
should have knowledge of relational
databases such as Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database mySQL database as well
as no SQL
databases also having hands-on
experience with SQL is a must for a
business analyst to access retrieve
manipulate and analyze data so they
should be able to write data definition
and data manipulation commands such as
create update delete and
insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth skill in
our
list Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with
data business analysts use Excel to
perform various calculations budget
analysis and data analysis to derive
meaningful insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivote
tables to summarize the data business
analysts can also create different
charts and graphs using Excel to
generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem business analysts can
use Excel to create Revenue growth
models for new products based on new
customer forecasts when planning an
editorial calendar for a website
business analysts can list out dates and
topics in a
spreadsheet when creating a budget for a
small product they can list expense
categories in a spreadsheet update it
monthly and create a chart to show how
close the product is to budget across
each category business analyst can
calculate customer discounts based on
monthly Pur purchase volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer
relationships and finally in the list of
skills we have documentation and
presentation you could have all the
industry experience in the world but if
it's paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all a
business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in concise and compact form they
should also be confident about
presenting their findings and
conclusions in front of the stakeholders
and clients organized documentation will
help you communicate technical Concepts
to non-technical employees it is
important that a business analyst notes
down all the details that they learn
from their projects this will help them
take better decisions in the future also
if similar problems Arise at a later
stage they can implement the same
solution thereby saving a lot of time
and unwanted problems while business
analysts are generally not responsible
for making decisions regarding project
Solutions decision- making skills are
still important for understanding
Gathering and presenting relevant
information to assist decision makers
with selecting the optimal solution now
let me ask you guys one interesting
question what is the primary goal of
conducting a SWAT analysis option A
identify market trends and customer
preferences option b accessing the
financial viability of a business
venture option C evaluating the internal
and external factors impacting a
business option D developing strategies
for product development and Innovations
please answer in the comment section
below and we will update the answer in
the pin comment you can also pause the
video give it a thought and answer in
the comment section now let's dive back
into our video business analysis is like
being a detective for a company it helps
a company figure out what it needs and
how to make things better business
analysis is done for all sort of things
a company wants to do whether big or
small it can be a part of specific
project or ongoing as the company grows
and improves think of it this way
business analysis helps a company
understand where it is right now where
it wants to go and how it gets there
it's like looking at a map and planning
the best route for a journey it's
important because it helps the company
make smart decision and find ways to
create value for the people involved so
if you're into solving Mysteries and
helping companies grow business analyst
might be the perfect role for you so
till now you must have gotten an idea of
what business analysis is now we will
see who is a business analyst a business
analyst is a person who performs
business analysis task described in a
bab which is the business analysis is
body of knowledge no matter their job
title or organizational role business
analysts are responsible for discovering
and analyzing information from a variety
of source with an expertise including
tools processes documentations and
stockholders now let's see what business
analysts do the activities that business
analyst perform includes business
analyst understanding Enterprise
problems and goals analyze ing needs and
solutions formulate strategies Drive
changes and facilitates stakeholders
collaboration moving ahead with the
positions that we have in the business
and let's discuss with the education and
skills needed for the career path let's
begin with discussing the typical salary
range of an entry-level business analyst
position it's important to keep in mind
that the salary figure depends on
various factors such as location
industry and Company size how however we
can provide a Jour idea of what you
might expect for entry-level business
analyst in India the salary range for
entry-level business analyst is
typically between 3 lakh to 6 lakh per
anom and in the US the salary range for
entry-level business analyst is
approximately between $50,000 to $70,000
per anom now let's see education and
Foundation First you will need to get a
bachelor degree in Business
Administration
computer science or relatable feied it's
like building a strong Foundation of
your career to boost your credentials
you can also consider getting
certifications after that sharpen your
skills acquire domain knowledge and
develop your analytical skills by
learning tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software these are like
secret weapons that will help you
analyze data and find important insights
you should also learn problem solving
methods and how the model processes it's
like becoming a problemsolving
superhero now hands-on experience to
really level up look for internships
entry-level positions or projects within
your organization this will give you a
practical experience and allows you to
contribute to the requirements Gathering
documentation and testing it's like
going on a real life mission and making
a tangible impact by following these
steps you will be well on your way to
become a skilled business analyst you
will be the hero who helps businesses
make smart decision and drive success
now let's talk about senior business
analyst salary for senior level business
analyses in India the salary range can
be between 6 lakh perom to 12 lakh perom
in the US the salary range of a senior
business analyst is typically between
$70,000 to $100,000 US per anom for
education and Foundation consider
pursuing a master degree in Business
Administration or a relatable field to
depend your knowledge and expertise
explore Advanced certification such as
certified business analyst professional
or project management professional
acquired domain knowledge continue
expanding your understanding of the
industry and its strength challenges and
emerging Technologies develop a deep
understanding of specific business
domain with the industry next analytical
skill development enhance your data
analysis capabilities by exploring
Advanced Technologies predictive
modeling and data
visualization familiarize yourself with
business intelligence tools and advanced
analytics platforms hands-on experience
take the lead on large projects and
handle critical business analysis
activities mentor and support Junior
analyst provide them with guidance and
assistance remember the key is to
continue learning G gaining practical
experience and staying up to date with
the industry Trends good luck with your
business analysis Journey after that we
have lead business analyst the salary
range of a lead business analyst in
India can vary from 12 lakh perom to 25
lakh per anom and in the US the salary
range for lead business analysts is
typically between $100,000 to
$150,000 next education and Foundation
take Advanced certification and special
Iz training in leadership and business
strategy you should also acquire domain
knowledge become an expert in your
industry by staying up toate on Trends
regularizing on new technologies next
analytical skills development is very
important develop expertise in advanced
analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence learn about
tools and Technologies for predictive
analysis and datadriven decision making
next we have business analysis
Technologies Master the art of
facilitating and negotiating in complex
stockholders engagement last hands on
experience take the lead on strategic
initiatives and large scale projects
play a significant role in shaping your
organizations business analysis
processes and
methologies everyone processes at their
own pace based on their skills
opportunities and Industry demands keep
seeking professional development take on
challenging task and build strong
relationship with the industry to
accelerate your growth as a business
analyst who is a business
analyst a business analyst is a person
who works with companies to study their
systems services and products in order
to enhance present operation and come to
profitable
judgments a business
analyst evaluates the business model and
how to integrate it with technology to
assist organization in documenting
business processes a business analyst is
responsible for processing and analyzing
the products and services to make
profitable decision to improve the
financial activities of the organization
business analyst handle all the
requirements demanded by the clients and
convey them to the product development
team now it's time to learn skills
required to become business
analyst analytical skills and critical
thinking great Achievers are great
thinkers the role of the business
analyst comes at the beginning of the
software development life cycle a
business analyst must analyze the client
requirements effectively critical
thinking helps the analyst in examining
different situations and providing a
solution communication skill every role
demands communication skill but
communication is the key for every
business analyst they are supposed to
have talk with stakeholders a good
business analyst needs to have
communication in different phases be it
with clients product development team or
the implementation team for instance if
a product needs to be implemented then
it is the duty of a business analyst to
communicate with the clients regarding
requirement clearly otherwise the entire
project May collapse as a business
analyst facilitating meeting is very
important first point to boost your
confidence if you have good
communication skill database and
SQL SQL is an important skill that every
business analyst needs to understand a
database is a software to store the data
business analyst should have hands-on
experience on SQL from which they can
fetch data from this databases so it's
better to know MySQL Oracle DB nosql or
mongod
DB programming skills it's good to know
programming languages like python or r
business analyst have to deal with lots
of data that are beyond the limits using
spreadsheets so if you know Python
programming language it helps in
analyzing the data as well as we can
easily integrate it with SQL databases
to automate
task R also works in the same way R
helps to create interactive graphs and
help in analyzing the data reports and
dashboards business dashboards are
increasingly seen to help business
analyst to produce data in an insightful
way dashboards are Consolidated with
charts and graphs on a single screen the
purpose of dashboard is to help business
analyst by allowing them to gather and
analyze the data let's say we have 10
sets of people working on a project we
have to maintain a dashboard in such a
way that it is understandable and
accessible to everyone so that everyone
can understand the growth of the project
these were some of the important skills
business analyst need to have
how to become a business analyst if you
are a fresher this is a very important
part firstly it's essential to decide
and concentrate on the fundamentals of
the business analytics understanding the
fundamentals and choosing the right path
are crucial in every field start
learning the fundamentals of business
analytics first and start mastering
it pursue the related course it's a
reminder to you to have a look at the
business analyst master program link
which is given in the description box
below you can take up a business
management course and get certified to
become industry
ready internship an internship is a
fantastic way to learn more about a
field or job you might like to pursue
internship in business analytics will
help you deal with realtime experience
working in Industry this will
automatically improve your resuming
start taking up realtime projects on
Business Development and analytics
lastly apply for a
job build a portfolio including your
practical experience the portfolio
should consider all the internships and
projects you will be qualified to apply
for a job after you get all the
experience necessary tools used by
business analyst we have covered some of
the important tools frequently used by
business analyst based on its
use project management tool jira the
collaboration tools jira and Confluence
are very practical to collaborate
effectively on projects and share
requirements every business analyst has
to be at least familiar with jira by
using platforms like jira all business
stakeholders May engage with various
teams and view the status of their
project Trello is a project management
platform businesses use for teamwork and
task organization dividing the work into
columns on a board enables you to manage
your projects and effort dividing compx
complicated projects into smaller more
manageable and reliable chunks of Labor
help simplify and standardize your work
so for this purpose Trello is very
important tool data
visualization the main use of data
visualization tools is the ability to
quickly solve business related problems
Tablo is the prime software for data
visualization it creates efficient
visualization which makes the
stakeholders understand the data more
effectively powerbi is a software
created by Microsoft that meets your
analytical and business needs service
that allows access to data even when
using third-party programs and services
for instance you can integrate it with
SQL Server you can enable python with
powerbi tool that offers customizable
visualization by including data
normalization and purification the
functionality of a desktop program can
be greatly increased using powerbi as we
we have already learned reports and
documentation is the key skill for a
business analyst to create report and
documentation we use Google Docs Google
Docs provide you with templates for
business research business analyst may
share and collaborate on documents
effectively using Google Docs with the
use of Google docs business analyst can
communicate with stakeholders about any
kind of file or
document Microsoft PowerPoint as we prev
previously discussed good presentation
skill is always counted for a business
analyst a business analyst must have
ability to present project teachings to
their stakeholders so it's necessary to
learn Microsoft PowerPoint these were
the important tools for a business
analyst to manage their work now comes
roles and responsibility played by a
business analyst in Industry a business
analyst has a variety of roles and
responsibility therefore it is crucial
to understand understand thoroughly the
roles and responsibility held by
business analyst before learning how to
become
one a business analyst pinpoints the
goals and issues of a company's business
and develops profitable
solutions they assemble stakeholders and
business requirements they help in
analyzing and evaluating business
processes an organization has and
identify the area of
improvement business analyst collaborate
with the development team to create a
plan for addressing a specific issue
they aggressively offer feedback on the
design of a software program and
integrate the newly created features
that a company needs business analyst
evaluate company's functional and
non-functional requirement different
roles performed by a business analyst
are data analyst business architect
system architect and product manager
these are the roles which are
interdependent on a business analyst
analyst in an organization so the top
companies hiring a business
analyst they are accentor IBM deloid TCS
VMware mckeny and Company we can also
include meta in this list this is the
job description provided by
exenter for a business analyst Ro key
responsibility will include working with
clients and Technical Resources to
identify their business problem and
developing the analytical solution good
knowledge and understanding of digital
application planning and managing
business diagnosis and planning
activities understanding and analyze
functional impacts on front to back
application design and document new
process and system changes performing
interpreting requirement analysis to
identify value creation opportunities
for clients on average accenter offers
$76,000 per year for a business analyst
rou now we will see job description in
IBM so what will be your responsibility
being an business analyst in IBM be part
of international teams in the design
build test run phases of customer
projects from various Industries and
interesting business domains this role
assist clients and projects in
implementation of wide range of
application and business processes
communication with business owners and
end user to Define business requirement
and with development team to ensure
deliver to the agreed standard and
quality support testing in the
resolution of defects learn and apply
processes and methodologies related
latest it Trends from both the JD we can
understand that business analyst have to
deal with clients a
lot so on an average
$84,000 per year is the salary offered
for a business analyst working in
IBM and the final part is salary of a
business analyst
analyst the average salary of a business
analyst for a fresher is $70,000 per
anom in USA and experience is
$100,000 per year at an experience level
you should be able to evaluate and
measure business Frameworks and how they
influence an organization and their
clients coming to India the average
salary of a business analyst for fresh
ranges from 8 lakh per year for
experience it can go as high as 15 lakhs
per year and more also such as the
demand for business analyst all over the
world you are prepared to begin your
career in business analytics because you
have a better understanding of what
business analyst does their roles and
responsibility and steps involved to
become one to get into the business
analysis domain we bring you topnotch
courses to become a skilled business
analyst from the best universities
around the globe so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll Now find the
course Link in the description box
postgraduate program in business
analysis by simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to equip
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as business analyst
this program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
enhance their business analytics skills
and Advance their career in the field so
this program covers various topics such
as business analyst Essentials project
management data analysis data modeling
and data visualization it also includes
Hands-On training in popular business
analyst tools such as you will see here
such as Microsoft Excel J powerbi and
many others upon completing the program
Learners will receive a certification
from Simply learn and the skills and
knowledge required to succeed as a
business analyst they will also have
access to Simply learn Career Services
which provides guidance and support to
help Learners transition into the job
market overall the postgraduate program
in business analyst by simply learn is
an excellent option for individuals who
wants to enhance their business analysis
skills and Advance their career
perspective in this field so now next we
have business analytics boot camp by
simply learn this is an intensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business Analytics the program is
delivered online and is intended for
individuals who want to understand
business analysis comprehensively and
how it can be applied to real world
business problems this program covers
various topics such as data analysis
data modeling data visualization and
predictive modeling it also includes
Hands-On training in popular analysis
tools such as R python Excel and W the
business analytics boot camp is designed
to provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in meaningful way it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insights and
recommendations to stockholder
effectively upon completion of the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
in the business analyst role access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
now let's see more about the business
analyst Masters program this Masters
program by simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to
provide Learners with a deep
understanding of business analysis the
program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
advance their career prospectus in the
field of business analysis the program
covers various topics such as business
analysis Essentials project management
data analysis data modeling and data
visualization it also includes Hands-On
training in the popular business
analysis tools such as Microsoft Excel
Microsoft powerbi R and python numpy
scii the business analyst master program
is designed to provide Learners with the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
as a business analyst it also focuses on
developing the necessary skills to
effectively communicate with stack
holder manage projects and analyze data
upon completing the program now leers
will also get the certification and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
in the business analysis role which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
the link will be in the description box
for all the courses next we have simply
learns business analytics for strategic
decision- making certification program
which is designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business analysis and how it can be
applied in the real world business
problems
the program is delivered online as an
intended for individuals who want to
understand business analyst
comprehensively and Advance their career
this program is delivered by Indian
Institute of Technology lki this program
covers various topics such as strategic
analysis data modeling data
visualization predictive modeling and it
also includes Hands-On training in
popular analysis tools such as again
Microsoft Excel R and W the business
analysis for stattic decision- making
certification program is designed to
provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in a meaningful way it
also focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insight and
recommendations to stack holder
effectively upon completing of the
program the learner will get the
certification by IAT Rudy and simply
learn they will also have the access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
the link will be in the description box
for this course also now we have simply
learns postgraduate program in business
analytics in a comprehensive program
designed to provide Learners with a deep
understanding of business analytics the
program is delivered entirely online and
is intended for individuals who want to
advance their career in the field of
business analytics the program covers a
range of topics such as statical
analysis data modeling data
visualization
machine learning and big data so this
program is sponsored by Purdue
University and you will get the
certification from IBM this program
covers a range of topics such as
statical analysis data modeling data
visualization machine learning and Big
Data it also includes Hands-On training
in popular analysis tools such as
Microsoft Excel R programming Python and
tblo the postgraduate program in
business analyst is designed to provide
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst or data scientist it focuses on
developing the necessary skills to
effectively communicate insights and
recommendations to stack holders manage
projects and analyze large volume of
data upon completion of the program
Learners will receive a post-graduate
program in data analysis certification
from Simply learn and the skills and
knowledge required to succeed as a
business analytics or data science role
they will also have access to Simply
learn Career Services which provides
guidance and support to Learners
transition into the job market so what
is project management now as defined in
pmis PMB project management is
application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to project activities to
meet project requirements so every
project will have an objective to
accomplish similarly the objective of
project management is to make the final
deliverables in a finite time and budget
this involves having clear understanding
about about the deliverables of the
project required resources for the
project resource in terms of Human
Resources Technical Resources Financial
Resources Etc project manager should
have a full picture of those aspects we
can call it as constraints or aspects
and manage those throughout the Project
Life Cycle for which a project manager
should have a full view about a project
and what is that this project has to
accomplish that objective should be
clear so as part of project management
the six straints which project manager
should look at are scope time quality
cost risk and resources so each of these
areas has very important role to play in
project management the clarity in scope
the clarity in terms of schedule within
which the project has to be delivered
the cost what it incurs to that
particular project once it is finalized
one cannot vary when cannot change
without any proper approvals similar to
that we have quality management which
has to ensure the score hope the
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organization so organization
should assess the risk associated with
the project and similarly as project
progresses various different risks has
to be identified like Risk related to
project management risk related to
technology area risk related to
resources risk related to financial
things so broadly risk management plays
a very important role so there will be
something called contingency reserve
kept for a identified risk above the
cost what is estimated for various
deliverables from the project so every
project require resources resources may
be in terms of Human Resources Financial
Resources technology resources
environmental resources so all these
resources are used to produce the output
of the project so these resources has to
be managed with the sufficient
optimization and standardization
required now let us understand the
definition of a project so what is a
project PMI defines a project as a
temporary endow undertaken to create a
unique product service or result the
temporary nature of a project indicates
that a project has a definite beginning
and end so when I say product unique
product it means every output it may be
similar products you are producing with
the same features and functionality but
the output of every project is unique
because it is unique in terms of all the
six constraints what we just discussed
now now when I say product it is very
easy for us to visualize it may be a
desktop it may be a laptop it may be a
car it may be a machine Etc but how do I
visualize a service now project output
is a service now it is it's about
building a capability a project by
through a project a capability can be
built to ensure Services can be provided
that's what the output of project is
service for example if I think about a
taxi services for providing a taxes
services I need a mobile app I need taxi
I need a server I need a data center so
all these are various different products
and services here service example can be
internet service so combination of all
the services and products builds the
capability for an organizations who can
provide the taxes services so building
that capability we say it is an output
of a particular project which is called
service similarly results can be
Improvement of something Improvement in
customer satisfaction increase in um
some specific objectives or specific
results need to be achieved in
performance perspective so output of
every project will be unique product or
a service or a result this we need to
clearly understand so when we say there
is a definite beginning and end every
project starts at certain point in time
and ends at certain point in time so it
has a definite beginning and end that is
the reason it is temporary in nature it
is not an ongoing business activity
right so so every project will have a
life cycle a beginning and end so when
it starts till end until the result or a
service or a product which comes as an
output of a project project life cycle
is not ended so interestingly in a
product life cycle or in a service life
cycle you come across many project life
cycles so one Project Life Cycle means
one project is initiated to introduce a
product or Services next project or uh
initiated would be to enhance the
capability of a service or a product
next project initiated after some time
is to optimize something similarly at
the end of the product life cycle
project is initiated to retire that
product or services so in a given
product life cycle there may be multiple
Project Life Cycle so what is involved
in the Project Life Cycle it involves
five areas five groups we can call it as
so initiation planning execution
monitoring and closure so when I say
initiation it's all about understanding
what is Project giving the basic
understanding of the project collating
the details and having key stakeholders
identified once that is done one will
move towards planning so here in the
initiation it is very clearly one has to
understand is Project is worth while of
doing so one has to check the
feasibility one has to measure that
particular investment is making sense
and then confirm yes it makes sense to
invest now next planning as we have a
basic understanding of yes this project
has to be done and a discussion with the
key stakeholders have happened now that
moves towards planning now in planning
one will understand the project in
entirety if it is a waterfall approach
one has to have a clear articulation of
entire project a comprehensive details
holistic approach now if you go if
you're going in a project in a agile way
of approach now in this planning you may
have a big skeleton as you go in each of
the iteration you may go deep dive into
detailed planning if it is a agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear Insight towards what needs to be
done in this project how it has to be
done and what are the results which can
be achieved out of that particular
project so this involves making that
clear blueprint of an project objectives
what we are supposed to achieve so this
will become a reference point throughout
the Project Life Cycle then execution as
you have a blueprint of the project as
the direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and execute the
project executing the sense
implementation acquiring resources and
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the deliverables as required you
acquire resources you configure resource
you ensure right resources are acquired
if it is human resource one has to
educate that human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to provide that assignment in
such a way that skills of that
individuals what they should have is
acquired by those individual ual so that
deliverables can happen and they needs
to be managed the entire team need to be
managed for that a clear structure has
to be created similarly when you do
technology resource perspective those
components has to be tested configured
then integrated again tested for and
check the performances so Collective
action of this results in a deliverable
during the execution so as the
deliverables are happening in the
execution it is quite obvious project
manager has to monitor review control
that particular deliverable and also the
processes tools resources used during
the project even those needs to be
monitored so that they are complying to
the defined processes so during
monitoring there may be a deviation one
can found during monitoring there may be
the project is running the way it is
required so in this monitoring phase it
involves an action from project manager
to Monitor and control the work of the
project so comparing with the blueprint
of plan what is accomplished what is
created during the planning uh phase of
this project and as the execution
happens monitoring and control is
monitoring it and checking is that
activities what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of a projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project
deliverables needs to be accomplished
within the cost what is budgeted for the
project so during the project you
project manager may find there are
certain deviations which are occurred
there are additional challenges which
has come in so for this reason one has
to ensure continued monitoring as the
execution happens and identify those
deviation and ensure Whenever there is a
deviation there is a correction Whenever
there is an additional things coming in
that needs to be considered carefully
whether that need to be involved as part
of this deliverable or should be taken
it separately so this requires lot of
conversation with all the stakeholders
of the project during the entire Project
Life Cycle especially during planning
execution monitoring and control since
they are not the one which is happening
in sequence so planning can also come
back again where there is something
which you may require to modify so may
require to have a change in the
blueprint Itself by adding that new
change which is coming in so you go back
to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand
inand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed similarly all the
process work instructions all those
templates what is given are used one is
complying to those requirement it is
very important and project is done
within the scope schedule and time and
the quality metrics defined then as the
completion of the project happens as the
monitoring and control says yes
deliverable has happened according to
the requirement then the project moves
to the closure the closure may be
closure of a specific project phase a
milestone deliverable or a phasal
deliverable or it can be a deliverable
at the end of the project which is the
ultimate deliverable so processes in
closing has to be triggered Whenever
there is end of the phase Whenever there
is a deliverable to conclude and also at
the end of the project to conclude the
entire project so during the closure one
has to ensure capturing all the details
in terms of what is accomplished against
what is Def Point what went wrong what
went well what is a learning one has to
take to the next level or to next phase
or to the next project and at the same
time a sign off has to be obtained
formally and everything should be
summarized and have a good handshake
with the project stakeholder mainly a
business or customer and also
disseminating of Team means you will
dismantle the entire team and send them
back to their specific units or
specialization and they may get assigned
to new project or if it is a functional
they can go back to their functions to
do do their functional activities so
that was about entire Project Life Cycle
what happens now while doing this I
mentioned there are six constraints that
is scope schedule cost quality risk and
resources so keeping these in mind one
has to ensure project is successful in
all aspects so to become successful
there are few key areas which has to be
looked at so first six key areas are
scope schedule cost quality resources
and stakeholders now let let's look at
the scope what does scope means scope is
about what needs to be delivered what is
in scope what is out of the scope so
this refers to all those deliverable
scope all those activity scope basically
we speak about two things one is product
scope and project scope product scope is
all about ensuring the features
functionality of products are well
defined and understood and signed off
and while delivering that product that
is tested against those defined features
and functionalities whereas project
scope focus on all the activities needs
to be done all those templates which has
to be used all the process which has to
be complied with all the skills which is
required to be applied so it is going as
defined so by doing this activities
which is defined as part of project
scope the result the deliverable will
come out which will be in line with the
deliverables features and functionality
which is defined as part of product
scope it is very important to ensure
entire projects happens within this
particular scope there should not be any
deviations from this schedule perspect
itive for that specifications what we
defined for a product and project so
these needs to be done in a specific
point in time means in a specific
schedule there will be start time end
time right so one has to plan how long a
project would take and what are the
deliverable should happen in what
sequence what activities are required to
accomplish this so all these needs to be
understood so while performing the
schedule management one has to look at a
specific deliverable at a specific point
in time by applying a specific set of
activities required so this will tell
you the duration of the project this
will provide you the sequence of project
this will also help you to understand
the dependency between one task to
another task this will also help you to
understand how the deliverables
happening in what sequence which helps
him prioritizing your deliverables third
is cost so as we know to do any project
it is very essential to ensure project
happens within that budget so project
cost is estimated initially then that
estimated cost will be checked checked
in terms of is the assumptions
considerations are right or wrong is
that really so much of monetary resource
are required for the project and then
after understanding the justification
and obtaining the clarity budget is I
mean monetary resources are allocated
and confirmed approved then it will
become a budget that will be a cost
Baseline so these estimation allocation
of budget once it happens that will
become a base and any deviations from
that cannot happen so easily so any
deviations because of additional of
scope that can be handled through change
management but idealistic scenario the
cost should not escalate or come down
organization can also set certain
tolerances at the project level
considering various different scenarios
like scenario of risks scenario of
something which deviated from the
deliverable so to what extent it can
deviate that tolerance will also be set
at the economic or monetary value
perspective that is about cost now
quality as we know quality is a very
important area which ensures the project
is delivered in time with all the
specifications defined by using all the
methods means by following all the
processes work instructions templates
and delivering as needed where it
enables the project to monitor it easily
so basically the requirement of uh
compliance and standardization and
optimization is to ensure everyone
follows the same same steps do the
activity so what quality management
focus is to ensure the intended
objectives of a projects are achieved
already there is a definition done in
terms of various different practices or
processes needs to be followed similarly
specification of each of the products
are defined and from that there should
not be any deviation so quality
management should focus on ensuring
those activities are done as defined
those deliverables are done according to
the specifications what is different it
is very important that way so for that
there is a layer of quality man there
should be a layer of quality management
where auditing or control activities are
initiated periodically so that any
deviations can be seen easily and
remember a project manager can become
cannot become part of quality management
like project manager cannot audit
project manager should have an team or
take the help of a team who can able to
do mostly the one which is who is not
part of the project is always better
resources now as I mentioned earlier
every project need resources ources it
may be human resources it may be
technology resources it may be any other
resources which are required to do the
project so organization acquires
resources configured and then deployed
for example in the project you acquire a
server you configure a server you deploy
a server technology resource human
resource is onboarded recruited project
induction is given then at the same time
the skills and capabilities of
individuals are according to the
requirement of project that needs to be
ensured and what needs to be delivered
and how it has to be delivered should be
clear to the particular human resource
so looking at all the aspects of
resources to acquire to build and manage
it is very important to look at the
resource management so this will help in
carrying out a specific task in the
project in the best possible manner so
interestingly when I a human resource
always there is a possibility that a
conflict can occur so when I say
conflict conflict of interest maybe in
terms of what the that individuals has
to do conflict in terms of the
preferences in terms of solutions what
they're looking at conflict in terms of
using resources different opinions
different preferences various reasons
conflict can come across so it is very
important to project manager to
understand this dynamics of human
resources and manage those conflicts
project manager cannot shy away from
handling conflicts project manager has
to hone and resolve those conflicts in
the favor of project not in the favor of
any individuals so there are various
techniques to look at uh resolving
conflicts so that is like compromising
problem solving smoothening
accommodating so whichever helps for
that project scenario for the project
objectives that needs to be applied that
technique has to be taken up so here the
resolution is not at the specific
individuals preference it is with the
objective of whether projects has any
impact what kind of impact positive or
negative if it is negative no that's not
the direction the direction should be
ensuring project gets that value through
the this conflict resolution so project
manager should own it it's an
accountability of a project manager then
as the human resource are acquired there
are five stages Team Dynamics are
involved so one has to bring them then
educate them about a project as a
education on the project happens one has
to go and do the job on floor that needs
to be observed means one has to manage
by looking at it and uh any corrections
needs to be done that needs to be guided
so it is very Dynamic thing when it
comes to Human resources similarly in
technology resources standardization
there is no ambiguity as such but right
Resources with the right configurations
should be acquired that is very
important the next stakeholders so who
can be stakeholders every project will
have a stakeholder who are internal and
external to the project so the internal
stakeholders are those who are part of
the project who are part of the um
organization or are part of the customer
organization or part of supplier
organization a computation into my
business means my organization's
business all this we can call it as a
stakeholders now every stakeholders will
have a specific interest a power an
ability to influence so through their
position through their distance from the
project they will get impacted at the
same time they will also impact the
project similarly they influence and
they get influenced because of the
project so a project manager should
identify all the stakeholders and
understand this what is the kind of
stakeholder is this in terms of power in
terms of legitimacy in terms of
influence in terms of impact after
understanding that there should be a
strategy for handling the stakeholders
how am I going to engage with these
stakeholders it is very important and
accordingly the engagement should happen
and then stakeholder engagement should
resolve in the favor of projects again
so if it is a customer customer should
get the inputs required through review
or periodic updates and the engagement
required with the customer so that
customer is having up to date
information about the project if it is a
team continued monitoring and control
and ensuring team delivers the results
what is required so focus of a
stakeholder should be in such a way that
your strategy should enable project to
become successful and get a proper
response from the stakeholder means a
supporting engagement so next few key
Focus areas to mention is communication
risk procurement critical success
factors deliverables and work breakdown
so this list is not exhaustive as we
deep into project I think you can just
keep listing the key Focus areas more
than this but whatever we have indicated
are the minimum which needs to be looked
at so when I say communication
communication is basically a
conversation exchange of message which
happens between two entities now
whenever we communicate it is necessary
to understand that it has to happen with
two individuals or two entities there
should be sender there should be
receiver in the absence of receiver if
sending is happening that communication
doesn't make any any sense there should
be a receiver and there should be an
acknowledgement from the receiver now
this is one of the most ignored area in
many of the projects even the
communication happens more often more
frequently but what people face
difficulty in realizing that as they
communicate generally informally
formally they just take those for
granted now when you identify the
stakeholder one has to understand what
is the communication requirement for
those stakeholders what is that
communication why is that communication
what is the content of that
communication how frequently we should
do that interactions or Communications
intent of that particular communication
what is the expected action or response
from that communication all this needs
to be very very clear and this can be
articulated it has to be articulated so
when it is articulated once there is a
picture in terms of what kind of
communication has to happen it is quite
obvious there should not be any
deviation from the agreed Communications
requirements and whenever there is a
need of change to the communication
requirements from the stakeholders that
needs to be updated for this one has to
have a stakeholders identified so
stakeholder management and communication
are very closely linked and Associated a
engagement with the stakeholder will
become successful with an effective
communication approaches next is risk so
every project which is undertaken by
organization that will have certain
amount of risk which organization will
evaluate similarly within the Project
Life Cycle lot of risk comes up which
would have certain impact to the project
now risk refers to by definition an
uncertain event it has an uncertainty an
event which is uncertain and when it
occurs it will have an impact on the
project positively or negatively now
current scenario in everywhere the
projects What You observe closely people
tend to look at the risk which are
threats that is negative only but they
fail to recognize the risks which are
opportunities the positive risks so
another gap which we see when do the
risk management is that that is done in
the initial phase of the project as the
project is kicked off someone will do uh
the risk assessment have a list of risk
identified but unfortunately there is no
categorizations for that risk and how is
that going to impact the project that is
not clear thirdly risk management or
list of risk are created only once it is
not done repeatedly so risk
identification and Analysis and
assessment of that risk has to be done
throughout the life cycle of a project
reason being the risk which looks as a
high impact when project is initiated as
the project progresses the impact levels
will vary maybe in the mid middle of the
project the impact may be very high or
low so likewise the impacts of the risk
will vary throughout the Project Life
Cycle it may be positive it may be
negative so as you identify the
stakeholder throughout the Project Life
Cycle as I said that is also a dynamic I
cannot just have a list of stakeholders
and I keep it as it is I need to update
that also regularly risk identification
assessment and Analysis should also be
done Reg regularly periodically so that
one will have a clear understanding
about is that risk still valid is that
risk is there still or not what is the
level of variations in terms of impact
of the risks so this Clarity will be
there so that necess organization or
project manager can get ready to face
those risk if it is a negative risk
definitely you should have a mitigation
or avoidance or acceptance whatever the
mitigation plan you have to eliminate
the negative impact of the risk when it
occurs if it is a pro positive risk is
quite obvious one has to take the
advantage of that one has to enance
exploit share a positive risk so that
organization is benefited further
procurement so whenever a project is
initiated whenever a project is taken up
the organization who is doing the
project cannot create everything cannot
develop everything in that Project Life
Cycle so organization would take a
decision make a decision stating that
some of the deliverables we make
ourselves some of the products we make
ourselves some of the products we
purchase some of the services we
purchase so to purchase that has to
happen from a specific supplier you
cannot go with every supplier you should
evaluate those suppliers qualify the
suppliers and then select on board the
supplier and then get the services or
products supplied by that particular
supplier so while doing this one has to
understand what type of Contracting they
need to enter with so three types of
contracts we speak basically one is
about uh uh Cost Plus contract where
cost is fully known to the project
manager and to the organization so apart
from known cost a fe will be paid to the
supplier another one is fixed price
where project manager or the
organization who is awarding that
contract to A supplier will not know
what is the cost instead it is a fixed
price but important here is the scope of
work needs to be clearly articulated and
defined another type of Contracting can
be time and material where the building
will happen based on the amount of time
one is spent spent on that particular
hire a resource or onboard a resource on
a time and material basis and what is
that effort that resource has been put
based on that billing will happen so
three types of contracts depending on
the different scenarios of the project
will be signed with the contractor
however before doing that it is very
essential to identify those suppliers
sign off with them and monitor and
manage them so if deliverables are not
there it is very essential to look at
the uh termination one has to terminate
otherwise one has to ensure instead of
uh terminating should be able to put
some effort to educate them also so that
they come up to the mark So project is
benefited so depending on what needs to
be done that call has to be taken on a
regular basis then critical success
factor so for every project there should
be an articulation of critical success
factor So based on that one can confirm
yes project has achieved his objectives
or project has not achieved his
objectives so key critical success
factor should be supported through the
metrics key performance indicators so
key performance indicators provide those
metrics to say critical success factor
is achieved for example if you want to
become successful in an exam critical
success factor is scoring or passing the
examination or uh let me say to pass the
examination key performance indicator is
scoring 60% and above so critical
success factor for me to get promoted is
to pass in this particular exam so to
pass in this exam minimum I should score
is 60% that is kpi passing in the exam
that is critical success factor so how
will I measure that success factor is
kpi so every project which it produces a
specific product or Services by using a
specific resources and each of these the
resources the processes the templates
the deliverables all these needs to be
measured on a continual basis so there
are critical success factors defined and
those are measured by defining kpis to
that critical success factors so
basically critical success factor
provides the Insight towards what needs
to be measured and when you measure what
should be the focus and to achieve those
critical success factors the indicator
is key performance indicators when you
measure yes the moment you achieve that
your CSF is achieved next deliverables
so deliverables are those which comes as
an output of the project right it may be
a product it may be a service it may be
a result so this refers to the output
within the scope of a project so there
can be one or more deliverables within a
single project so these deliverables
maybe the items that are to be sent
externally to a customer or a
stakeholder so every deliverable will
have a defined scope will have a defined
specification so those deliverables has
to be measured tested and one has to
confirm yes this deliverable is
performing as we are intended to have
the performance accordingly the decision
will happen should we accept this
particular deliverable or not if there
any deviation that has to go back for
correction so that's the reason we have
monitoring and control all the control
processes like control quality focused
on the product straight whether it has
achieved that results or not is that
functional as needed or not one has to
ensure these deliverables has all those
features and functionalities only then
that can be handed over to the
respective stakeholder customer or
operation whoever the stakeholder it is
next is work breakdown structure so when
we say work breakdown structure when I
look at a specific piece of product or
services and have a bigger picture I
cannot even visualize the various
different components various different
actions involved in achieving that
bigger deliverable so if I say a car so
I can think of a body external I can
think of a mirror on that body I can
think of a glass in the front side as
well as the back side and also I can
think of Interiors like seat then
accelerator steering dashboard all this
I can visualize but since I'm not a
technology expert relating to car can I
visualize all those parts which are
working inside for car to move like in
engine the battery assembly I don't know
what to say further so all these can be
visualized by an expert so every product
or Services should be broken down into
multiple pieces I'm not saying go and
break that product I'm saying that
product will have multiple components
which are involved those needs to be
segregated for example if I say cars
exteriors cars interior so cars
exteriors external items you can see
whatever visualize body body structure
mirror mirror assembly uh headlights uh
then tires so likewise whatever I can uh
visualize I will make it as a line items
under the exterior so under for example
under a mirror mirror I can speak about
mirror glass mirror cap mirror pedestal
and mirror assembly where it moves where
you can move the mirror so these are the
various components involved in the
mirror so I need to ensure by breaking
down the product into multiple levels
but depose decomposing it to multiple
levels I can able to visualize the
product very clearly what is there in
detail so once I have the details I will
articulate those what is that particular
work breakdown element is product
breakdown element is then I will look at
what skills and capabilities required
for the product and I will assign the
resources accordingly so once activities
resources everything is assigned
automatically this will become a work
breakdown structure further after
creating a work breakdown structure one
will go and sequence the activity look
at sequencing will happen based on in
what period prity deliverable should
happen What order deliverable should
happen then once the sequencing is done
it will be checked to see whether
anything can be optimized anything can
be um done in such a way that smooth
flow of the project can happen there is
no dependencies which will make project
to delay like as the flow happens
smoothly so you would find the various
techniques like critical path method
Network diagramming critical chain
method so all these are used the floats
of an activities are checked then leads
and lags of the activities the
relationship between the activities so
accordingly full visualization in terms
of how the project will flow and how in
what order the deliverables are
happening can be easily visualized so
that is the reason first activity is to
do the product breakdown which would
result in work breakdown structure so
those are the points till now whatever I
mentioned are the basic understanding
one should have about a project and
project management so as you deep dive
into various best practices like PMP by
P PMI Prince 2 by axelos scrum Master
agile scrum Master similarly you have
certified scrum master so many agile
practices so when you look at any of the
best practices that will tell you
clearly articulate what should be the
practice for you to adopt and adapt that
practices so that your project can
become successful so any of those
approach you touch upon all those refers
to these basic things in the absence of
this basic things none of those best
practices discusses the project
management now typically in the industry
there are lot of job roles to the
project management which we have seen so
based on that this information is
captured here on various job rules in a
project management so some of them are
like project manager senior project
manager Project Lead resource manager
pmo that is project management office
analyst steering committee member so not
necessarily all the project management
roles are limited to this so these are
the roles which commonly you see and we
are trying to capture that to give the
ins s right when I say project manager
the project manager is the owner one has
to take an accountability for the
project right so project managers takes
the project according to the plan and
plays a lead role in all the steps of
the project management right so
responsibilities should be managing
reviewing and prioritizing the task
wherever necessary looking after risk
management stakeholder management and
project communication management some of
the uh salary what we found while we
were uh doing the survey the success
ratio of a project depends majorly on
the project manager so the demand for
project manager is rapidly increasing in
the market so accordingly uh
7,474 per year that is a USD in INR it
is 1,500,000 so this is what the salary
on an approximation what was found next
role we look at senior project manager
where senior project manager is the head
of the overall project management plan
the role demands in-depth knowledge of
all the project aspects on a specific on
the specifics of the project the
responsibilities would be planning and
coordinating complex projects visiting
project sites to check progress and
handle complex issues so salary looks
like
$114,000 per year year
292,000 INR per year so the role of
senior project manager is one of the
highest paying roles in the industry as
we have seen having several allowances
and bonuses because of the criticality
involved in that project and the
accountability level of that particular
individuals in the organization next
role Project Lead so project leads are
the one who leads the people throughout
the project and provide them with all
the information required throughout so
responsibilities involve motivating the
team beneit taking care of their needs
and paying attention to what they feel
ordering or controlling the project team
since the project lead has more freedom
than the project manager salary Project
Lead makes sure that project gives the
best possible outcome and is hence the
demand for the project lead in a company
never reduces so in US USD 82,000 per
year whereas in INR it is 1, 269,000 per
year next role we look at on resource
manager so resource manager is the human
resource needed to make the project
success right so one has to manage those
resources responsibility involved
assigning the right people to the right
projects at the right time managing
employees currently and determining
hiring needs depending on the projects
requirements so salary would be around
64,000 USD which comes around
96679 in INR project management office
analyst for this role the project
management office analyst works with pmo
means project management office and does
not look at the project or manage the
project directly instead does most of
the data driven work which required for
a project to uh have or project to get
supported by that so that project
managers will have better Insight
analyzing and interpreting the data
concerning the project figuring out the
future risks to the project Pro finding
new ways to advance the idea of the
project management so salary would be 10
6,253 per year in USD whereas
449 337 in INR per year so steering
committee member so the steering
committee members are the members who do
not work on the projects they are there
to help the project manager like
providing inputs during the development
of a project advising on the budget and
evaluating the project strategies taking
regular Fe feedbacks from the project
managers and asking necessary questions
so salary would be around $
68,4 per year so those were the various
roles and that is not that list is not
an exhaustive list various different
roles we come across but these are the
basic roles which is seen in the
industry these roles are being recruited
now there are various project management
certifications which are offered as I
mentioned earlier so those
certifications are PMP that is project
management professional from PMI aile
certified practitioner that is PMI ACP
again from PMI then certified associate
in project management so difference
between capm and PMP is like CM would
act as a basic level of certification
for those who does not have a sufficient
project experience project management
experience whereas PMP is for those who
has some project management experience
similarly PMP is the one who is aspiring
to look at agility in project management
and they can go for it certified scrum
Master yes it is a scrum master
certificate which will explain the role
of a scrum master in detail similarly
prints to a certification from axelos
which also speak about all the aspects
of the project what we discussed and
provides the framework for project
management Aela also provides print to
certification in agile also agile print
to certification so we will look at each
one of this certain details which are
required for us to know so project
management professional as I mentioned
is most acknowledged and value the
certificate value what it carries which
has resulted to the certified
Professionals in landing up in highest
speed jobs in the world so certified
managers gets 20% more salary than the
average salary so to take up an
examination one has to go through the
formal training of 35 hours that is one
of the prerequisites and there should be
some experience of 4500 hours of project
managing project by Leading various
activities of a project and once the
person person becomes eligible with that
prerequisites person will become
register in the pmis website becomes
member and then go for examination so
examination fee for PMP would be $45 for
the members who are registered with PMI
and for those who are not registered as
a member with PMI it is $555 the
duration of the examination is 4 hours
and the number of questions will be 200
which are multiple choice questions so
each each questions carries one marks
there is no negative scoring now
prerequisites one has to have
4,500 hours directing and leading the
projects that experience has to be
filled in while filling the application
if a person is a bachelor degree holder
and along with that 35 contact Arts of
PM PM education now prerequisites for um
the one who is not a graduate who may be
high school or diploma is 7500 hours of
directing and leading projects 35 hours
of PM education so those are the
prerequisites before one will go and
appear for examination so once an
individual passes PMP examination that
certificate is valid for 3 years so now
after 3 years if the person aspires to
keep the certificate continued they need
to produce 60 pdus professional
development units which has to be
acquired during those 3 years how to
acquire one has to go through additional
learning one has to contribute towards
project management knowledge base so
those needs to be evidenced and then
renewal fee has to be paid and
certificate has to be renewed then agile
certified practitioner as we saw for PMP
here agile certified practitioner
demonstrates that one has relevant
experience and education to handle and
Lead agile projects the organization has
started shifting towards agile as we
know in today's uh industry which makes
this certification fast growing in the
world so examination fee would be $435
for PMI members $495 for non PMI members
duration is 3 hours and multiple choice
questions 120 questions prerequisites is
2 2,000 hours project management
experience with 1,500 hours agile
experience and 21 contact hours of agile
practices so maintenance 30 PDS are
required for every 3 years and after
paying the renewal fee that can be
renewed now certified associate in
project management so here this is an
entry-level certificate of PMI
especially for those people who has less
project experience it intends to
demonstrate fundamental knowledge
terminologies and processes of effective
project manag agement so examination fee
would be do2 225 for PMI members whereas
$300 for non-members of PMI so duration
of examination is 3 hours and
examination will have 150 multiple
choice questions so prerequisites
someone who has secondary diploma with
23 contact hours of PM education is
enough there is no experience of doing
the project is required as we sign PMP
so maintenance is again 3 years someone
who need to continue the certification
has to retake the examination every 3
years next certified scrum master so
certified scrum Master is an entry-level
certification that helps the
professionals to begin as the scrum
practitioners is one of the most sort of
certifications as other after this one
can get the designation of certified
scrum Master which is offered by scrum
Alliance so examination fee which will
change time to time which is not
revealed so one has to approach the
training organization where they will
get trained on certified scrum master so
duration of examination is 60 minutes
and pattern would be 16 hours 2 days of
training and 50 multiple choice
questions after that particular two days
of train then prerequisite is done for
maintaining this credentials so one has
to ensure it has renewed every 2 years
then projects in controlled environment
that is Prince 2 so Prince 2 is a method
which is effective mostly from the base
of UK all the organizations who are from
UK region prefers to have prin to
certific ification and it is as popular
as any other project management
certifications like PMP so examination
fee would vary from $900 to $1,000
depending on where exactly you're taking
the examination and certification will
happen at two levels one is at
Foundation level and other one is
practitioner so in Foundation it is 60
Questions multiple choice and in
practitioner it 68 questions now 60
questions or 68 questions each carries
one marks for correct answer any wrong
answer there will not be any negative
scoring one has to score 55% to clear
the examination so prerequisites for
Prince to Foundation is none whereas
Prince 2 Foundation is a prerequisite
for prince2 practitioner examination so
to maintain the certificate one has to
achieve 20 cpds every year continued
professional
development what is
jir J is an agile project management
tool used for project management bug
tracking issue tracking and automate
workflow it is also the solution that
provide Concepts and solution to the
entire
team the clients allowing for
collaborations and transparency it is an
incident management tool and a platform
independent tool that can run on any
platform or operating system and also in
a multilingual tool so now we will see
how does J
work if we look into the work process of
chir then it permit us to organize the
task and other priorities constructing a
well organized workflow in different
management the workflow includes review
and approval steps and multiple
resolutions
possibilities going through this
workflow we can create a subtask
customize task manage activities set due
dates reminders task Recycling and
determine what types of project this
help gather contextual data or
information regarding the task the track
and the process report and Tackle all
the books and release it when
approved after understanding how J works
we will see its component along with its
uses what is a component in terms of
project
management a project subdivisions are
called components these subdivisions are
applied to break down problems into
manageable chunks within a project which
later helps to generate good reports
that is collecting useful statistic and
grouping data
contextually as we know that chir
components are very helpful and most
software project team use these
components and also big companies might
use J components more often to manage
their data steam because larger data
sets are more difficult to track the
project manager put a lot of effort
behind to ensure no task is
overlooked and that reports are prepared
prepared for action but as team
expent the project becomes more
complicated when it's become too easy
for things to slide through the cracks
have issue and have created
problems to overcome all these the team
uses Chira components to track issue
software bugs and individual work this J
component helps to organize these issue
based on functionality features
customers and departments let's take a
look at another example let's take an
over as an
example Suppose there are three
subcomponents of projects a driver's app
a customers's app and a food delivery
app and under your food delivery app
project you have got like order Meal
special offer and food Combos and so on
how will you track all this information
across different projects this is done
by com
components next we will discuss jira
concept jira works on following three
concept project issue and
workflow the first one is Project it is
a collection of issues you can use a j
project with your team to coordinate and
improve the development of a product by
tracking the project managing the help
desk and more depending on the
requirements of your need it can be
processed and conf according to your and
your team's
need and the second one is issue as we
already know J is a tool used in project
management and also uses issue to track
all the task according to your team and
how your team uses G the issue can be
represented as a project the task user
requirements detection of software bugs
and enhancement of the
project the next one is workflow jira
has built in workflows and it is used to
track the life cycle of an issue where
it tracks a set of status and
transformation that an issue moves
throughout the process and typically
represent a process within your
organization and lastly let's take a
look at features of CHA
software so the first one is
authentication users are authenticated
against the active directory remember me
provides automatic login when the user
visit J
software it helps in quick access to the
software the next one is
dashboard users can have more than one
dashboard on the main page showing
Dynamic information presented in text or
Graphics a team can share a dashboard to
track the
progress
it helps an immediate access to
meaningful mattress that are used to
track the health of a project or
application and to manage resource
workloads next is
workflow it defines a cycle of an issue
with validation first it will open then
it will go in
progress and it will resolve then it
will close if it is not resolved it will
go to reopen and to the progress
the next one is they can be shared by
several projects and can be
unique it can be simple and sometimes
quite complex
too the next one is issue
searching this will allow you to find an
issue in which you are
interested it gives better transparency
so that everyone can see what is being
done and the progress that is being
made the next one is time
tracking this feature allows for the
import and monitoring of actual and
estimate time span on an
activity it will allow more effective
management of rese sources and many
more next is Project
Administration the control the access to
the data and who can access it and what
should be
accessed they can also control who can
view and addit issue handle locally
without system administration
involvement and the last one is road
maps a road maps allow you to create a
clear version of the product you are
developing and can use to find what
needs to be done and when problems are
expected to be fixed if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more so
let's get started with that lassan
website and we will create an account
the first thing Z will ask you to log in
your email ID with your unique name
there should be a site name and you can
provide any name and it should be
unique or after writing any name
suppose it should be unique and just
after that you have to agree so next
page is this here J will ask you whether
you are new to this or you are
experienced with suppose you're new to
it and your agile methodology is new to
it and suppose we spend our time on
working on features and it is flexible
schedule to finish up but now
next so for our project we are going to
use scrum template so we will change the
template
first then this
scrum use
template and we'll use team manage
project CU is it it's free let's take a
name for our project let's suppose
here
sample and here J also assign a key to
your project that is
JS this key can be used to refer your
any project so let's create the
project you're also having so many
options for in integrating your G
experience with other platform but uh
let for for now let's take
uh just skip
this here is a first thing we need to do
is first we will create an appic so let
us enable the
appic yeah this is known as appic panel
right now over here at the left down you
can see and you can give it an epic name
for this project um I want you to use an
example of
favorite where I could store and view my
products so let us give the name
as a
favorite so now that we have created the
appic we can I can use this drop down
menu to view the
details so first view all
details that it make it little
big okay over here you can add a
description we can also add
comments and we can add
stories so let us see how to do that at
first you can click add add a CLI sorry
you click add a child
issue so here you can uh specify what
kind of issue you want to create like
any story task or bger
Etc so for first story let us say that
we wants to save our products so in our
favorite list so we want to write here
here product and we will create it right
right let us also add another story for
sharing the favorite
so so
here
favorite and then we will
created so now we have created our two
stories now we will close this section
and we can view our stories in the back
and now next step is to create a Sprint
so
very simple all we have to do is to
trag this
backlog and the next
one and we have
to start
sprinting and it will ask you for the
detail over here and you can see a
Sprint
name and the duration date timing and
Etc so
just
s so now we have created a to Sprint and
you can see to do in progress to do in
progress and done in the board
section now you can um open up the
stories and
View and view the details
inside you can assign to the same one
and you can do it at a set story Point
estimate is a quantitative value of how
much relevance a story has in the appic
so far now let us just set it
as
four or
three and over here you
can add a child
issue since this story is about saving
the product in the favorites
so can
first
first we can first create a favorite
button on the product
page page that is product page right so
[Music]
page we can also add another subtask to
create a new database so that we we can
store the product uh that we like or
like
yeah
create database
for aite
product now that we all are done here we
can close this section
story here we will do the same thing for
this story
also Thea is over
here was it
tree can add a child ISO button over
here and we can
create a page to
display
spray
[Music]
favorite and our second subtask could be
about creating a button so that we can
view our favorite list like we can
add
view favorite
button okay but we are done here you can
also see
this so now you can see this Todo button
over here now for our subtask so you can
expand them and you can click on the
progress now see that the since the
story in progress we can close
this and slide
over sorry into the process we can do
this to the same for the Second
Story we'll open this we done in
progress close it we shift it to in
progress now once you are done with the
subtask you can go to the same place and
you can specify it as
done this also second canel it
down now you can see that the the
progress is
100% 100% done right so now you can t
the
story and shifted it
over the done
column can do same for the
next so now once we completed all the
sub task and the stories you can go in
the complete and you have to complete
the
Sprint
yeah we have also seen how to assign it
to
someone and how to create story points
estimate and how to track progress of
your project and now we will see how to
manage workflow so the first thing you
need to do to access your workflow is
first you have to go to the board and to
the right corner
button and and click on the manage
workflow over here you can see the phase
that your business is currently going
through and start Crea do in progress
done and Etc so you can also add a few
phase like if you want to add let us
know add another to do status suppose
add so once you are done over here it
will come you can see the face set you
have deployed and you have to update
your workflow and save and
continue so you can exit this interface
and and have then overhead to the
board and now over here you can
see that the add phase for your project
so now that we have seen what overflow
repeat so now that we have seen what
workflows are let us explore few other
options so the first thing that we can
see is
code over here you can integrate jira
with other
platforms so that you can manage any of
your project easily and you can also
have an in-house inversion interface
important part of jira configuration
these are a collection of configured
values to be later used by one or more
jira project there are seven types of
schemas including notification schemes
permission scheme issue type schemes Etc
comes the last question in the list what
does jira schema consist of to answer
this question the G schema is consist of
notifications workflows issue types
permissions screens and field
configuration to get into the business
analysis domain we bring you topnotch
courses to become a skilled business
analyst from the best universities
around the globe so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll Now find the
course Link in the description box in
this session we will start with certain
exercises which we will perform in tblo
in order to understand some basic
concepts now in order to learn tblo the
basic first step is to import a sample
data so in our case what we have done is
we have imported a sample super store
which is in Excel format a sample
superstore. excl which has three
worksheets in it orders people and
returns so by importing this data into
TBL first of all we will create
relationships between these sheets in
order to identify who all have placed
orders and how many people have returned
the order
we will do some analysis on the orders
placed by certain set of people and
Order returned by certain set of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders table the
order sheet on the relationship canvas
here okay and you can can see the data
sample data the first 100 rows over
here okay then now we need to create an
inner join with people's table between
order and people okay so if you
see it has automatically detected the
field names on which the inner joint has
to be created so on the order side you
have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people
data so if I close this box and go and
check the people's
data
open so see the region and the person
these two columns from the people table
have now been joined with the a orders
table right so it means that these are
the orders in a particular region which
has been placed by in this
region
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by
customers across multiple regions south
west of USA South Region west region
then you have a list of order IDs which
have been returned so
basically the order ID in the returns
sheet matches with those orders in the
orders table and then you have the
people uh sheet in which you have
region and a person associated with that
region the sales person associated with
that region okay so basically when we
are combining joining orders with people
we are joining
that which
orders belongs to which region and who's
the salesperson associated with it so
what we have done over here is we have
made a inner join means all the orders
should belong to particular region and
that region is in the people's sheet and
then in the second step now we will make
a left join between returns and orders
not in a join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the order ID
okay so just edit
this click on left and select order ID
as the join column now what does left
join means left join means is that
consider all the orders from the orders
table and only consider
the orders from the returns table which
have data means which are returned
otherwise show null for the order IDs
which are not returned so if you see
this is the these are the two columns
from the returns table and these are
null because this is relevant to the
order IDs which are not returned okay
which has been accepted by the customer
but these are the orders for which you
see data in the returned and Order ID
column it means that these have been
returned now with these joins in place
please save your book and now we have
our relations created in the
um in the tblo now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model now we'll move to sheet
one
okay and first we will
place
state
and person on the rose sheet
okay then I'll go to
my numbers
and put the profit or the so per state
per person how much profit I am making
as a company okay this is my goal to
check now sort by highest to lowest so
California is giving me the maximum
profit of 76,6 381 then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I
have listed my profit in descending
order now I can also check what are the
number of orders played
and check the distinct
count so out of 120 out of the total
orders of 127 okay so this is the number
of total number of orders which have
been returned for California is
127 it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as
per the revenue as per the profit and
this is the details of the orders which
have been returned per state so if you
see for Connecticut for a canas there
are zero
returns
so you can also extract
data table to refresh is orders and
identify new rows using order date so as
in when new data is being added you
can refresh it now say
extract and now you can save this
information
profit by
state and click save so this is the
extraction of this particular report
which is possible in
tab so this is the first exercise which
we have completed
for reviewing and analyzing the profit
per state highest to lowest and within
that per state what are the number of
orders which have been returned by all
the customers the distinct count of
order IDs which have been
returned now let's start start our
second exercise on creating calculated
fields in tblo now in this exercise we
will be doing
certain activities like we will be
creating a set to show the states which
have more than 100 customers then we
will be creating a calculated field to
show an average sales per customer okay
then we will create a calculated feied
to show the sales goals and then show
emerging and developing stage so these
are the four kpis which we have to
derive now the first thing we have our
sample super store data already imported
and the relationships created inner join
with people and left join with
returns now we have our sheet two in
which we will create the uh States a
list list of states which has more than
100 customers so what we have to do is
we have to click right click on the
customer name and click create
set
okay now we have to give the name as
states with 100 plus
customers and then go to the condition
tab select by field and then apply
condition
as count of customer
name greater than equal
to
100 and click
okay now we have this set created states
with 100 plus
customers now to determine average sales
by customer we have to now create a
calculated field so go to the analysis
and click on create calculate
field
okay now name it as
average sales per
customer and now we will say
average we will use
uh okay so we are saying that per
customer we are using a level of
definition function include which means
that per customer what is my average
sales right we've already used a
function aggregated function called
average so we are saying per customer
give me the total and then give me the
average per customer so we're going to
click
okay now create another calculated field
you can also create from here and name
is as name it as sales
goal now in this we are going to type
the formula if
minimum
states with 100 plus customers equal to
true
then sum of
sales into
1.3
else average sales per customer into
100 so we we are saying
that if the customer belongs to the set
of states with 100 plus customers then
the sales Target should be 1.3 times the
actual sales as of today else it should
be 100% of the average sales per
customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging or developing
state if distinct
count of customer
name is greater than equal to
then the state is tagged as developing
State else it is called
as emerging
State okay so we have now three
calculated Fields average sales per
customer emerging or developing State
and sales goals now we will use this in
our reporting so we will drag sales goal
Under The
Columns and then I'll drop my state so
now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or
not then add your customer
name
make the measure as count
distinct and make it as
distri okay so if you see
this we have the count of customers per
state and the the sales goal for that
particular
State and
now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want per which is there per
state now go to show me and
select this particular chart bullet
graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales AIS and select swap
reference line
fields
now from the your left hand panel drag
and drop emerging or developing State on
the color
panel okay so emerging state is the
orange one and the developing state is
the blue
one and save the sheet as developing and
the emerging
stage so if you see this it's an
emerging State because its count is less
than the customer count is less than
100 its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is 1
okay so now this is a developing State
it's count is greater than equal to 100
and its sales goal and its sales is
exactly the same it matches so that's
why you are saying the bar and the blue
bar is ending exactly where the vertical
bar
is so what we are trying to depict is
that whether the uh state is going
Beyond its Target sales goal or it's
behind it and you can see that using
this particular vertical bar like for
example Michigan its sales goal is 71
952 but its actual sales is
76270 average sales so that's why it is
be above its
Target and it's a developing
State because it has more than 100
customers so you can even
sort by the count of the uh customers
higher to lower so all your developing
state will group from at the top and the
emerging States Will Group at the
bottom or you can sort
by the sales
goal so the orange bar is the sales goal
or the blue bar so depending what sales
goal is
being derived for each
State hello and welcome to this new
session on Tablo now in this session we
will talk about how to prepare
dashboards and how to Interlink reports
within the dashboard so in order to
start this session we will first create
couple of reports and then include them
in the dashboard and then link them
together so for this session as usual we
are using the sample super store data
set for our
example now first we will create a
report where we are going to show profit
by region per
region so first we will drag the region
in the rows column and we will get all
the regions
and
state so we have all the states per
region in our report now and then we
will
drag
sales and profit so now we have our
sales and
profit measures at the column
level
now just also drag now the region to the
color section so now we have each region
colored the entire sales and profit per
region is distinguished by the different
colors Central East South and
West now click on the
colors now we want to show the labels
using the marks card okay so we want to
show the
region
okay so we need to include the show the
marks labels just a
second so enable the
labels say show Mark
labels
okay so you have on the left this is the
profit and this is the total sales now
rename this sheet as region and state
analysis
report
okay now let's create another
worksheet now in this sheet just drag
the
state on
the marks card now automatically Tableau
will detect that you know you have
dropped a particular State and we have
the states of United States so it has
identified the state names and showed
you the identifiers of the states on the
map and
automatically identified the latitude
and longitudes which are generated by
tblo and given you the markers on each
and every
state now drag the sales measure to the
color
panel okay so now this is sales per
state in the color scheme with the color
scheming
then now Drag The Profit to the
size so now each state you have the
color the the profit and the
sales now you can edit the colors and
you can
select a particular scheme of colors and
say apply and okay so now you are able
to
distinguish the colors on the state
now after this just rename the sheet as
profit by state
report now create let's create another
report now in this report drag the
subcategory to the column
section and
sales and profit measures in
the
rows
Okay now click on the right click on the
sum profit pill and check dual
access now click right click click on
the profit AIS and say synchronize
access now select some sales from the
card marks card and change the notation
as
bar and for profit change the notation
as line so now this is a fair display of
subcategory
wise sales and profit representation
that these are the sales and what is the
profit now go to the marks all marks and
drag the category section the
category section as the tool
tip okay so for each and every bar or
line item you should now see the
category
also save your
report and rename this now report as
sales by and profit by subcategory
report
now let's create a new
dashboard now the reports which we have
just now created first our dashboard
size let's make it as
automatic okay
then let's show the dashboard title KCK
click on the dashboard
title now drag the reports which you
have
created profit by
state sales and subcategory
report and region
and okay so you have all your three
reports in a single dashboard
now profit by state sales and profit by
subcategory and region by and state
analysis report now we will link these
reports so go to
dashboard click on actions
add a action called new
filter select Source sheet in the source
sheet dashboard 2 only select region and
state analysis
report and in the Target sheet just
deselect region and state
analysis on the source sheet keep the
Run action on select and
click
okay now whatever state you select over
here that particular state will be used
as a filter across both these reports so
it means in North Dakota you have all
these Cate subcategories being sold and
they're Associated profit and on the map
profit by Straight report you can see
the North Dakota State being highlighted
or only selected and the relevant profit
and
sales okay so here is the total profit
and sales in the profit by state report
and in this sales and profit by
subcategory report you have the breakup
of the profit and sales across the
categories similarly you can select any
other state and automatically
the filters will get applied
automatically
see this Marine
main
okay so with this we cover our example
of how to create multiple reports and
then connect them or encapsulate them in
a single dashboard for a single view
across all these going to take example
of the Netflix database which we have
and we will prepare some certain reports
in order to identify what kind of
reports we can generate from such a data
set So currently on my screen what you
can see is the tblo the Netflix data
sheets the data sources where you have
the Netflix shows movies their
Associated duration uh what kind of
shows or movies are there they release
here uh the associated rating
description and and a key which is the
show ID now this is the unique
identifier for each show uh in this
Netflix title sheet and with this show
ID all other sheets are related like you
know who are the directors of the show
in which country the show was released
what is the cost of each show all that
information is in this sheet and to
which particular category basically the
listed in category
is being uh listed in this particular
sheets so what we're going to do is
first we going to import this sheet into
tblo okay and then create relationship
between them using the tblo relationship
canvas so first our the primary
transaction table the sheet sheet in
which all the information related to
movies is there or shows is there is in
Netflix titles and then we will
drag sheet like Netflix cast titles cast
now DA has automatically identified the
relationship between uh the show ID of
titles and show id id of titles cast and
it has made a join so if you double
click
this you can see this relationship
cardinality and the Rel ated Fields
similarly I'll drag Rel titles category
countries and
directors Now by virtue of this all the
sheets have now been joined with Netflix
titles and with this relationship ready
we can start preparing our
reports now let's create a basic report
where we can just glance the data like
you know whatever we were seeing in the
Excel how it looks in tblue so you have
all the types of movies
then for example I drag the release here
now first I do not want to uh consider
it as
a dimension so I'll
just release Here know per category per
type uh there is a release here and then
I'll drop the listed
in so now these are the categories so
per year the the details of the
categories right and then you
can drag the title and the associated
rating so this is just a view of your
data we can name it as shows listing
report now let's try to create some some
report for some uh measures some numbers
Etc so now let's check in which country
how many movies or titles were released
you know what is the count so first
let's drag
the
country so as soon as we drag the
country uh field it is identified that
it has the geographical names and
identified the latitude and longitude
details so Tabo internally does that
automatically and it has identified the
spots across the globe of the relevant
country now let's drag the listed in on
the color
section now what it is doing is it is
showing in which country what different
kind of uh category wise movies are or
shows have been released like in Sri
Lanka documentaries have been released
in India action and adventure United
States action and adventure like this
now
let's put account
of the titles right so if you see
247 action adventure move movies or
shows have been released in United
States okay so this is one inference by
this particular report you
can identify so let's save this report
as
listed
in by
country okay now let's create another
report we will call it as the per year
statistical report in this first I'll
put the release ears in the column
now count of Netflix titles so this is
the count of Netflix titles per year
2017 2016 14 and then count of Netflix
titles in the
countries this is the second bar chart
okay now what I'll do is I'll combine it
into
one
so one
report we
are moving in the bar creating the bar
and one in the line and now I just have
to so we will click on the count of
Netflix titles by country right click
Market dual access so now as soon as you
click this both the uh charts have been
combined and right click over here and
say synchronize
access
okay okay so now if you can see see
right in 20 17 you had uh
2,33 Netflix
releases across all categories and
1159 titles right 1063
titles in
2017 so this is a descending
representation of the count of titles
released per year across category and
across
titles
so let's call this as per
year
stats now let's create another
report number of
shows per title
okay so or or sorry per rating so we
will drag the rating column
and we
will count of
titles
and
unique count of titles and unique count
of show
IDs
okay one is bar and one is
line okay
so this is a report which shows rating
wise titles and the show
IDs
so in the tool tip you can see the
distinct count of titles and show ID per
rating okay so let's call
it shows per
rating now let's create another sheet
call it as
shows by
cast so in this what we going to do is
first drag the cast column on the rows
section you have name all of all the
cast and then we drag
the show ID on the column section and
put a count D and sort it okay uh you
can remove the null cost and this is
your sorted order and on the label
section you can say show Mark labels and
you will see the count that anupam K has
done the maximum then shahruk Khan Omri
nasin sha so this is the details on the
sorted order that who has done how many
shows
okay then next is shows by director
similar to shows by
cast
drag director into
rows or differently if you want to
prepare into columns and then count
of show
ID okay sort
it and you can actually filter out the
null director
value and this is your account put the
label so you can see Jan's switter has
the maximum
shows
okay then create another report shows by
category now similarly drag the listed
in in the rows and show ID
count
remove the null
category and
sort labels show Mark labels so
International movies are the highest
category drama the next comedy
International TV shows this way you have
your category now let's create a
dashboard in which we want to bring
combine all these reports
and take a common view so first let's
drag listed in by
country then shows by
director also please let's set the size
as
automatic then let's drag shows by
category and shows by cast now these
four reports are on a single dashboard
we will link them to each other so go to
worksheet
actions add action
filter select dashboard
one only select shows by category
here and in Target dasboard
one except shows by category keep
everything else and in the source sheet
just select click select click
okay okay now whatever category you will
select over here that related category
data will automatically be shown in
other reports like see International
movies across the globe across countries
directors of only International movies
who has done the maximum Johnny toe and
uh shows by cast right that who has done
the maximum International movies or
dramas or
comedies see pares Ravel has a maximum
number of comedies and then if you see
the comedy movies uh you know these are
the count of comedy movies released
across the countries and the who is the
director another very interesting report
which you can prepare is that for
example you want to check in which
country maximum duration of uh
your
uh maximum duration
of movies have been released
so first let's create uh to
measure move
this
okay
so if you see maximum duration of the
movies or the entire Netflix content is
maximum United States then in India
these many minutes next is United
Kingdom and you can also change the
colors whatever you feel is as per your
standards or as per the convention you
can change the color
combination so there are multiple ways
you can generate reports and uh hope you
have understood how you can leverage
such a data to create your reports to
get into the business analysis domain we
bring you topnotch courses to become a
skilled business analyst from the best
universities around the globe so what
are you waiting for for hurry up and
enroll Now find the cost Link in the
description box today we are going to
talk about powerbi what are its features
what are the basic advantages of using a
visualization tool like powerbi and we
will talk about how to install
powerbi and other features it provides
and the basic
setup so let's discuss what's in it for
us
today now we will first talk about why
powerbi you know why it's a popular tool
and what problem it solves what is
powerbi uh and what are the primary
features of power VI uh which you can
use in your day-to-day data analytics
visualizations creating fancy reports
creating meaningful intelligent reports
uh for your organization for your
personal use uh for crunching numbers
for generating reports real time
Etc now the most popular tool for
powerbi is the powerbi desktop uh I'll
show you certain uh aspects of powerbi
desktop and then I'll show you the steps
how to install powerbi desktop on your
machine and then definitely powerbi
desktop is a free tool provided by
Microsoft but then you can also
subscribe uh for an Enterprise version
which is primarily used uh by
Enterprises for publishing their data uh
so we'll see the difference and then
overview of o or dashboards which can be
created uh you know what kind of
dashboards can be created in
powerbi so this is the agenda for us
today now why powerbi so generally uh
you know visualization tools reporting
tools are required in order to create
and prepare and analyze meaningful data
it could could be a data for an
organization it could be a social media
platform data it could be a data from
iot devices but something which needs to
be analyzed and some intelligent
inferences and data mining has to be
done on top of it now imagine there are
today we are in a world where terabytes
of data and information is getting
generated on a instantaneous places on
minute by minute basis so it becomes
very essential to churn out something
meaningful something intelligent out of
it in the market there are lot of other
tools where which are available like
klicks uh ultrix tblo and powerbi so
powerbi is a Microsoft product which is
one of the most popular products and it
comes as a free to download product
Microsoft powerbi desktop which is
available and I'll show you couple of
ways how you can install it on your
machine but why powerbi is um uh popular
is because it provides a lot of outof
the-box features Dragon do features
which we will talk about in our
subsequent sessions and uh you know
classes but today's session is primarily
focused on giving you guys an
introduction on what is the purpose of
powerbi and what all problems it solve
uh in the in the real world so powerbi
allows you to VI view analyze and
visualize huge quantities of data and
the data could be any format Excel CSV
text or it could be uh a direct
connection to a database like SQL MySQL
Azure Oracle anyone IBM db2 so it
supports n number of uh uh you know data
types or data sets and it's very
powerful in terms of data connectivity
so it uses powerful compression
algorithms to import and cache the data
within the PB file so it's as convenient
as a simple software if suppose you
import a data and then you prepare a
report and then you can easily share the
reports uh with your peers or someone
who's co-developing with you either
through powerbi cloud services or even
you can share the PB file in an email or
through any other means and you can
share the data set with the concern and
they can then work on the report
independently so there are different
ways there is no uh kind of a limitation
for you know uh working on powerbi there
are multiple ways and it is very fast it
is the most fast uh tool to work with
Excel because definitely Excel is also a
Microsoft Technology so it works very
fast on uh Excel based data and gives
you numbers and Reporting at a very high
speed so now once you have imported the
data
powerbi allows you to model the data
allows you to work intelligently on the
data it allows you to model the data in
a way that if you're are importing data
from multiple Excel sheets importing
data from multiple tables you can easily
create a relationship between those
tables or data sets in powerbi and then
create visually appealing reports
meaningful reports as I've been
emphasizing and make sense out of that
data no data in silos is of any use data
in Silo means a single worksheet or a
single data set will not churn out any
meaningful information until unless you
basically join it Club it merge it Union
it append it with some other data sets
because a single data set will never be
able to hold that much amount of
information which is generally required
for a you know important report
so it has easy drag and drop
functionality with features that allow
you to copy all formatting across
similar visualizations so just like in
Microsoft Excel we use format painter to
copy the format of one cell to another
it similar features very very similar to
excel products or Microsoft product they
have provided that if you have applied
uh a particular theme on a report you
can easily replicate that on an any
other report the font uh the header size
the background color you don't need to
do it again and again so there's lot of
reusable features which are also
available okay now as I said Excel is a
Microsoft product powerbi is a Microsoft
product so they have intercompatibility
you can publish data from Excel to
powerbi now with the latest developments
and
enhancements as of today Excel has also
uh plugged in a new feature called Power
pivot which I'll uh show you uh later
down the line but that also allows you
to do a quick analysis not you can't
create of course complex reports or uh
fancy reports like powerbi but Power
pivot allows you to create you know
quick measures quick functions quick
calculations on your data quickly only
in Excel so it's an Excel plug-in but
whereas you know you can powerbi is also
compatible with Excel so when you create
a report in powerbi it gives you inbuilt
feature to export your powerbi report
into Excel format directly you don't
need to do any programming for it
also uh you can easily publish when you
publish your powerbi reports it allows
you to give some inbuilt intelligence of
analyzing your reports in Excel and it
gives you all those of all those
features of exporting your powerbi
reports into Excel which is not
available in any other tool or otherwise
those tools have to create plugins
create addins and probably they might
charge for it uh but powerbi comes with
lot of out of the box features which are
very very helpful for analyzing data in
Excel and vice
versa Azure Cloud now Azure itself again
is a Microsoft cloud uh uh text tack so
using powerbi with Azure allows you to
analyze and share large volumes of data
so Azure basically Azure database or
Azure Cloud servers are meant to hold
huge amount of data and powerbi allows
you to have seamless connection you can
easily connect to Azure data Lake uh you
can reduce the time it takes to get
insights and increase collaboration
between business analysts data engineers
and data scientists so aure data L
becomes the central focal point where
all your uh analysts Engineers uh can
keep working on on the centralized piece
of data and churn out their reports data
scientists primarily job is to keep the
data in a structured way optimize way
optimize the input output operations
disk operations and memory utilization
so that the reports also get churned out
in a faster manner so every uh you know
every person has their own role in order
to give a quick refreshable report a
quick rendered report any report which
is taking huge amount of time to get
rendered will not eventually be used by
the business users because then it does
not solve the purpose the report should
be fast report should have uh you know
appropriate filters slices and dices you
should be able to you know uh create the
reports or dynamically or you should be
able to analyze visualize the data
dynamically so all those visualization
features are available in powerbi and it
works seamlessly either it is small data
or huge data uh it allows that you to
work on those kind of data in know
seamless
fashion right so this is just a very uh
quick uh example of uh how a typical
dashboard looks like dashboard is
nothing but you know you have clubbed
couple of multiple reports on a single
page and and you know if you change a
filter uh a single filter on the page
all the reports will honor that filter
and the numbers will change accordingly
so if you see the in this example
there's a filter or a drop down of
product ID product name employee name or
supervisor or a date range so whatever
date range or filter you will apply all
the reports on this dashboard will get
changed based on the filter you have
selected so powerbi allows you to get
insights from data and turn insights
into action to take data driven business
decision and that is the ultimate goal
of any visualization tool that is the
purpose for which visualization tools
are
bought uh and purchased by the
organizations and data is fed into
them now powerbi fetches data from
Factory sensors social media sources to
get access to realtime Analytics
so that you are always ready to make
timely business decisions to so
basically there is a uh feature of live
connection or cut off data connection so
either you can work on data which is
deciding on a machine and you can just
work on the cut off data like for
example it's there's a data which is
available for sales 2017 2018 and you're
just working on a historical data it's a
cut off data or it could be possible
that you want to be connected live uh to
a uh realtime iot based sensor based
data or social media data like Twitter
Facebook feeds or you know you connected
to live Google worksheets that is also
possible you just need to publish your
Google sheet for a public domain embed
the UR into powerbi and then whoever
updates that Google sheet automatically
the powerbi report will also start
honoring and consuming the new data
which is added in the
uh Google sheet so all those kind of
realtime streaming analytics is also
possible and that is one big feature uh
and very important feature of powerbi
which is widely used and has a very huge
uh you know Market acceptance and Market
utilization now what is
powerbi powerbi is a business analytics
service provided by Microsoft that lets
you visualize your data and share
insights right so earlier you
know uh Microsoft used to have a
technology called ssas now they have
replaced actually ssas and SSRS with
powerbi so basically you can use powerbi
on the data which is there in your Excel
or any other data source and the powerbi
service or powerbi desktop uh basically
creates a connection to those data sets
and uh import it cach it and give you a
handle to it in order to work with it so
you can create these fancy meaningful
visualizations like for example there's
a geographical map if you are importing
data for a country or a continent or a
region powerbi will automatically detect
that it's a geographical information and
give you a map with latitude longitude
information and you just need to plot uh
your um your numbers on the map either
you can use bubbles or or either you can
use triangles or whatever data structure
you want to use but all the mapping will
be available geographically then you can
create pie charts which is shown in this
visualization you can create tree maps
you can create cards where you know you
can highlight the most important numbers
like sales total sales of your company
uh across all the regions or the growth
chart or the month-on-month uh you know
sales of your organization or number of
total number of products or units sold
so whatever is important and to be
highlighted for the management to take
any meaningful decision or any insights
you want to share powerbi
visualization tool the powerbi
visualization uh uh uh chart allows you
to drag and drop and create wonderful
reports okay so what are the features of
powerbi so powerbi desktop is something
uh Standalone tool which you need to
install on your machine it allows you to
build reports by accessing data easily
you do not need Advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report though yes it is beneficial that
if you know uh some SQL programming
analytical programming or you are aware
of advanced features of any analytical
tool that might help you but that's not
a showstopper uh you can easily build
reports in quick turnaround time without
needing any technical background you
just need to have some
analytical uh mindset and you can create
uh Savvy visualization and you know
analytical
reports stream analytics as I mentioned
you can create a live connection uh with
any kind of uh data it could be iot it
could be media social media it could be
Google dog it could be um you know any
other kind of uh you know live
connection it could be a live database
connection itself so any insertions or
updations or deletions happening will
automatically reflect in your
report yes multiple data sources and
that has to be the uh primary criteria
for any tool to be popular if any
visualization tool is limited to certain
data sets then you know it will not be
highly acceptable in the
market and custom visualizations right
so as I showed you certain uh examples
in the past uh in the previous
presentation uh that feature is very
important because someone might want to
look the kpis look at the kpis from a
different perspective some management
might want to look at the kpis from a
different perspective so you need to you
need to have uh that capability to
create different visualization from the
same data set now let's take a look that
how to install powerbi desktop on your
machine so basically what you need to do
is you need to go to this
URL powerbi do
microsoft.com enus desktop okay and and
you need to just enter
this now you can download it for free so
just click over here
and it will open Microsoft store so
basically now what Microsoft have done
in the latest operating systems is that
when you are trying to download you can
actually directly go to the Microsoft
Store and search for
powerbi
so let's wait for a couple of
seconds right here so powerbi desktop in
Microsoft store for me it's already
installed so it's asking me to open it
I'll open it in a while but for you for
anyone who is not installed he will see
the button of install over here and it
will automattic atically install in your
uh machine and then you can easily go
and open powerbi Desktop now if I click
open over
here now this is
the uh UI of the powerbi desktop I'm not
going to go right now in creating
reports right away we will talk about
that in a subsequent session with sample
data sets and we will cover the features
of powerbi desktop one by one but this
is what it is this is the whole tool of
powerbi which is having the
visualization pan all the different
visualizations are you know can be
created from this pane then this is the
pane which allows you to select the data
data fields then there is a report view
data View and relationship view the data
model view where multiple relationships
you can create you can view the data uh
in the grid of the tables which you will
create and the reports so you can create
multiple reports uh on multiple Pages
you can keep adding pages either you can
D create multiple reports on a single
page and it will become a dashboard or
you can create separate independent
reports on the single
page and these are the menu options
which we will talk about how you can
change color scheming you can do data
modeling you can create new reports and
you can also transform data it is the
biggest feature extract transform and
load the data apply different logic
changing data types massaging the
information creating new joins appending
the data you know adding new columns etc
etc uh we that is what you can do in
transform data so this itself is a whole
different world it's a diff uh dedicated
topic so we will talk about that in our
subsequent sessions so what's in it for
us today we will be learning how to
connect to data different data types
data files like Excel PDF then what are
the different data importing modes and
then I will also show you practically
different sets how to import them in
power VI and use it for your
visualization purpose now what are the
steps to connect to data so now we will
go directly into powerbi and try to
import one by one few most commonly and
popularly used data sets which are most
commonly used uh in a day-to-day
activity rest of course there are uh
powerbi supports n number of data
sources uh but we will uh do something
practical on the most popular ones so
let's let's open our
powerbi now this is my power bi and
first I want to show you that how can I
import data directly from a web page and
import the data now it is asking for a
URL in order to import data so what I
have done is I have created a Google
Excel sheet with simple data with rows
and columns and what I have done is I
have shared this sheet as publish to web
okay so you just need to say publish to
the web the link as web page and say
done it's it's automatically published
and say link so copy the link which you
have published on the web copy this link
and then go back to your tblo paste it
link over here and click
okay now powerbi will try to establish a
connection with this Google doc sheet
because it's published on the
web you need to wait for a while while
it is
reading okay now it has read one of the
HTML tables I'll select this one now you
can see it has it is showing me a
preview of the table which is there on
my Google sheet right it has 11 rows so
it has all showed all the 11 rows so now
I can go and transform this data because
I can see my headers are there starting
from the second row so there's an
opportunity for me to transform the data
so I'll go and transform it so that it
looks
clean okay so first is I need to remove
the first row which is
the null row remove the top
rows okay and then I need to use the
first row now as a header so you just
click this option use first row as
headers that's it so now if you see my
row ID order ID order date ship date all
my data is now ready so I can say close
and
apply click apply
changes now this is an example of web
data import you can go and preview your
data right now uh the biggest advantage
of this data connection is that it's a
live data so for example I insert
another
row let me change the order
ID some some I've some changed some
basic stuff and I
it's Auto saved contrl s now I'll go to
my TBL Lo and I'll
refresh now you can see as I refreshed
my power query editor I clicked refresh
all and I got my new row which is there
in the live data I got that fetched from
my okay I got that row the row row ID
number 12 so I I have to say close and
apply now you can see the new row the
row number 12 is now available in my new
data set in the data set because it's a
live connection it's a live connection
with the webbased Google sheet okay so
this is one important way in which you
can import data now let's try to import
data from a text file now I have already
prepared a text file called sub
categories.
txt now let me just open it in a notepad
now it's a very plain simple file tab
separated file in which you have product
subcategory ID subcategory name and
product category key so basically to
which product category this particular
sub product belongs to right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go back to
my get data
option and I'm going to select text SL
CSV
option and I'm going to select option
mod product sub categories.
txt okay so now powerbi has identified
that it's a tab delimited file it has
recognized the headers Etc right and I
can now directly load this
file okay so now once the data is
imported in powerbi it is like
irrelevant to me it's a composite data
in import I'm doing right so in my
present presentation when I'm talking
about importing data there are different
importing modes right import data import
can happen through different ways
okay one is direct query mode in which I
create a live uh connection to the
database which I'll also show you uh
using MySQL and Ms SQL server and also
you can do a composite mode in which you
can have data imported from Excel plus
you can have direct query modes so you
can have multiple uh modes to connect
and create a composite data model and
that's what we are doing right now in
our practical so what we are doing over
here is one we have imported data from
the web second we have imported data
from a text table now after doing text
now our next task is to import from CSV
let's try another one so now I have
imported product subcategory
now I'll
import a CSP file so again I'll choose
the option text / CSV and now in this
CSV file let me open this CSV file and
show you what in is
it so this is a list of all my products
product key product subcategory key
product uh stock keeping unit Etc a
simple CSV file and I'm going to import
that okay so now has identified the D
limiter is comma rather than a tab and
it has already recognized the headers
correctly so I'll load
it okay so now my products are there
product subcategories are there for
product categories now what I have done
is I have created a Excel mode now so
now Excel I'm using to import my product
category so now I have to click on the
option of import data from Excel and
I'll say product category
select the sheet
load and now so my products product
categories product subcategories do with
different uh data storage types but
still now the data is imported into
powerbi it is a composite data model now
another very important data type which
you can import is the PDF also right so
what I've have done is I have created a
PDF called customers my customers data
is lying in a PDF so what I've done is
I've created a
PDF which has data for some columns are
there like you know customer key prefix
first name last name birth date marital
status gender email address annual
income total children etc etc so this is
the data set which I have created in PDF
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
select PDF now
and import customers. PDF and see it has
recognized my table on page one which
I'm going to
load
okay you can rename this as
PDF
table
so this basically these are the
different type
of
data types we have imported PDF Excel
text CSV and web page now let's take a
look at another interesting data set
which we want to import is the my SQL
Server data
set so what I've have done is I've
already installed my SQL server on my
local instance and there's already a
schema of SQL live tutorial over there
and I have certain tables
already prepared over there like
Department employee Etc so my goal is
now to import this data or create a live
connection with this data set now in
order to
import my SQL database Connection in
powerbi you need to
First download
a connector MySQL powerbi connector so
you need to go to this
link and then click on download and
install the MySQL connector based on the
operating system you have you click on
download and install it after you you
have done this go back to
powerbi and then give the IP address of
the database in my case it's there in
this local machine and the schema which
I want to import is SQL live tutorial so
I'll give the
name click
connect okay now it's connected so now
it is asking me which particular tables
you want to create a connection with I'm
choosing department and
employee and I'm just loading
them okay so now this is the exact data
which is there in the employee and
Department in my cull okay so this is
one example of how to create
connectivity between powerbi and MySQL
now I want to do the same thing
using SQL Server Microsoft SQL Server so
I have also installed Microsoft SQL
server on my machine and I have used the
SQL Express so this is the name of my
server so which I'll copy the server
name and go to get data select SQL
server and for now database is optional
I can say direct query click
okay okay now it is showing me what all
tables I can import so in my SQL Server
tutorial in my SQL Server I
have I have these three tables customers
employe TR Olympic events so I can use
prob probably the customers one which
is now you can see this is the data the
customers data which is lying in my SQL
Server okay so I can preview it and load
it so now you can you can preview the
data in uh powerbi that is this is the
data so I can rename is customers from
mssql and this is
from my y
SQL
and okay so now this is not the only uh
data sets you can import now if you take
a look at the options which powerbi gave
what different type and variations of
data it can it has compatibility to
import
from okay so we can just take a look at
the categorization on the left hand side
first there are file based like Excel
text XML Json is also possible you can
evenly directly import entire folder and
within the folder whatever uh data types
of files are there it will detect it PDF
Pary or even SharePoint folder which is
itself a
Microsoft uh technology then different
kind of databases SQL server and my SQL
we just saw but it's not only limited to
this you can connect to Microsoft Access
ssas Oracle database IBM db2 postgress
uh sbase Terra dat and then sap uh uh
databases Amazon red shift Impala
vertica Snowflake and N number of
databases which are there in the market
today uh Amazon ET ET then it also
allows you to connect with its own power
platforms powerbi platforms data Mars
powerbi data flows data ver Etc azour
there are different kind of storage uh
mechanisms in azour and azour itself is
a Microsoft Technology uh so it has a
compatibility with lot of azour uh based
data storages like azour SQ database
blob storage uh Azure data brakes right
aour HD Insight spark so if you have
those kind of services running on your
Azor cloud services you can even import
them over
here now online services like you know
you have erps running uh or some data
which is shared on the internet if you
want to import it uh that is also
possible through certain products uh
Dynamics 365 Microsoft Exchange on
online Salesforce Google analytics Adobe
analytics GitHub uh LinkedIn sales if
you want to do some analysis of some
social
networking uh you know feeds that also
you can
import then other miscellaneous are also
their webbased hive R script python
script if there's something to import
get data from uh Google Google Sheets
like we saw one example in our video
right now so there are multiple options
available now once you have imported the
data which is relevant to you um in our
subsequent sessions we will see how to
create relationships but just giving you
a glimpse that whatever data you are
importing powerbi autod detect certain
relationships and it will create for you
but then you can go and manually also Al
change so this is the composite data
model which is getting created in the
back end while you are importing the
data you can easily go and manage these
relationships either keep them as is you
can delete and create new ones manually
so there is no limitation in
that so this is what we have witnessed
we have imported data from different
files types data types and then you know
we have tried to once it is imported
into uh powerbi then there is no
limitation of how you use it you can
create visualizations across different
data sets and then create
your standard
reports so this is the example of
importing data from web importing data
from a database from a PDF and then once
you have data you can shape and combine
data you can basically do what whatever
transformation you want to do you want
to uh make joins merge the data so for
example if we go back to our powerbi and
if I go back to my transform data
section now as I have now different data
sets available with me I have I can do
any kind of U you know operation
transformation on the data right
uh so like I showed you I uh upgraded
the header row because one of the
imported data was not showing the header
correctly uh or this columns like this
exact one column is extra I can remove
the
column right all those Transformations
whatever I do in the back end gets
captured in the applied steps section
right this is the customer data you can
create uh you can merge it you can
append it uh you know with other data
set right look for example I want to
create a merge data set of my categories
and subcategories so I can say mer
select the two data sets and say merge
queries as
new and I can select product categories
and product
subcategories
select product category key on both the
side and and then they do a left Auto
join so whatever product categories are
there I'll get the subcategories
associated with it and I'll create a new
table which will
have now I have the table which has the
category and the subcategory and
subcategory in one table itself so I can
rename it now to
as
category
subcategory table it's a it's a merge
basically it's a join between category
and subcategory and now I have a common
table right and I can close and
apply so imagine I have created a new
table which is imported created from one
data set is which is Excel page and
another data set which is text
base see this category subcategory table
so now I can use it the way I want in my
visual visualization reports so that's
what the presentation says right that
once you have uh the imported data you
can shape you can combine you can adjust
you can do whatever transformation you
want to do and create your visualization
okay so what topics we are going to
cover today we going to talk about
different types of data modeling and the
most important part and aspect of data
modeling is the cardinality the
cardinality which you basically decide
after reviewing the nature of data and
after you imported it what kind of
cardinality you have to basically
highlight right and there are different
type of cardinalities which you might
have heard earlier also if you are from
plsql background like 1 is to one one is
to many Etc we will we will talk about
that now what are the different types of
data modeling now dimensional data
modeling is one one of the most popular
and most uh you know widely used uh
modeling in dimensional data modeling
you have Master data uh like for example
customer data date store data product
data so these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers Etc that will change less
frequently as compared to the sales
transactions because transactions are
happening every day every minute so
sales is a more fast changing data set
in dimensional modeling which is in the
terminology of data uh is also called as
a fact and customer store product which
are like more of static data and less
changeable data is sometimes called a
dimension so this is a typical
dimensional data model which is
typically used
uh sometimes right and then there is
another model which is relational model
this is a typical model which we have
been using in database design like you
know primary key foreign key
relationships so for example you have a
customer who has purchased a product so
probably he might have the customer
might have the details of the product
which he has purchased and you will make
a join between customer and product
table and even uh you can make a join
between product or product type or
customer or product type customer table
will also have a key to the product type
so this is less uh conducive for
reporting but it is more of a
transactional uh relational model but of
course this is also feasible but from
the powerbi perspective when we talk
about reporting and visualization this
is the most extensively used dimensional
data model and this is what we going to
see in our example now so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you certain
data sets first we will prepare and uh
create certain of data sets and then we
will Import in our sample powerbi file
and then slowly slowly we will create
the
relationships now one important thing
which you need to understand that in
powerbi if you go to powerbi there is an
option that that powerbi autod detect
new relationship ships after data is
loaded and import relations from the
data source on first load so for example
if you are importing the data from a
database where you have already defined
the primary keys and the foreign key
relationships so uh that is the first
option which powerbi will autod detect
and secondly if suppose you are
importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
powerbi detects a common column key
column it will autod detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship uh menu manage relationship
menu in powerbi which I'm going to show
you okay so if I open a powerbi and this
is where the option lies go to file go
to options and setting
options
data
load and these are the two options which
are by default checked you can uncheck
it and auto and manually prepare
relationships there's no limitation to
that but if you uh keep it checked then
powerbi will do its job to detect the
relationships
okay now coming to the next important
factor cardinality now before I start
playing around with my data and start
showing you certain
relationships it's very important to
understand these four types of
cardinalities one is many to one right
so basically many to one means that many
orders contain data of One customer so
per order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one to many relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many to one
relationship okay second other
cardinality is 1 is to one one is to one
relationship is only applicable when you
are saying it's an extension of the
current table so for example in one
table you have employee details and you
are extending the details of the
employee in another table like employee
address employee ID so that is like one
is to one there's no multiple records of
a single employee in the address table
only one employee ID exists right
now one is to many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one so in
customer table only one customer record
exists per customer and one customer can
place many orders for multiple products
and can also have multiple delivery
addresses so that way this is a typical
1 is to many relationship we will be
seeing this example also in our sample
data
set and last is the many to many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you pra practically and in our case
we will see that like for example you
have placed an order for a particular
product U you know but there are
multiple fulfillments which has happened
so suppose you made order for 10
products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically your the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order ID might have a multiple
fulfillments for the same order ID so
there will be a multi many to many
relationship which I'll show you
practically so now with this background
let's start importing our data now the
first important thing which we need to
import is the master data so first I'll
import all my master Dimensions which
are uh which I'm going to you know use
in my example so first is the customers
table customers
data so this is the customer details
like customer key prefix first name last
name birth date marital status and
gender some redundant columns are also
present but we'll remove
it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over
here okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes okay so now this is my customers
data with the relevant columns and the
key per customer customer key now
there's no relationship in this model
right now right because only single
table is there and the associate data is
only imported now let me also import my
another important master table is the
products select the product data product
key product subcategory product SKU
product name model name product
description color size so just see all
the relevant information only specific
to the product is available so I'll
imported okay now see there's no
relationship between product and
customers directly because until unless
a customer makes an order places an
order for a particular product there is
no join right so now between these two
tables the most important now another
table which will now make sense as the
sales order table sales
table now I I'm assuming that powerbi
have autod detected the relationship now
you can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
powerbi what relations powerbi has Auto
detected detected let's first check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click
this uh joint now what it has done is it
has created a joint of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
uh Place many orders right and that is
that it has detected by the quality of
the data and the data sampling which
powerbi has done you can can also
reverse this relationship here I can
select
customers and I can select sales now it
has become one too many so that you can
also do manually so that is what I said
whatever powerbi is detected it is up to
the discretion of powerbi internal um
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's change the relationship so
one is to many means from One customer
and many sales
orders similarly let's see what has
happened at the product side of the
relationship similarly powerbi many
sales orders for one product
you can for Simplicity sake you can say
products
sales product key is the join now just
focus one more thing please uh also see
the co the column on which the join is
is the grade column grade out column
product key is also here and product key
is also there and it is what we wanted
so one is to many relationship from
product to sales table and active now
looks fine this is something which is
looking logical and probably now we can
proceed further to create a report now
let me explain the cross filtering with
an
example now for example I want to check
in a report that what is the count of
products
which uh which a particular customer has
ordered okay so what I'll do is I'll
select the product
count of product
name now if you
see the and for each customer in front
of each customer name the count is
coming as 293 293 it is getting
repetitive because because there is a
oneway filter Direction filter between
customers and sales and sales and
products right so this
join is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go
here I'll first open my sales
table we can also open it here let's
make click it is okay now if I click
okay you can see the single arrow is
changed to Double Arrow it means it's a
it's a both side filter So when you say
a both side filter it means that
implicitly within powerbi you can
imagine that all the product columns now
will get appended because of both ways
filter you have applied and if you go to
your report now see the change of the
numbers now 40 20 so the total count of
products across all my customers come
out to be 293 now the report looks uh
correct if I change the relationship
from back to single between product and
sales then you can't make a join between
customers and product basically you
can't derive the product count from the
product table see
this if you have to live with it then
you would have to go to the sales table
get the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct
okay so if you want a report in which
you want the count of product name and
even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have have to go and
change the direction of the filter which
is from single to both so this is a
typical example there where you want to
use a twood directional
filter now let's proceed further and
import other data set in order to give
show you another example now I want to
show you an example of 1 is to
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is
there so I'm loading the customer
details now you see it has autod
detected a 1 is to one
relationship what is the meaning of 1 is
to one means one One customer key only
has one entry in customer details there
is no multiple entry so if you click
this
button it's a 1 is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now
easily associate
a email address with the first name you
will get 1 is to one
record so now you can see that with one
is to one
relationship with the first name I have
Associated the email ID and for each
email ID there is a Associated first
name with that so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count so in this report what we have
done is uh if you click over here so the
first name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one
relationship and then
and if you
drag the customer
key uh report takes time to render and
even if you
can so this is the reporting output you
have the customer key first name
associated email address and the count
of product names uh which the customer
has ordered
now this is an example of 1 is to 1 now
I want to show you an example of many to
many now for that I'll import my
fulfillment data
set
okay now in my fulfillment data set
there is a column
for order number so basically what I'll
do is I'll drag order number from here
to
here okay so now what has um uh Power by
detected I'll do one thing I'll select
sales over over here fulfillment over
here and order number to order number
okay so it's a many to many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order
now many to many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for both ways
cross filter
detection uh a Direction but you can you
can check that but definitely uh powerbi
shows a warning that this relationship
has cardinality to many to many and this
should only be used if it is expected
that neither column contains unique
values okay so we know that fact that's
why we are accepting this relationship
as many to many because we know there
are multiple order numbers over here in
the sales table which are mapped to the
multiple order numbers in the
Fulfillment table we'll click
okay now you want to keep uh the uh
direction as both ways or One Direction
that is up to you the way you want to uh
map the report so I can double click
over here and you can even click so now
you can select from which way single
filter you want from fulfillment to
sales or sales to fulfillment I'll
prefer sales to fulfillment and click
okay
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to short list one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many to many now if I show
you further relationships which you can
keep on adding like for example I have
uh uh the example of
territories now in which particular
territory the sales was done so I can
map it over
here okay so now it's a typical 1 is to
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent region and it is
mapped to the uh territories which are
for in which my orders have been placed
so it's a typical one is too many so
that way you know you can keep on adding
data then you
have uh details of
returns now this is another
transactional table which is about the
orders which have been returned rather
than being you know returned by the
customers so you have a product key H so
automatically powerbi has detected a
relationship between the product key and
the product uh table right and even if
you can join the territory key in which
territory the return has happened right
so mostly the most common relationship
which you will observe is the one is to
many because as I told earlier the most
common relation
model is the dimensional model uh the
static data the slow changing Dimensions
the scds are the master tables and the
most frequent changing are the fact
tables so if I talk about a typical
dimensional model the Fulfillment table
sales table and the terator table sorry
uh the Fulfillment table sales table and
my returns table are the fact tables of
my data modeling now so far what we have
done as per our last session is that we
did data modeling on the different data
sets which we had imported in powerbi
like products sales data returns
fulfillment customer details uh and
customer Master data calendar details
Etc so in the last session we prepared a
data model and established the
relationships between these different
data sets like 1 is to 1 1 is to many
many to one 1 is to one Etc and we saw
the examples now once our relational
model is uh prepared our data model is
prepared now our next activity is to
create certain additional columns which
we want to derive bases the data which
we have imported so for example I'll
start with my product data set now in my
product data set I want to introduce a
column which basically categorizes that
if any product which has a color uh you
know red black or gray I'm going to tag
it as a colored product rest I'm going
to say not a colored product right so
all these are like example of bite type
product skus so for that now in order to
introduce a new column you just need to
do what you need to select the table in
the data grid go to the table tools and
say new
column okay so column will get appended
to the rightmost part and you will start
seeing a uh formula section typical to
like you get in your Excel now I'm going
to say that the name of my column is
going to be bike type color okay and I'm
just creating a if condition
if
product
color is equal
to
Black
okay
or or if it is equal to
red or if it is equal
to Gray
then say yes it's a colored product I'll
say
no okay so now you can see Bas is the
product color red and black they are
saying bike type color Yes blue is no
multi is no etc etc so this is a classic
example of an if and else condition
based conditional column okay so you can
create such columns now second column
custom column which I want to create is
I'm going to call as
discount now Bas is the pricing of my
products I want to associate certain
discounts which I'm ready to give to my
customers Bas is the product category
like what is the pricing of the category
again I'm going to use make use of if
else but in a nested way so if I'm
seeing if
my
product price is less than 100 then I
will
give 0%
of uh 0 percentage of uh discount so 0o
into product price just to keep it
consistent now I'm
seeing
else if less than 100 than zero else
I'll check again that
if the price
is less
than 500 then I'm ready ready to give 1%
discount on the product
price
else I'll move further so like this I
have created a
formula so what I'm saying is if product
price is less than 100 give 0% if it is
less than 500 then give 1% less than
2,000 then
1.5% less than 3,000 then 2% and
otherwise else less less than 3,000 if
it 2% else 3% right now after this
column is created
now you can check right so this see the
product price for this particular
product it is less than 100 so that's
why there's no discount it is uh between
100 to 200 then this has been given a 1%
discount so like this all the discount
column is now calculated now this column
is available just like a regular column
in my product
table now after this I'll go to my sales
table now in sales table I want to
identify
uh create a column called as cost there
is no product cost column over here so
that will be derived so let's create a
column called as
cost and it is derived by order
quantity into now the cost of the
product is in the product table and I
know I've already created a relationship
between product and sales
table so I just need to select the
product cost column now now only keyword
which I have to use in powerbi is the
related keyword so this will pick up the
relation and now for this particular
sale order the cost has already been
derived so this order number this is the
cost for which uh the product has is the
costing of the product for this
particular
order
okay now I'm going to create another
conditional column over here called as
order
status I'm saying if any order whose
order quantity is greater than
two then for my organization it's an
urgent order else it is
a normal
order oh
sorry
I lost
it
so this is
my order status column and I have my
order
quantity urgent or
normal so any order which has order
quantity one is normal any order which
is having order quantity as greater than
two is urgent you you can see this so
there's
a this whole
powerbi uh tabs and sheets allow you to
also review the data what you're doing
so it's very
convenient
now I have my sales data now what I want
to bring within the sales is my discount
column so here also I want to bring the
discount which I have
created so I'll say
[Music]
discount discount will be order
quantity
into
related product discount right so the
discount calculated column which I had
created under products I'll bring over
here now I am creating the order level
discount so if you see for this
particular order there's a
25 uh uh you know for 25 rupe discount
at the cost is 100,000 rupees
okay and what is the order price now so
I have taken the order cost the discount
now I have to create a column called as
price order price so that will
be again order
quantity into
related price which is per
product price
enter
okay so now I have the cost the discount
and the price right available with me
now I want to calculate the
total uh total revenue total profit and
loss
right per order how
much so first I'll calculate per order
how much Revenue I'm generating so now I
have to generate a column called as
revenue revenue is
price minus
discount
so 1700 - 25 1700 -25 2071 - 42 and if I
want to calculate the profit per
order
then it is
revenue Minus
cost okay so now you can see you know
typical custom columns calculated
columns which we have created are all
playing around with the number numeric
value use numeric data primarily and
trying to give inferences into per order
cost discount per order price revenue
and profit so typical calculation
columns which I have prepared in front
of
you now let's take a look at other
different variations of custom columns
uh I'll create certain columns for text
based custom custom columns calculated
columns uh using text Bas data so I'm
now moving towards my customer table in
which I have customer key prefix first
name last name birth date marital status
and
gender now I want to create a new column
in which I want to derive the age of
each customer as of today right so I'll
use another function a cre function
called
as date
diff now date diff so I want the
difference between the birth date of the
customer and as of today in
years
okay so this customer as of today 68
year old one is 74 68 57 Etc so this is
one derivation of uh calculated column
of
age let's take another example now this
is a text based column where I want
to derive the full name of the customer
now here I'll say
first lower case in lower case I'll
concatenate the
prefix then
ENT
space
ENT first
name
ENT space
ENT last
name and closing brackets
Etc full
name okay so this is an example of full
name in lower
cases now another calculated column
conditional column add the customer
level I want to identify a flag which
says who is my Target customer bases the
demographics shared over here Target
customer so I'll say
if the marital status is equal to
M
and total
children
three and total children annual
income so okay so let me change the
logic a bit so marital status is M and
and
age
is less
than
50 these customers are my Target
customers okay so I would
say
yes else
no see this he's a marital status is
married Logan Dias and age is less than
50 else everyone so if I try to
filter so these are the my Target
customers 69 out of 1178 so this is just
a conditional column but a logical
condition an example which I'm trying to
highlight over
here
okay now let's look at certain
calendar date oriented columns
calculated
columns very typical like now I have a
simple date column now I'll keep adding
certain columns which uh you know which
help you which will help you understand
how we can uh you know you know do some
calculations on the dates so like for
example I want a date which is 12 days
after the current date the date in the
column so just simple 12 Days After
select the date and add
12 now if you see the date format you
can go and change the format at the top
and if whatever you feel like like
this now see 12 days after 1st Gen 2015
is 13 gen 2005 you can go and change the
format and other
details let me also show you if I go to
my cost and other columns I can go and
change the format this is like a
currency cost is currency so I can go
and uh select the change the currency
type and you can even show the dollar
value or whatever currency type it it
is so for numbers you can do currency or
text or dates you can select the format
so this is available at the column tools
level now in
customers like we had
our column of full name so now what All
Things Are ailable format as text okay
data type text so very minimal options
are there with date you have options of
the date
format now
next I want a column which defines the
expiry date okay so 8 months prior to
the expiry date within which is uh
coming up in 8 months so I'll create a
column called as 8 months
expiry and then there is a e date
function I'll use that I'll use
my date in the data
set comma I'll say eight so now this
date column will append eight months to
my actual date and again I can go and
change the
format correct now another important
column like I want to know the date
name so I'll use a function called as
format and I'll select my calendar date
column and and I'll say give me the
dddd format of it so it'll give me the
day name the day the day name of on that
particular
date
next ears in
between so I want the ears in between
the today's date and the date of my
calendar so equal to date diff
the calendar
date comma
today comma
year
end 7 years 2015 to
2022 then last date of the month so if I
want what is the last date of this
particular calendar month month I will
use a function EO month which is there
available in
the powerbi so I'll
say last date of the
month equal to EO
month
then just select the calendar CSV date
comma zero in months and
enter
change the
format then similarly start of the
month
so I'll use a function called start of
month so for for all January dates end
of the month is 31st Jan and start of
the month will remain 1st of
Jan change the
format
next I want to know what is the week
number of that particular date so now
there is an inbuilt function
called week number week num and just
pass the date and you will get the week
number first week of the year second
week of the year
Etc
now another
very good example is whether the
week day is a week day or a weekend
right so what is it's a weak type
okay so I'll CH I'll put a if condition
and there is a function called
weekday and I'll pass the
calendar if it is less than six it means
it's a weekday else it's a
weekend so all
Saturday and Sunday day names will come
as weekends else everything else will
come as
weekd to get into the business analysis
domain we bring you topnotch courses to
become a skilled business analyst from
the best universities around the globe
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll Now find the cost Link in the
description box now today we will
discuss how to create relationships and
different kind of data models within
powerbi based on the structure of data
you're importing
okay so what topics we are going to
cover today we going to talk about
different types of data modeling and the
most important part and aspect of data
modeling is the cardinality the
cardinality which you basically decide
after reviewing the nature of data and
after you imported it what kind of
cardinality you have to basically
highlight right and there are different
type of of cities which you might have
heard earlier also if you are from plsql
background like 1 is to one 1 is to many
Etc we will we will talk about
that now what are the different types of
data modeling now dimensional data
modeling is one of the most popular and
most uh you know widely used uh modeling
in dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers Etc that will change less
frequently as compared to the sales
transactions because transactions are
happening every day every minute so
sales is a more fast changing data set
in dimensional modeling which is in the
terminology of data uh is also called as
a fact and customer store product which
are like more of static data and less
changeable data is sometimes called a
dimension so this is a typical
dimensional data model which is
typically used uh sometimes right and
then there is another model which is
relational model this is a typical model
which we have been using in database
design like you know primary key foreign
key relation ships so for example you
have a customer who has purchased a
product so probably he might have the
customer might have the details of the
product which he has purchased and you
will make a join between customer and
product table and even uh you can make a
join between product or product type or
customer or product type customer table
will also have a key to the product type
so this is less uh conducive for
reporting but it is more of a
transactional uh relational model but of
course this is also feasible but from
the powerbi perspective when we talk
about reporting and visualization this
is the most extensively used dimensional
data model and this is what we going to
see in our example now so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you certain
data sets first we will prepare and uh
create certain of uh data sets and then
we will Import in our sample powerbi
file and then slowly slowly we will
create the
relationships now one important thing
which you need to understand that in
powerbi if you go to powerbi there is an
option that that powerbi autod detect
new relationships after data is loaded
and import relations from the data
source on first load so for example if
you are importing the data from a
database where you have already defined
the primary keys and the foreign key
relationships so uh that is the first
option which powerbi will autod detect
and secondly if suppose you are
importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
powerbi detects a common column key
columns it will autod detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship uh menu manage relationship
menu in powerbi which I'm going to show
you okay so if I open a powerbi and this
is where the option lies go to file go
to options and setting
options data
load and these are the two options which
are by default checked you can uncheck
it and auto and manually prepare
relationships there's no limitation to
that but if if you keep it checked then
powerbi will do its job to detect the
relationships
okay now coming to the next important
factor cardinality now before I start
playing around with my data and start
showing you certain relationships it's
very important to understand these four
types of cardinalities one is many to
one right so basically many to one means
that many orders contain data of One
customer so per order one customer is
there so from customer to order or
product or delivery address it's a one
to many relationship and from the other
side from order to customer perspective
it's a many to one
relationship okay second other
cardinality is 1 is to one one is to one
relationship is only applicable when you
are saying it's an extension of the
current table so for example in one
table you have employee details and you
are extending the details of the
employee in another table like employee
address employee ID so that is like one
is to one there's no multiple records of
a single employee in the address table
only one employee ID exists
right now one is to many as I said is
the reverse side of many is to one so in
customer table only one customer record
exists per customer and one customer can
place many orders for multiple products
and can also have multiple delivery
addresses so that way this is a typical
1 is to many relationship we will be
seeing this example also in our sample
data
set and last is the many to many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you pra practically and in our case
we will see that like for example you
have placed an order for a particular
product product you know but there are
multiple fulfillments which has happened
so suppose you made order for 10
products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically your the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order ID might have a multiple
fulfillments for the same order ID so
they will be a multi many to many
relationship which I'll show you
practically so now with this background
let's start importing our data now the
first important thing which we need to
import is the master data so first I'll
import all my master Dimensions which
are uh which I'm going to you know use
in my example so first is the customers
table customers
data so this is the customer details
like customer key prefix first name last
name birth date marital status and
gender some redundant columns are also
present but we'll remove
it so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes okay so now this is my customers
data with the relevant columns and the
key per customer customer key now
there's no relationship in this model
right now right because only single
table is there and the associate data is
only imported now let me also import my
another important master table is the
products select the product data product
key product subcategory product SKU
product name model name product
description color size so just see all
the relevant information only specific
to the product is available so I'll
import
it okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales
table
now I I'm assuming that powerbi have
autod detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
powerbi what relations powerbi has autod
detected let's first check the relation
between customer and sales I'll double
click
this uh joint now what it has done is it
has created a joint of many to one
between sales and customers so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
uh Place many orders right and that is
that it has detected by the quality of
the data and the data sampling which
powerbi has done you can also reverse
this relationship here I can select
customers and I can select sales now it
has become one too many so that you can
also do manually so that is what I said
whatever
powerbi is detected it is up to the
discretion of powerbi internal U
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
make this is by default active so we
want to keep it active One customer many
sales orders cross filter Direction
means that only from customers to sales
is the filter applicable not reverse
I'll come to this with my another
example but first let's change the
relationship so one is to many means
from One customer and many sales
orders similarly let's see what has
happened at the product site of the
relationship similarly powerbi many
sales orders for one product you can for
Simplicity sake you can say products
sales product key is the join now just
focus one more thing please uh also see
the co the column on which the join is
is is the grade column grade out column
product key is also here and product key
is also there and it is what we wanted
so one is too many relationship from
product to sales table and active now
looks fine this is something which is
looking logical and probably now we can
proceed further to create a report now
let me explain the cross filtering with
an
example now for example I want to check
in a
report that what is the count of
products
which uh which a particular customer has
ordered okay so what I'll do is I'll
select the product count of product
name now if you
see the and for each customer in front
of each customer name the count is
coming as 29 3 293 it is getting
repetitive because because there is a
oneway filter Direction filter between
customers and sales and sales and
products right so this
join is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that
it is equal to a join between product
and sales and every product detail now
is appended to the sales table so if I
want to make you visualize this you need
to go
here I'll first open my sales
table we can also open it here let's
make click it is okay now if I click
okay you can see the single arrow is
changed to Double Arrow it means it's a
it's a both both side filter So when you
say a both side filter it means that
implicitly within powerbi you can
imagine that all the product columns now
will get appended because of both ways
filter you have applied and if you go to
your report now see the change of the
numbers now 40 20 so the total count of
products across all my customers come
out to be 293 now the report looks uh
correct if I change the relationship
from back to single between product and
sales then you can't make a joint
between customers and product basically
you can't derive the product count from
the product table see
this if you have to live with it then
you would have to go to the sales table
get the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct
okay so if you want a report in which
you want the count of product name and
even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the direction of the filter which
is from single to both so this is a
typical example there where you want to
use a twood directional
filter now let's proceed further and
import other data set in order to give
show you another example now I want to
show you an example of 1 is to
1 so I have another table which is
called customer details so the key in
this table is again customer key but
only email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer Custer is
there so I'm loading the customer
details now you see it has autod
detected a 1 is to one
relationship what is the meaning of 1 is
to one means One customer key only has
one entry in customer details there is
no multiple entry so if you click this
button it's a 1 is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because One customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now
easily associate
a email address with the first name you
will get one is one
record so now you can see that with one
is to one relationship with the first
name I have Associated the email ID and
for each email ID there is a Associated
first name with that so this is an
example of 1 is to one relationship so
in this example what we have explained
is that for each customer there is an
Associated customer detail right uh so
you have the first name email address
education level homeowner occupation and
total children count so in this report
what we have done is uh if you click
over here so the first name and the
email address okay so there's a one is
to one
relationship and
then and if you
drag the customer
key uh report takes time to render and
even if you
okay so this is the reporting output you
have the customer key first name
associated email address and the count
of product names uh which the customer
has ordered now this is an example of 1
is to 1 now I want to show you an
example of many to many now for that
I'll import my
fulfillment data
set okay now in my fulfillment data set
there is a column
for order number so basically what I'll
do is I'll drag order number from here
to
here okay so now what has um uh powerbi
detected I'll do one thing I'll select
sales over here fulfillment over here
and order number to order number okay so
it's a many to many relationship so it
means that per order I have created
multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order
now many to many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for both ways
cross filter detection uh Direction but
you can you can check that but
definitely uh powerbi shows a warning
that this relationship has cardinality
to many to many and this should only be
used if it is expected that neither
column contains unique values okay so we
know that fact that's why we are
accepting this relationship as many to
many because we know there are multiple
order numbers over here in the sales
table which are mapped to the multiple
order numbers in the Fulfillment table
we'll click
okay now you want to keep uh the uh
direction as both ways or One Direction
that is up to you the way you want to uh
map the report so I can double click
over here and you can even click so now
you can select from which way single
filter you want from fulfillment to
sales or sales to fulfillment I'll
prefer sales to fulfillment and click
okay okay now we have our all our
different kind of relationships over
here uh which we have tried to short
list one to many many to one one to one
which is uh this example and uh many to
many now if I show you further
relationships which you can keep on
adding like for example I have uh uh the
example of
territories now in which particular
territory the sales was done so I can
map it over here
okay so now it's a typical 1 is to many
relationship because territory is my
master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you you have uh details
of
returns now this is another
transactional table which is about the
orders which have been returned rather
than being you know returned by the
customers so you have a product key and
so automatically powerbi has detected a
relationship between the product key and
the product uh table right and even if
you can join the territory key in which
territory the return has happened right
so mostly the most common relationship
which you will observe is the one is to
many because as I told earlier the most
common relational model is the
dimensional model uh the static data the
slow changing Dimensions the scds are
the master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I if
I talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the trator table sorry uh the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data
model hello and welcome to the lesson
formatting conditional formatting and
important functions in this lesson we
will learn about custom formatting how
to use conditional formatting and
formulas and Implement logical
statistical and mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above Target below Target and met
Target as a data set can be huge and
complex differentiating each value
manually would consume a lot of effort
and time here comes the Excel features
such as formatting and conditional
formatting which enables us to perform
this task easily formatting as the name
suggests helps us to format the data
using different techniques making the
data easy to read in the required format
and analyze them the right formatting
technique applied to the worksheets can
help the users present the data
efficiently conditional formatting a
type of formatting helps us visually
explore and analyze data detect critical
issues and identify patterns and Trends
conditional formatting helps to add
patterns and Trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formula
Etc at times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set Excel provides a
large number of logical statistical and
mathematical functions such as vlookup
hookup and if not rank quartile and many
more that can help the users to perform
calculations ranging from basic to
complex op
operations these inbuilt functions help
us to manage data and perform
descriptive statistical
analysis Excel also offers a wide range
of important formulas that help to
perform many common tasks these formula
may be as simple as basic addition or it
could be a complex combination of
inbuilt excel functions before going
into details let us start this lesson by
defining the objectives of the
lesson the worksheets appear more
polished and easy to to read if proper
formatting techniques are applied to it
we can format the cells in Microsoft
Excel manually by selecting fonts font
color font size background colors and
borders we can also use numerous
predefined table Styles or quick styles
to quickly format a table automatically
this is the basic formatting in
Excel if these built-in functions do not
meet our needs or do not display the
data in the format that we require we
can create our own custom format in this
this topic we will focus on custom
formatting in Excel let's say we want to
display 1,
532,000 as
1.53m or the 1st of January 2016 date
with a weekday as the 1 Friday January
2016 here we can use custom formatting
feature of excel let's see how we can
accomplish this in
Excel in this lesson we shall consider
the following fields from our master
table dates order ID
product salesman region number of
customers net sales and profit and loss
here in the given worksheet we have a
column named net sales suppose we want
to display the values of net sales in
terms of thousands for example
7,164 should be displayed at
7.16k select the entire column for net
sales
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in the numbers panel select the
option more number formats a format
cells dialogue box appears from the
category list select the type as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number zero decimal 0 0 comma
open double quote capital K close double
quote here number is the digit holder
with thousand comma
separation each comma after decimal 0 0
indicate divide value by
1,000 the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places the K component displays a
literal K character to denote
thousands here we can see the preview in
sample box the value shown is
7.16k
finally click okay
button the values in column net sales
are now displayed in terms of
thousands now let us consider another
example of date
formatting in the column dates we have a
date value written as 1st Jan
2012 we want to display it as first
Sunday Jan
2012 first select the column contain
aing
dates under the Home tab click the
dropdown present in numbers panel select
the option more number formats a format
cell dialogue box appears from the
category list select the type as
custom in the type text box enter dd- DD
dd-
mmm- y
y here D d stands for date m stands for
month and y stands for year the first
2dd is the date the next four d d DD is
for weekday say
Thursday then mmm is for the month in
short form and YY is for year here we
can see in the preview in the sample box
the value shown is 1 Sunday Jan 12
finally click on okay
button thus the custom formatting helps
us in changing the appearance of the
cell value according to our needs a
worksheet may contain thousands of rows
of data by simply examining the raw
information it would be difficult to see
patterns and Trends conditional
formatting helps us visualize data that
make worksheets easier to understand it
quickly highlights important information
in a spreadsheet by using colors icons
and datab bars it changes the appearance
of one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than 5,000 color the cell Yellow
by applying this rule we'll be able to
quickly see which cells contain values
that are greater than 5,000 let just
understand this with the help of
examples consider the given sales table
which depicts the amount of sales done
by each salesman here we want to
highlight the duplicate order ID
values first select the order ID
column click Home tab under Styles panel
select the option conditional
formatting from the drop- down menu
hover the mouse over High light cells
rules and select duplicate values a
duplicate values dialogue box
appears select a formatting style from
the drop-down menu in our example we
will choose green fill with dark green
text click
okay here we can see that the
conditional formatting is applied to the
column order ID Excel highlights all the
duplicate cells with green fill
with dark green
text we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains a date occurring and
top/bottom rules all these rules work in
the similar
format Excel provides predefined styles
to quickly apply conditional formatting
to our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph color scales color
scales change the color of each cell
based on its value each color scale uses
a two or three color gradient icon sets
icon sets add specific icon to each cell
based on its
value let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales
table here on the basis of the sales
amount we want to apply the icon set
rule if sales amount is greater than
8,000 then a green arrow should appear
in the upward direction if sales amount
is between 5,000 and 8,000 then show a
yellow arrow in the horizontal Direction
and if sales amount is less than 5,000
then show a red arrow in the downward
direction to perform conditional
formatting select the desired
cells
click on Home tab under Styles panel
select the option conditional
formatting from the drop- down menu
hover the mouse over icon set rules and
select the first
rule again click on conditional
formatting select the option manage
rules from the dropdown a conditional
formatting rules manager dialog box
appears go to Icon set Rule and select
three icon set
rule click on edit Rule and an edit rule
formatting dialogue box
appears by default for three icon set
rule Excel uses the 67th percentile and
the 33 percentile rule this means that
it shows a green arrow for values
greater than
67% yellow arrows for values between 67
and 33% and red arrow for values less
than
33% now let us customize this rule for
our criteria in the type drop down
select the option as
number in the value reference box enter
value is 8,000 for green color arrow and
5,000 for yellow color Arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color arrow click okay in
the conditional formatting rules manager
window click
okay we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8,000
have a green arrow in the upward
Direction values between 5K and 8K are
highlighted with a yellow arrow and
values less than 5 5K are highlighted
with a red
arrow we can also apply conditional
formatting rule with the help of
formulas consider the given table which
shows the profit done by each salesman
here we want to highlight the rows in
the table whereever profit is greater
than
4,000 select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting select
the option new rule from the drop-down a
new formatting rule dialogue box
appears under select rule type select
the option use a formula to determine
which cells to format under format
values reference box enter the formula
as equals if Open Bracket dollar sign H2
greater than 4,000 comma true comma
false close
bracket this will apply formatting to a
cell if the profit is greater than 4,000
click on format button from the format
cells dialogue box select the fill tab
from the color dialogue box select the
color as green finally click
okay
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than 4,000 are
highlighted with the green
color logical functions evaluate a cell
or cells for a criteria and returns a
Boolean value true or false in this
topic we will cover various logical
functions like if and or not true
false consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to determine the commission
percentage of each salesmen following is
the criteria if net sales greater than
or equal to 10,000 set commission as
5% if net sales greater than or equal to
5,000 and less than or equal to 10,000
set commission as
2.5% if net sales less than 5,000 set
commission as
1.5%
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function let's write the
formula in cell I5 like any other
formula we will start with the equal
sign then type our function if and then
type an open parenthesis the first
parameter we need to pass is a logical
test here The Logical test is if sales
cell G5
greater than or equal to 10,000 assign
value as
5% then we will pass the second logical
test here we will use and function if
Open Bracket and Open Bracket s cell G5
greater than or equal to 5,000 comma
cell G5 less than or equal to 10,000
comma aign value as
2.5% in the else parameter we will type
1.5 % this means that if the first two
cases become false then the formula will
assign the value
1.5 finally close the two braces for the
two ifs thus Excel Returns the result as
2.5% for cell G5 now drag the formula
with the help of the fill handle we can
see the results for the other cells as
well the or function returns true if any
of the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
in the given table we are required to
assign performance remarks for each
salesman as per the scaling
table in scaling table we have the
criteria that if net sales greater than
10,000 or profit greater than 5,000 set
remark as good else set remark as needs
Improvement let's write the formula
using IF and or to check sales and
maximum sales in cell
J5
so our formula becomes equals if Open
Bracket or Open Bracket G5 greater than
10,000 comma H5 greater than or equal to
5,000 comma double quote good double
quote comma double quote need
Improvement double quote close
bracket let's drag this formula across
the cells with the help of the fill
handle this formula return true if any
of the condition is true thus in the
given example the cell j9 returns good
even if profit is less than
5,000 our next function is true/false
true/false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell the not function reverses the
result of the function if result is true
it returns false else true
let's write formula as equal not open
bracket K5 close bracket in cell
L5 this Returns the result as
false let us now study about different
lookup and reference functions used in
Excel such as vlookup hookup match index
and offset function the vlookup function
let us search for specific information
in the current worksheet say we have a
list of students with marks
we can search for the marks of a
specific student if our table is in
horizontal format and we want to
determine a specific value then we use
the H lookup
function consider the extract from our
Master sales
table the table depicts sales
information based on order ID product
sold salesmen and net sales now we want
to determine the net sales corresponding
to order ID
1121 let's understand how we can
accomplish this this using the vlookup
function note that vlookup function is
only used for vertical tables let's use
cell I2 to add the formula like any
other formula we will start with the
equal sign then type our function name V
lookup and then type an open
parenthesis now we will add the
arguments the first argument is look up
value lookup value corresponds to the
value or item we are searching for so so
in our example it will be order ID
1121 cell
H2 the second argument is table array
table array is the cell range that
contains the data in this example our
data is in cell B2 to
E40 the third argument is call index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be
four the fourth argument is range lookup
this value corresponds if we are looking
for approximate matches or not and can
have value either true or false true
denotes the approximate match and false
denotes the exact match here we will
pass false finally close the parentheses
so our function has the form equal V
lookup Open Bracket H2 comma B2 colon
E40 comma 4 comma false close bracket we
can see that the function Returns the
value as
2277 note that the V lookup function
works from left to right that means the
lookup value should always be present in
the leftmost column of our table
array if our table is in horizontal
format and we want to determine a
specific value then we use the H lookup
function consider the given table let's
write the formula in cell I4 we will
start with the equal sign then type our
function name H lookup and then type
open parenthesis the first argument is
the lookup value so in our example it
will be order ID equals
1121 cell
84 the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G8 to
as1 the third argument is row index
number here our table array net sales is
the fourth row so our third argument
will be four the fourth argument is
range lookup here we will pass fals
finally close the parenthesis so our
function has the form equals H lookup
Open Bracket H4 comma G8 colon
as11 comma 4 comma fult close bracket
the function Returns the value
2277 note that H lookup function works
from left to right that means lookup
value should always be in the topmost
row of your table
array the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then Returns the
relative position of that item in the
array let us understand its functioning
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
to determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell
E5 type equal sign then type the
function name match and then type an
open
parenthesis the first argument is the
lookup value so in our example it will
be date in cell
B5 the second argument is lookup array
the lookup array is a range of cells
that contains the value we are searching
four in this example we will select the
cells B17 to
b1342 the third argument is match type
match type Ty can be either min-1 0 or 1
the value should be 1 if we want to find
the largest value less than or equal to
the lookup value the value should be
zero if we want to find the first value
exactly equal to lookup value it should
be minus one if we want to find the
smallest value greater than or equal to
lookup value here we will pass the match
type as zero as we require an exact
match finally close the parenthesis
so our function should look like match
Open Bracket B5 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign 17 colon dollar sign B
dollar sign
1342 comma 0 close
bracket this Returns the value as three
now we can drag the formula across cells
with the help of the fill
handle similarly we can use the match
formula in cell E3 to determine the
position of the shown field name ccel C3
in range B17 to i7 for example net sales
is at 7th position in the range B17 to
i7 let's write the function in cell E3
write formula as equal sign match and
open parentheses in the first argument
select cell C3 for second argument
select cell's B17 to
i7 past third argument is zero finally
close the
parentheses so our function looks like
equal match Open Bracket C3 comma dollar
sign B dollar sign 17 colon dollar sign
I dollar sign 17 comma 0 close bracket
so for profit loss field the value
returned is
eight net sale the value returned is
s the index function Returns value value
from a specified position in a specific
column in a list suppose we want to
determine the value of a field mentioned
in cell C3 from the sales table on a
specified date the table should
dynamically fetch the value if the value
of the cell C3 is
changed if we enter profit loss formula
should fetch the profit loss value for
the specified
date if we write net sales in cell C3
then formula should fetch net sales
value for specified date so let's use
the index function to determine the
value in this worksheet select cell C5
write formula as equal sign index and
open
parenthesis the first argument is the
array for our example enter B17 colon I
the second argument is the row num this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter E5 which denotes the required date
the third column is col num this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name in cell C3 in
table finally close the
parentheses thus our formula Returns the
value as
6528 8 based on the position at cell's
E5 this is the net sales value on the
date the 2nd of
January now drag the formula with the
fill handle to the other cells as
well the offset function returns a
reference to a range that is the offset
number of the rows and columns from
another Ranger cell now let's understand
how to use it select cell D5 write
formula as equal sign offset and open
parentheses the first argument is the
reference this denotes the starting
range from which the offset will be
applied for our example we will select
the reference cell as
B17 the second argument is the rows this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or A negative number so for
our example we will enter E5 minus one
here we are subtracting one to match
number of row which have the value and
the offset from the reference cell the
third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name and subtract by one to
match with the offset
referencing finally close the
parentheses the function Returns the
value value based on the position of
date from cell B5 and field from cell C3
now drag the formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle if we
enter profit loss formula should fetch
the profit loss value for the specified
date a variety of statistical functions
are available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test bom or chai square
in this topic we will cover various
statistical functions like sum if count
ifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and
median Su ifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
sum based on one or more criteria the
sum ifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain
criteria let's understand how to use the
function with the help of an example
consider the given sales table say we
want to determine the net sales done by
salesman
Justin here we will use the sum ifs
function to calculate net sales so let's
write the formula in cell N4 type equal
sign then type the function name sum ifs
and then type an open parenthesis the
first argument is the sum range this is
the input range that contains the
required data so so in our example we
will select cells H4 to H
1,328 the second argument is the
criteria range this denotes the range
that contains the required criteria here
we will pass the range that holds
salesman's name Sals E4 to e
1,328 the third argument is criteria
this corresponds to our required
criteria we only require net sales of
the salesman Justin so we will select
sell and
4 finally close the parenthesis note
that we can pass multiple criteria in
this function the function Returns the
net sales done by
Justin countifs function Works in a
similar manner like some ifs it counts
the number of sales in a given range
when certain criteria is met say in the
given sales table we want to determine
the total number of sales for net sales
greater than 8,000 to determine the
count we will use the count ifs function
so let's write the formula in cell N5
type the equal sign then type the
function name count ifs and then type an
open parentheses the first argument is
the criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales H4 to H
1,328 the second argument is criter IA 1
this corresponds to our required
criteria we only require entries with
net sales greater than 8,000 so we will
enter greater than 8,000 finally close
the
parentheses note that the function
allows you to enter multiple criteria
cell N5 reflects the total number of
sales as
445 for net sales greater than
8,000 in this topic we will learn how to
use the functions percentile quartile
stand standard deviation and median in
Excel consider the given sales table
let's see how to use the percentile
function on that sales to find its 40th
percentile select the cell n6 write the
formula as equal sign percentile Open
Bracket select the column net sales H4
to H
1328 as our first argument pass the
second argument as 0.4 in order to find
the 40th percentile
this Returns the result
5,220 this means that 40% of the net
sales is less than or equal to
5,220 the next function is quartile
quartile function depicts the results
for the first 2 third and fourth
quartile say we want to find the total
number of sales which are less than or
equal to
25% let's use the quartile function to
calculate this select cell N7 to write
the
formula type equal sign function name is
quartile and open
braces select net sales column H4 to H
1328 as the first
argument type one as the second
argument the second argument must be a
number between 0 and 4 the function
Returns the value as
3,822 which means that 25% of the sale
is less than or equal to
3,822 note that here we can use a
percentile function to perform the same
task the function percentile H4 to H
1328 comma
0.25 gives us the same result it's up to
us which function we would like to use
for the
quartiles Excel has a function to
calculate sample standard deviations
stde V
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean say
we want to calculate the standard
deviation for number of
customers so write the formula in cell
N8 as equals the function name
STD open
braces select number of customers
columns as its
argument the function Returns the result
1.4 the median function Returns the
value from the range for example we want
to find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in cell N9 write the
formula as equal sign the function name
median then open braces select net sales
column as its
argument
this calculates the midv value of net
sales as
6,192 rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in a
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function Returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales select cell j4
and write the formula as
equal sign then type the function name
rank and then type an open parenthesis
the first argument is the number this is
the value whose rank we are required to
calculate here we will pass the argument
cell H4 the second argument is ref this
corresponds to the array or reference
list here we will select the column net
sales I.E sells H4 to H
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and one denotes
ascending order this argument is
optional if we don't pass any argument
Exel automatically takes the argument
zero here we will pass zero finally
close the par pareses here we can see
that Excel has determined the rank for
net sales
7,164 as
553 finally we can drag the formula and
can see the rank for the other celles
based on net
sales to get into the business analysis
domain we bring you topnotch courses to
become a skilled business analyst
from the best universities around the
globe so what are you waiting for hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box so what is Excel
macro you do certain daily task and
daily reports or monthly reports that
you generate and you use data from your
Excel and use scrub data and you
basically have the same things performed
or done on the Excel sheets every time
and every day or monthly or bi-weekly or
any number of times that you open your
Excel you remove certain columns you add
certain things and you change certain
values and these are the things that you
do an N number of times on an Excel and
this can all be done by simple
automated way which is macros so what it
does is it is a set of tasks that you
can execute as many number of times as
you want when you create a macro
basically what it does is it will record
all your mouse clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it and extract certain data and
remove certain columns that you do every
time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the obsolute values of of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add sear things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
in a simple running script called macros
so what you do is you record those Mouse
clicks and keystrokes and record a macro
for it say save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros and this will do everything for
you and you do not have to do that same
tedious task every day so this is
basically a set of codes or a task that
you can execute and automate and which
can be done a number of times so it
makes your life easy now so next thing
is how you actually activate the macros
in your Excel it's simple uh tab that
you need to add in the ribbon section
which I'll be showing you across and
this will enable the macros on your
Excel so you go to
files good options and then you need to
customize a ribbon click customize
ribbon and then there is a developer tab
which you see here it should be
activated so you just need to select
that click on the the tick mark and just
click okay so this will add a developer
tab here and this will enable the macros
so now you you have your data and you
can run macros or record a macro and run
it over on your
Excel there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your ma macros
from here so this is two ways that you
need to that you can activate your
Macros so how you record a macro is the
next thing so here I have a workorders
sheet that I receive every day or one of
you will receive every day and how you
record a macro you have certain set of
task that you do and you know this
report has so many things that are
obsolete which you do not need which has
to be put across uh to your management
or your for your use so how you record
or uh uh start a macro you go to the
developer tab and start recording a
macro as soon as you click on this
record macro button it will start uh
recording your key strokes on the mouse
mouse clicks and you can save that and
run it as a script in the next sheet
that you do so this is the sheet that I
have and we'll try to run a macros on
this and see what it
does so here I have and uh this actually
works this way uh I need to go to the
developer tab and start recording a
macro so when I click record macro it uh
starts uh recording my mouse clicks and
key strokes so in this sheet I have to
you know remove some columns and uh the
columns that are Obsolete and the data
that looks uh weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the
workorder number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the request date
work date the cost and the payment so
this is what I want and I do it every
day when I receive the sheet and I have
to make these changes and send it across
to the accounts team so what I do is I
simply automate this by running a macro
so I go
to let's see how it records the
macro I click record macro I save it as
work
order
accounts and I'll add a little
description
like work
order for
account
team
cost click okay
and see what I do is basically I add the
borders
first so that the data looks proper and
then I do not want this column I delete
it I do not want the number of
technicians that are there I do not want
all these and I also want the labor R
the account and what kind of payment
this is very crucial for the account
scheme I do not want any of these
obsolete
data so I just delete this okay and then
I just want to have some cosmetic
changes done
so I make sure this doesn't have any
border and that's it this is the task
that I
perform every day right still don't need
this and I go to the developer tab and
click stop recording so now I have the
macro sa and when I have it I have you
know automated these all these steps in
one simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you the next thing so here I have the
next uh report that has to be uh changed
or formatted and send it across so I
simply go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro Save which we ran the
just now and I simple with a single
click I will be able to do these daily
task and execute in a Flash so I just
click run and it does the rest for me I
have my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running a simple
macro continuing our uh work on macro we
can simply do this by a single click of
a button by adding a button so what you
have to do is go to the developer tab
and in the control section you will see
the insert option when you click on the
insert drop down you will see uh form
controls and you can say select a button
and here I select a button and the mouse
uh changes into a cross and you can add
your macro and assign it so as we have
saved it work order accounts as a macro
and when I just uh assign that macro to
this button I can edit the text
by making it as work order account just
to make it simple
okay and now if you see if I just click
this button it will run the
macro and format our sheet so this is
how we run the macros in a single click
of a button by adding the
button there is another alternative way
to go to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your macro so when I click
view macros it will show you what are
the macros that I have and that I can
run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab okay the next
thing is to edit the macro how do you
edit your macro you have uh to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
BBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another
window like this and you will see the
module that you have been working on and
you can edit the macro here so as we see
if you go back to the Excel we see that
uh our sheet we have been working on um
the sheet and it has the column still K
and the actual sheet is this so if I go
to the Visual Basic
editor and I'll make sure you know I
remove the columns that are existing
from the column M and I just delete that
and I click
run I go back to my sheet and you see
these changes are not there
okay this is our old macro and this is
our new
macro as we see this sheet has the rush
column which is the priority of my
orders so these are the things that we
can edit with the
VBA so here we are what is VBA Visual
Basic application it is basically a
Visual Basic application language uh
that is used for macros in Excel so what
it basically does Visual Basic for
application is a programming language of
excel that helps you automate task by
writing macros we have seen how we use
macros how it simplifies our tedious
daily task by running a simple macro now
to help us you know write these macros
and help us get the best use of our
abilities
to ease our work and automate our task
we use
VBA so why VBA there are many advantages
of using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel so basically it is a
very simple language it saves time in
Pro performing tedious task you have
number of tasks that you do every day as
we have seen in the previous section how
we uh you can simplify your daily task
by just running a simple macro and this
VBA helps us in performing those tasks
in a very simple manner another thing is
it supports english- like statements
there are multiple statements that you
can use and which are very basic English
language statements and this can help us
or it is very easy to program or code or
edit these commands you can select a
range you can it is like a if and L
statement and things like that we'll
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple function
that you perform in Excel like selecting
a number of rows or columns or selecting
a set of cells in particular you do it
on a daily basis so these things can
easily be performed and easily be edited
and executed by using VBA we will look
into those in detail now what is the VBA
editor interface this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have a look
in detail uh where where you can edit
your commands or your codes for your
Excel now how this is uh achieved we
will see it here now these are the this
is basically the VBA editor interface
where you can see the uh this is the
tool bar section where it shows all the
options where undo or save or file
we'll see those details in the next
section this is basically the toolbar
section of the VBA editor interface the
next thing is the menu bar menu bar as
we all know it is simply shows you the
menu wherein you have all the options
like file edit view insert insert is the
one very important uh menu bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all we'll look
into those in details run is one more
important thing all these things fall
under menu bar the next thing is the VBA
code window VBA code window as it says
is the code window where your actual
code resides where in you can go into it
and edit the codes or write the codes
and select the different range of
functions that you can perform and this
is basically the VDB VBA code window
where you edit your or write your codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the the Excel sheets or
the worksheets that you're working on or
the modules that you have saved and so
on basically it is an Explorer for your
PBA like a Windows Explorer which is for
the file explorer the next thing is the
properties window properties window
shows you the properties of the
worksheet that you're working on for
instance here we are working on the
sheet two and it shows the properties
what are the kind of uh uh worksheet
that we have the page breaks the right
to left whether it is enabled or not the
name of the sheet and so on whether it's
visible and things like that the next
thing is the immediate window and the
watch
window now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple lines of course individual Excel
code that you can run it will allow you
to test individual lines which is very
useful and handy when you're writing and
the buing codes uh the output of the uh
lines that you execute can be seen here
in the immediate window whereas watch
Window watch window is similar to it but
it displays the value of the watch
expression in its current current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the use the advantages of
having a watch window in your uh VBA
interface so these are the things that
we'll learn and look into it in detail
in the coming section now we continue
our topic for visual basic for
application for macros and uh I'm going
to show you how to you know run some
codes and run some macros in the codes
and perform some simple to complex task
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and uh first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
just just press and it will open the
um Visual Basic for application window
or alternatively you can just go and
click on the Visual Basic and it will
open the sheet F I mean the code window
F and as we have discussed before these
are the windows that we see this is the
code window and this is the project
Explorer and this is the immediate
window where will we can run some
testing codes immediately it will show
you the output so here where we see the
project Explorer window where we see the
modules and all for our Visual Basic for
applications so as we see the code is
empty here we'll try to record a macro
and see uh how the code develops okay so
I just go here and click uh record
macro and I save it
as
format and
columns
okay T bre can I just save it click okay
and it has started recording so now what
I'll do is I make it simple and I just
delete some columns
here okay I do not need this I delete
this is there a wait I want this I want
the mode of payment parts cost labor
hours I do not want this number of
technicians forget it
okay and I go forther left and see what
all do I need I need I don't need this I
delete all these
and I just expand this so that it's
clearly
visible and then I want to change the
format I mean the font so I select
this and I change it to time
room
okay go back to my developer tab click
stop recording it is
saved
okay now I go back to my
code and see the macro here so we see
the macro here and we can see uh in
detail what it looks like so we see the
code what it's doing and where the macro
run has generated the code with so we
see we have basically the name of the
macro is format columns and what it is
doing we just selecting The Columns and
deleting some we checking the range on
some columns e select that is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 11 so it is basically a basic VBA
code so it starts with a sub and it
should end with end sub so this is the
code or a format of the VBA code that it
looks like and we'll try to do some
basic functions with the VBA and discuss
this in further details so for ease of
explanation I have picked up a blank uh
spreadsheet and uh I'll try to explain
some basic uh uh functions and the
commands and the codes that we use to
accomplish the task that we with
VBA so as we see this is the blank sheet
and I have selected a new module for
it so here I uh start the code and as it
says it starts with sub and I am
specifying the the module name as a
number so I'll just try to make it quite
simple and you know so we as soon as we
enter the sub it it sends with the end
sub and so this is the uh start of the
code and this is the end of the code and
whatever is there should be here and
this is the name of the code of the
macro now uh I'll explain it further
about the dim statement why is it used
and what is it Ed for so dim is
basically a keyword which is the a short
form of Dimension and it is used to
declare a variables in the VBA so here I
am trying to specify uh a variable
called X and how I'm going to do it I
will has have it as a number or an
integer or anything so here in this
example I'll put it as an integer or a
number okay and as I put as it populates
the prompt so I select integer and for
example I select the number to
be
500 okay and here I'm trying to assign
assign a variable integer a a cell a
value of 500 with the dim keyword so
where exactly I want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay range I am selecting it should be
under codes where I'm going to put the
value of x as and I close the backet and
what should be the value we will
value should be X so now as I click run
sub or you can do it with the by running
the alt or F5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the uh Dimension
keyboard or dim
keyword and you can can assign the value
as integers now proceed we proceed
further with certain more example some
more examples and how we assign the
string value as a as a text or something
else okay now I'm going to show you what
dim can be exec I mean used as to set
variables dim can be used as a uh double
where double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses uh needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can
set double and I just uh don't specify
it and you can use date it's basically
stores the date values okay and then
again string so what string does if you
use string it stores the text it can
contain numbers it will have some text
as calculations or anything can be
performed so these are the basic thing
that I will cover
and you can also use different uh values
for it so I will discuss this in the
next
example
okay so in the next example I'll try to
sub or use a string value for it and I
put it as string sub
string uh
[Music]
value this is my name so as soon as I
hit enter it ends with the Ender promp
and now I can get my code so I put it as
dbook as
[Music]
string okay now I'm trying to use uh uh
uh to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the sales so so let's
see how it goes and I select country and
in country I select
ma okay now what is the value or the
cell that basically takes the or we will
put the name of the country as so I have
to specify a range and as soon as I hit
it goes and I have to specify
the the cell here so here I put it as
G and four okay so I close
it and I put a value to it what value I
am going to assign it is a
country
okay now I try to run this code by
simply and see G4 the name populates as
a country here so this is uh dim keyword
being used as a string in our VBA code
so uh we can also use uh VBA to you know
pop up a message or an alert or a kind
of a button or a message pop up pops up
when you execute this code so this
basically can be uh executed using uh
the code here which I'm going to
put and we use the
okay let's give it a
value I'm going to name it as double
value and again the keyword I'm going to
use the keyword as double okay why
double is used is basically uh it gives
a longer it can be used for a longer
form of single variable takes it usually
takes more space and larger numbers and
we'll try to assign it okay now I'm
going to pop up a message in the which
says value of a is so and so so I'm
going to give value of a
as
250 okay and how I it pops up a message
okay so there is a message
box which you know can be used and it
will give you a value I mean uh it will
prompt you to enter the value what kind
of button you want and you you can enter
the text and you can enter the value so
here I'm going to uh write a code which
you know which gives a popup message a
message box saying that the value of a
is so and
so value of a is I'm going to put it in
in percent code so it actually takes the
value of a okay okay now that's it and
let's try to run this and you will see a
message box popping message box popping
up okay so the value of a the message
box pops up saying the value of a is 250
so in the next example I am going to
write a code where in you know you can
give a value or a string you can assign
it to a selected cell and this basically
used when you have some you know when
you have a a task of you know giving a
value to a particular cell or you have
to assign a text or say something about
a report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use
the I will say it
as fun with some
procedures
this is the name and again
name so here I am giving to I'm going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give any I mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it
[Music]
here
course this is the report
for ABQ let's make it
simple okay and where I'm going to put
it is in the active cell or the cell
that
I have it select okay what will be the
value the value will be the user
input I have defined user input as this
is a report for VBA so this cell turns
into you this is a report for
VBA I run this and you see
this so in some cases you need to run
this and you know it makes life quite
simple when you use VBA for this as we
have seen before we have used message
box now I'm going to use the same
message box uh to display my name or you
can use it to display your name so so
let's see how it goes I'm going to name
it as
name okay and it's very simple you have
to define a message
box which displays your
name and I'm going to put it under codes
that my name is
a and we'll try to run
[Music]
it
see
here so it pops a a message saying that
my name is it fun so this is a message
box that you can display and I can do
anything with
[Music]
this this is a
PBA B6
[Music]
Workshop okay I run it again and it pops
this message so these are the things
that you can use to customize or you
know when you open an Excel sheet or try
to run a workshop or a report and it
pops up a message customary welcome
messages that you can customize or you
know Define a she report or kind of data
in it and this can be used using uh run
using the message
box now I have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of uh a
cell or what is the number that is there
in the cell so here it is I put it as
sub okay
number and it will again populate a
message
box which will set it to
the the
entered value is and it should tell
me which or I specify which cell it is
that we are going to find the value of
okay so I give a
range
of I have to give it in codes I'm going
to
code
completed and it should tell me the
value of the number that is present in
the cell
A1
okay it end let's try to run
it run it and it will give me the value
so this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
uh number that is there in the cell so
here I can change it
to a
four as well and try to run it and it
will give me the number so this is
simple way of you know populating a
message box which will tell us
the value of
a uh let me show you one more simple
example where in a message box pops up
or a welcome message that can be popped
set when you open the uh Excel or
worksheet so so let's uh name it as
Auto
open and then again message box I want
it to populate and what does it
say I put it in codes
Welcome to
our
worksheet um
Workshop it's very simple you just run
it
and see it pops up a message saying
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to simple
welcome message on
Excel next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or a sign a
value to a particular cell by
simple
cured so we name it as add
value now I specify the range I mean
where I'm going to specify a
cell where the value will be given to
the cell now I'm going to give it as
V5 okay I put it in codes close the
parenthesis what is the value that I'm
going to give value
equals
250 okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's
see run it
see again I do it to V 10
okay so this is how you can assign a
value to a particular
cell now I can run uh the same thing and
give a range of cells I mean let me make
it very simple
here
B I give it as
B1 through
b
five
as 450 so let's see what it does see
here I'm going I'm specifying the range
to be B1 through B5 so it is doing it
for the whole
range okay and
then and then I can give a another set
of range here like uh let me specify
it range to
be
C1 I have to give it a course otherwi it
will give me an error C
colon
C4 and I separate it with a comma and I
can specify another range so the next
one will be
D1 2
D4 and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis what is the value that I
give
is let's
say 2 3
Z and I try to run it so it gives the
value of C1 through C4 and D1 through D4
as 230 as we specified in the code so
this is one of one more example wherein
you can assign values to to
the uh so range of cells or cells with
the
BBA one more thing I can U you know
assign a value to a particular cell by
specifying these cells it's very simple
just specify the cells
like
six Comm 7
okay and I close the
parenthesis I assign a value to it
value equals 10 let's
see see here it assigns the value to
that particular cell that we have
specified row six and column 7 okay so
this is one more uh example wherein you
can assign values to particular
cells okay in the next example uh there
will be a scenario where in you need to
select a range of cells in a sheet so
this can also be done this task can also
be performed using vpa so I will show
you
how this is
our let's say
select
range okay and
uh and I am going to set a dim variable
as example okay let's say it as example
and what I'm doing is I'm specifying a r
range because I need to select a range
of cells okay now I'm going to set the
variable
as set example where I'm going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a
One
D
five okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going
to set the value okay I am going to set
a value
example I'm going to give it a value of
256 so let's see how it pans
out okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task where in
you know there is where will be a
scenario where in you have to select a
set of cells and give give a value to it
so you can do it with a click of a
button with the vpa now I can simply
tweak this with the you know by just
selecting it so there
is I'll remove
this and instead of assigning a value I
just put an option to select
it now let's just run it and see what
happens
next okay so this is one way of you know
just selecting it okay and then it's it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some function in so you can uh select
this and you can assign a value and you
can also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
codes now what if I want to do a
selection of the same rows and columns
in the next sheet and I can do this with
the set of another set of command so I
will show you how so here let's say you
know we set the same thing and we
specify the worksheets okay
worksheets I want it in sheet two okay
so I just put it sheet to and I activate
it basically activating it and now I'm
I'm going to specify the
worksheet two and what is the range that
I'm going to select the same thing okay
the range will
be
A1 to
D5 okay what I'm going to do I'm going
to select
it okay and see what happens here
okay P so here I am selecting the
worksheet to and I'm activating it and
I'm going to assign range and I'm going
to select it so I can just copy the same
or select the same set of cells in the
next sheet okay now when there will be
as I said there will be you know a
requirement where you need to copy some
sell contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's again a
simple code that you can write and let's
say let's say it as a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
[Music]
relate
copy
past okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to select this range and I'm going
to copy it and paste it somewhere here
okay so let me just remove this and I'll
show you how first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again
A1 should be in
COD call
[Music]
D5
course and I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it okay
so I just uh set that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the column here uh let's say
G uh
10 okay and close
it I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active
sheet and paste it so we are selecting a
range of cells selection and that
selection ction what we are doing is we
will copy it and now we are going to
specify the range where you are going to
select it and then paste it quite simple
let's okay
see
and you can just change it to so it is
visible on
this
G5
okay so this makes uh quite easy and you
can run it uh the next scenario will be
like when you need to get the count of
the number of cells like you have to
have a selection and you need to count
the number of cells so this can also be
done and it's quite easy I am going to
show it to
you let's say the
subb
count
SS should always be relatable so that
you know you remember and you understand
what is the output and why you're using
it and I'm going to set a variable let's
say I'm going to set an example for this
and what we are going to do is we are
going to specify a range first okay we
we will specify the range of the cells
that we are going to that we need to
count basically so I'm going to set a
variable as a range and then what we are
going to do
is
example and we specify the range
here you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the where you
need the count of the number of cells so
E1 colum D5
hes this is n now how you want the
output you want it you want a message
box to pop up so you will we will set a
message
box
and what should it give will give you
the count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples okay so it
will count the number of cells in this
area Okay uh let's see it
says okay here I think I missed it so I
just specify the number here and let's
see so it gives you the number of count
in this 20
okay now let's see I want
to
six so it gives you the selection so
it's quite simple it will be very useful
in our daily task and where you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it well I can further tweak
this and to determine the
or to count the number of rows or
columns so it's again very simple I just
need to do some changes here I have to
set the column
count so if I want to calculate the
number of
columns
just
let's see how it it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
here see it gives there are five columns
okay 1 two 1 2 3 4 five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to should give
me four col okay similarly you can count
the number of rows
here just change to
rows see say six rows are
there
okay should give me
m see so this way you can calculate the
number of uh count the number of uh
cells number of columns number of rows
with
this the next thing I'm going to talk
about is the if statement if statement
is one of the the most widely used
statement and whoever is in programming
are very much familiar with this
function so what it does is we specify a
condition if a condition is met then the
out output should be such and such we
can specify the condition and it will
check whether that condition is there
and if it is uh spe mean if it is
achieved then you will have to specify
the output as well so this can be
achieved with the if
statement okay and it is very easy
because it is it understand the basic uh
English language so it's not very
complicated and I'll show you how so the
syntax can be like this if suppose you
specify a condition and if that
condition is met then the result you
specify the condition and the result for
it okay so this is one thing and then
you can specify the else or else
condition where you know you specify the
condition two then the result should
be
this so here you are going to specify
two conditions or multiple conditions
wherein you
specify this and if it is there then
result will be this if it is this
condition and then the result will be
something else let's take an example
where in you have to you have some
scores or
marks and you have to select the result
you can't do this manually entering so
just you can write a code suppose for
example I have it
here okay let's
show and I specify
is
if
statement okay now I have to specify the
variables now I have two variables I
have a score and I have a result and the
score is an integer the number and the
result is a string pass or fail so I
specify this okay dim
score I specify it as integer okay and
then there's another variable that I
have to set
result
as
string
okay now what the score will be the
score I have to specify the range score
I'm giving it as a range I mean the
it's in
my cell
A1
okay I specify the range what is it it
is a
value
okay
sorry should be a
do okay and then I'm specifying a
condition here if score the
variable is greater than or equal so as
I said it's quite simple and it takes
the basic English uh language
functions
then the result result is another
variable that I have said result what it
should be it should be in codes
pass okay so if this condition is met
then the result will be this okay and
now where I want to specify my result I
should give a range for that as well so
I give it in the next column or
anyone this is the basic uh
example value should be the
result okay let's see how it
runs see say
pass change it to
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay change to 75 let's see
HRS see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifying the
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be
pass now in the next uh section uh we
will simply tweak this and use an if
then else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's uh stick to the same
values and now um I'm going to specify
it and if the score is greater than
60 then the
result so the result will be pass as it
is before and
then I'm going to specify another
condition here
else the result should
be
should
three okay and now I have to put it as a
end if statement I have to specify the
end and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be B1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is pass otherwise it is
fake okay this pass let's see
and run it
again so okay so we are specifying two
variables again we are giving it a range
and we are specifying one condition if
this condition is met the result is
passed otherwise else it is failed so
another set of
example uh the next uh statement that we
use uh or we going to discuss is is the
loop statement that is the for Loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations and uh task that
you need to execute and you need to do
it several number of times these are
basically executed sequentially it means
one after another so the first statement
of the function is executed and the next
is taken up so and then the next and so
on so these uh loop statements allow us
to execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first uh task
is done and it executes that and it goes
to the next one so here we'll discuss a
simple example of the for Loop
statement so let's see how it works and
I'm going to set up a loop statement
okay again the
I'm going to make it as Loop one so here
it is I have to specify the uh variable
that is
dim and I'm going to specify X as an
integer okay I'll try to execute it and
then explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1
2.4 okay let's see and I'm going to
specify the
range range as so what I'm going to do
is basically I'm going to fill the
column A from 1 to 24 with some value
from 1 to 24 with the values of 1
through 24 okay so I'm setting up a
range and How It Ends is it gives me a
value now it takes use this and goes to
the next so I'll explain you how it so
we are setting up a loop we are setting
up a integer variable X as integer and
we are setting the value of x to be 1 to
24 so here for one it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as one and it
fills in A1 and then the next value of x
will be 2 and it goes to A2 and fills
the value as two so just let's try to
execute this and you will see the row
column A filled with 1 through
24 see it's quite simple it executes one
condition and then goes to the next and
we are defining it with the number of
values and the variable as X and the
number of values is 1 to be
24 okay so this is one basic example of
a per Loop
statement uh now let's do some more uh
addition to this uh uh example by you
know executing another set of for Loop
and giving the output and we'll code the
output to be the color coded once in the
column B so how we do it it's a basic
simple example that I'm going to take
and again what I'm going to do is I will
have this values here and I'm going to
col code the B column with certain color
index for each number there will be a
different color so let's see and what
I'm going to do is I'm only going to
change the
B and what action is going here we put
up a value now we going to select it and
with this
selection what I'm going to do is it
should select it and it should color the
interior with
what
with the color index
okay and the value of
x and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the box to be colored and I'm going to
put it as a
solid it will fill the whole thing with
the
solid and then then I just executed see
it takes
this color
B let's coded like this so these are the
simple things that you can set up with
the codes and for Loop statements so
there are numerous examples and
exercises that we can perform task we
can perform with the
BBA and uh this can be a found in detail
now next courses Advanced courses to get
into the business anal is domain we
bring you topnotch courses to become a
skilled business analyst from the best
universities around the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
Now find the cost Link in the
description box So currently I am on my
MySQL workbench let me connect to the
local instance so I'll give my
password I'll click on okay all right so
this is my MySQL workbench query editor
so first we are going to learn
subqueries let me give a
comment and write
subqueries all right so first of all
let's understand what a subquery is so a
subquery is a query within another SQL
query that is embedded within the where
Clause from clause or having
Clause so we'll explore a few scenarios
where we can use subqueries so for that
I'll be using my database that is SQL
intro so I'll write my command use
SQL intro now this database has a lot of
tables I'll be using the employees table
that is present inside SQL intro Let me
just expand this and you can see here we
have an employees table so let me first
show you the contents within this table
I'll write select star from
employees let me execute it okay you can
can see here we have the employee ID
employee name age gender there's date of
join Department City and salary and we
have information for 20 employees if I
scroll down you can see there are 20
employees present in our table so let's
say you want to find the employees whose
salary is greater than the average
salary in such a scenario you can use a
subquery so let me show you how to write
a
subquery I'll write the select
statement in the select statement I'll
pass my column names that I want to
display so the column names I want are
the employee name then I want the
department of the employee and the
salary of the employee from my table
name that is
employees next I'll use a where
condition
where my salary should be greater than
the average salary of all the employees
so I'll write salary greater than
after this I'm going to write my
subquery so I'll give
select average of salary from my table
name that is employees and I'll close
the bracket and give a
semicolon so what it does is first it is
going to find the average salary of all
the employees that are present in our
table once we get the average salary
number we'll use this wear condition
where salary is greater than the average
salary number
so the inside subquery let me run it
first if I run this this gives you the
average salary of all the employees
which is
$75,400
now I want to display all the employees
who have salary greater than
$75,400 so let's run our
subquery there you go so there are eight
employees in our table who have a salary
greater than the average salary of all
the
employees all
right next let's see another
example suppose this time you want to
find the employees whose salary is
greater than John's
salary so we have one employee whose
name is
John let
me run the table once again
okay if I scroll down you see we have an
employee as John you see this our
employee ID 116 is John and his salary
is
$67,000 I want to display all the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary so basically all the
employees who are earning more than
$65,000 I want to print them so let's
see how to do it I'll write
select I want the employee name comma
the gender of the
employee I also want the department and
salary from my table name that is
employees I'll write where salary is
greater
than I'll start
my opening bracket inside the bracket
I'm going to give my inner query that is
Select
salary from
employees
where the employee name is John So
within single quotations I'll give John
as my
employee I'll end with a
semicolon so let me first run my inner
query so this will give us the salary
that John has which is
$67,000 now I want the employees who are
earning more than
$67,000 so let's run our
subquery okay so you can see 12 rows
returned which means there are 12
employees in our table who are earning
more than
$67,000 you see here all these employees
have a salary greater than
$67,000
okay
now you can also use
subqueries with two different tables so
suppose you want to display some
information that are present in two
different tables you can use subqueries
to do that
so for this example we'll use a database
that is called classic models you can
see the first
database so let me use this database
called classic models I'll write use
classic
models now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website site I'll just show
you the website name so this is the
website that is MySQL tutorial.org you
can see here they have very
nice articles blogs from where you can
learn my SQL in detail so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website you see here
they have a MySQL sample database if you
click on this it will take you to the
link where you can download the database
so they have this download link which
says download my SQL sample database and
the name of the database is classic
Models All right so we are going to use
this classic models database throughout
our demo session if I expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have Cricket
customers there's employees office
there's orders order lines and many more
so for our subquery we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table first let me show you the
content that is present
inside the products table
first if I run this you see here it says
110 rows returned which means there are
110 different products that are present
in our table which has the product code
the product name product line we have
the product vendor description quantity
in stock Buy price
MSRP the other table we are going to use
is order details which has the details
of all the
orders let me show you the
records order details tables has okay so
there are thousand records present in
this table you have the order number the
product code quantity ordered price of
each item you have the order line number
as well okay
now we want to know the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products whose price of each product is
less than $100 for this scenario we are
going to use two different tables and we
are going to write a
subquery
okay so if you see here in the order
details table we have a column called
price each I want want to display the
product code the product name and the
MSRP of the products which have a price
of each product less than
$100 so the way I'm going to do is I'll
write
select product code
comma product name now one thing to
remember that this product name is
actually present inside our products
table and product code is present in
both the tables that is products and
Order details here you can see this is
the product code column comma MSRP which
is present inside the products table
again from my table that is
products
where I'll
write
product
code I'm going to use the in
operator next I'll write my inner query
that is
Select product code from my table order
details
where my price of each
product is less than
$100 let me run
this okay so you can see there are total
83 products in our table which
have a price less than $100 you can see
see the price
here
okay now we learn another Advanced
Concept in SQL which is known as stored
procedures I'll just give a comment
saying stored
procedure
okay so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure a stored procedure is
an SQL code that you can save so that
the code can be reused over and over
again so if you want to write a query
over and over again save it as a stored
procedure and then call it to execute
it so in this example I want to create a
stored procedure that will return the
list of players who have scored more
than six goals in a tournament so I have
a database called SQL IQ these are a few
databases that I've already created so
this database has a table called players
if if I expand the tables option you see
we have a table called players and you
can see the columns player ID the name
of the player the country to which the
player belongs to and the number of
goals each player has scored in a
particular tournament so I'll write a
store procedure that will return the
list of top players who have scored more
than six goals in a tournament so first
of all let me Begin by using my SQL IQ
database
we'll run
it so now we are inside the SQL IQ
database let
me
select star from players to show
the values that we have in the players
table you can see there are six players
in our
table we have the player ID the names of
the players the country to which these
players players belong to and the goals
they have
scored so I'll write a stored
procedure so the stored procedure syntax
is something like this it should start
with a D
limiter okay in the D limiter I'll write
Amberson
Amberson next I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
I want to name my procedure as top _
players next statement is
begin after begin I'll write my select
statement I want to select the name of
the
player the
country and the goals each player has
scored from my table that is
players
where I'll write goals is greater than
six we give a
semicolon then I'll end
my procedure with a d limiter that was
double
Amberson next I'll write D
limiter and give
a
semicolon now the semicolon
suggests this is a default
delimiter and there should be a space
okay now let's run our stored
procedure there you go so you have
successfully created a store procedure
now the way to run a store procedure is
you need to use the call method and give
the procedure name that is is top
underscore players in our case with
brackets and a
semicolon let's execute it okay there is
some problem
here so we made a mistake while creating
a procedure the name of the column is
goals and not
goal let me create that procedure
again okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just edit the procedure name instead of
top player we'll write it as top players
and similarly we'll edit here as well
now let's create it
again okay now to call my procedure I'll
write call space followed by the
procedure name which is toop _ players
if I run this you can see we have two
players in our table who have scored
more than six goals so we consider them
as as the top players in a particular
tournament all
right now there are other methods that
you can use while creating a stored
procedure one of the methods is by using
an in parameter so when you define an in
parameter inside a stored procedure the
calling program has to pass an argument
to the stored
procedure so I'll give a
comment stored procedure using in
parameter
all right so for this example I'll
create a procedure that will fetch or
display the top records of employees
based on their
salaries so if we have a
table in our SQL IQ database which is
called employee
details I'm going to use this table you
can see we have the name of the employee
the age sex then we have the date of
join City and salary using this table
I'll create a procedure that will fetch
or display the top records of employees
based on their
salaries and we'll use the in parameter
so let me show you how to do it I'll
write
delimiter this time I'm going to use
forward
slash I'll write
create
procedure followed by the procedure name
let's say SP for stor procedure sort by
salary is the name of my procedure
procedure and inside this procedure I'll
give my
parameter in I'll create a variable V
and assign a data type
integer then I'll write
begin followed by my select statement
where I'll select the name
age
salary
from my table name that is EMP details
or employee
details I'm going to order this
by salary
descending
and I want to display limited number of
Records so I'm using
this limit keyword and my variable V
which I created
here I end my select
statement I'll end my stor procedure
with forward slash
and I'll go back to my default delimiter
that is
semicolon all
right so let me run
this there should be a space here all
right so let's run
this okay you can see we have
successfully created our second store
procedure which is Spore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the St
procedure was created or not here you
have an option to see the stored
procedures let me just refresh
this and you can see we
have three stored procedures that we
have created so far one is sp Spore sort
by salary the other two were topor
player and topor players okay now let's
call our stored procedure I'll write
call space followed by the stor
procedure name which is a
Spore
sort by
salary and inside this I'll give my
parameter which was actually V and this
V we have used in limit let's say I want
to display only the top three records of
the employees who have the top three
highest
salaries okay so let me run
it there you go so Amy Sara and Jimmy
were the top three employees who have
the highest salary so you saw how you
could use the in parameter in a stored
procedure we created a variable and that
variable we used in our select statement
and we called our stored procedure and
passed in that
variable
okay
now instead of a select statement in
inside a stored procedure you can also
use other statements let's say
update so I'll create a stored procedure
to update the salary of a particular
employee so in this procedure instead of
Select statement we'll use the update
command in this example we'll use the in
operator twice so let me show you how to
do it I'll write my D limiter first
which is going to be forward slash then
I'll write create
procedure my name of the procedure is
going to be update
salary and inside the update salary name
I'll write
in and then
temp underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
I'll assign is varar
20 I'll again use my parameter I'll
write
in
next my other variable would be newcore
salary and the data type would be
float I'll write
begin and write my update command or
update statement I'll write
update table name that is employee
details
set salary
equal
to newcore
salary
where name is equal
to my temporary variable that is tempore
name so this is my update command and
I'll end the
delimiter all right so let's run
this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure if I refresh this you
can see I have my stored procedure
update _
salary okay now let's
say first of all
I'll display my records that are present
inside employee _ details table okay so
we have six rows of information let's
say you want to update the salary of
employee Jimmy or let's say Mary from
70,000 to let's say
72,000 or let's say 880,000 so I'll call
my store procedure that is update uncore
salary and this time I'm going to pass
in two parameters the first parameter
will be the employee name and next with
a comma I'll give my new salary that I
want
to so my employee name let's say is
Mary and the salary I want to be updated
is let's say
$80,000 I'll give a
semicolon and I'll run it you can see it
says one row affected now let's check
our table once again there you go you if
you see this record for Mary we have
successfully updated the salary to
$80,000 now moving ahead we learn to
create a stored procedure using the out
parameter so I'll give a
comment stor procedure using out
parameter okay so suppose we want to get
the count of total female
employees we will create total employees
as an output parameter and the data type
would be an in
the count of the female employees is
assigned to the output variable which is
total _ emps using the into keyword let
me show you how to write a stored
procedure using the out
parameter so first I'll declare my
delimiter to forward slash I'll
write
create
procedure followed by the procedure name
it is going to be SP
tore
count
employees and inside this I'm going to
give my out parameter and the variable
name that is total
underscore emps which is total employees
and the data type will be integer next
I'm going to write
begin followed by my select statement
that is Select I will want the count of
total
employees and the output I'm going to
put into my new variable that is total _
emps from my table that is
empore
details
where sex is equal to F which means
female I'll give a
semicolon next I'll end
it with the D limiter and I'm going to
change the D limiter to a default D
limiter that is
colon so let me tell you what I'm doing
here I'm creating a new stored procedure
that is Spore count employees using this
stored procedure I'm going to count the
total number of female employees that
are present in our table empore details
so I've used my out parameter and I'm
creating a new variable called total _
emps the data type is integer here in
the select statement I'm counting the
names of the employees and the result
I'm storing it in total _
emps I have used my wear condition where
the gender of the sex is female so let's
run
this okay so we have created our stored
procedure let's refresh this okay you
can see we we have a new stored
procedure Spore count
employees
now to call it I'll write
call the name of the procedure that is
countor Spore count
employes within brackets I'll pass in
the parameter as at the rate fcor
EMP I'll give a semicolon then I'll
write
select at the rate
fcor EMP as female
employees okay so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first I'll
call my procedure and then we'll display
the total number of female employees you
can see in our table we have three
female
employees all right now with this
understanding let's move on to our next
top Topic in this tutorial on Advanced
SQL now we are going to learn about
triggers in
SQL so I'll give a comment here triggers
in
SQL so first let's understand what is a
trigger so a trigger is a special type
of stored procedure that runs
automatically when an event occurs in
the database server there are mainly
three types of triggers in SQL we have
the data manipulation trigger we have
the data definition trigger and login
triggers in this example we will learn
how to use a before insert trigger so we
will create a simple students table that
will have the students role number the
age the name and the students marks so
before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero so in case the marks are less
than zero our trigger will automatically
set the marks to a random value let's
say
50 so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students all
right so I'll write
create
table
student now this table will have the
student role
number the data type is
integer it will have the age of the
students again the data type is integer
we have the names of the students so the
third column would be
name the data type would be variable or
varying
character size I'm giving it as 30
finally we have the marks as floating
type so let's create this table which is
student so we have created our
table
now I'll write my
trigger command so trigger command will
start with D limiter like how our usual
store procedures
have
next this time I'll write create
trigger then you need to give
the name of the trigger that is Mark
underscore let's say verif
by I'm going to use a before insert
trigger so I'll write before
insert on my table name that is
student next I'll write for each
row
if new DOT
marks is less than
zero
then we'll set
set new do marks equal to
50 so this is
my condition first we'll check before
inserting if any student has marks less
than zero we assign a value 50 to that
student because usually the marks are
not less than zero in any
exam I'll write end if semicolon and
I'll close the delimiter
so this is
my trigger command I'll run it it says
trigger already exists in this case we
need to update the trigger name let's
say I'll write maxor verify
uncore student for
STD let's run it
again okay there is an error here
because in our table the column name is
Mark and not marks so here we need to
change it as Mark instead of marks all
right let's run
it okay so we have created our
trigger
now let me insert a few records to the
student table so I'll write insert into
student I'll write
values we'll give the values as 501
which is the student role number the AG
is let's say 10 the name is let say
Ruth and the marks is let's say
Z give a comma we'll insert our second
student
record student role number is
502 age is
12 the name is let's say Mike
and this time I'm purposely giving a
value of minus
20.5 give another comma we'll insert the
third
record for student role number
503 AG is
13 the name is
Dave
and let's say the marks obtained by Dave
is
90 now we'll insert our final record for
student number
504 the age is
10 name I'll enter as
Jacobs and this time again I'm purposely
giving the marks in
negative 12 point let's say
5 I close the bracket and give a
semicolon and I'll run my insert
statement okay so we have inserted four
rows of information to our student
table
now let me run the select query I'll
write select star from
student if I run this you see the
difference there you go so originally we
had
inserted for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for
504 for Jacobs the marks was -
12.5 our trigger automatically converted
the negative marks to 50 because when we
created our trigger we had set our marks
to 50 in case the marks were less than
zero so this is how a trigger
works now you can also drop a trigger or
delete a trigger you can just write drop
trigger followed by the trigger name in
this case our trigger name
is marks _ verore
St I'll just paste this
here and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger I'll
give this as a comment
okay now moving
on now we are going to learn about
another crucial Concept in SQL which is
very widely used this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of Their Own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables I'll give a comment as views in
SQL
okay now to learn views I'm going to use
my table which is present inside classic
models database now this database as I
mentioned we had downloaded we had
downloaded it from the internet so first
of all let me write use classic models
so I'll switch my database
first all right now we are inside
classic models so here let me show you
one of the tables which is called
customers so I'll write select star from
customers okay I missed s
here let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name customer number we
have the address State country and other
information now I'll write a basic view
command using this customer table the
way to write is I'll write create
view followed by The View name which is
custor
details then you write
as select I'm going going to select a
few column names from my original
customer table which is this one so I
need the customer name let's say I need
the phone number and the city so you
have this information here you have the
phone number and the
city all right I'll write from my table
that is
customers if I run this my view that is
cust details will be
created let's run it there's some error
here because the name of the table is
customers and not customer I'll give an
S and I'll run it
again all right so you can see we have
created our
view and to display the contents that
are present inside our view I can write
select star from followed by The View
name that is custor
details let's run
it there you go so we have the customer
name the phone number and the City of
the different customers that we have in
our table all
right now let's learn how you can create
views using joins so we'll join two
different tables and create a view so
for that I'm going to use my products
table and the products lines table I'm
talking about the products table table
and the product lines table present
inside classic models database so before
I start let me display
the records that are present inside the
products
table let's run it so these are the
different products you can see
here now let's see what we have in
product lines
table so we have the product line the
text description and there's some HTML
description and image so I'll create a
view by joining these two tables and
we'll fetch specific records that are
present in both the tables so let me
first start by writing create view
followed by The View name that is
product
underscore
description as I'll
write
select product name name comma then I'll
quantity in
stock I also want the MSRP now these
three columns are present inside the
products table and next from the product
lines table I want the text description
of the products so I'll write
from products
table I'll give an alas as
P followed by Inner joint my other table
that is product lines as let's say PL
on the common column that is product
line so P
dot product
line is equal
to I'll give a space PL dot product line
okay so here we have used an inner joint
to fetch specific columns from both the
tables and our view name is productor
description let us run it all right so
we have our view ready now let me view
or display what is present inside our
product _
description view I add select star from
productor
description let's run
it there you go so we have the product
name the quantity in stock MSRP and
textual descriptions of the different
products in the
table okay now there are a few other
operations that you can perform let's
say you want to rename a view instead of
productor description you want to give
some the name so I'll just give a
comment rename
description so to rename a description
you can use the rename statement I'll
write rename
table product underscore description
which is
my old
name I want to change this name to let's
say I'll give vehicle description since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so I'll write vehicle
description okay let us run
it all right so here you can see I have
renamed
my view so here if I just refresh it and
I'll expand this you can see we have the
Cur details view and we have the vehicle
_ description View
okay now either you can view all the
views from this panel or you can use a
command let's
say I'll write display views is the
comment now to show all the views you
can use
show full
tables
where
table
underscore type is equal to to within
single code I'll write
view so this is the command that will
display all the views that are present
inside a
database there is
some error here let's debug the error
this should
be okay so instead of table types it
should be table type equal to view let's
run it you can see the two different
views that we have one is customer
details another is vehicle undor
description okay now you can also go
ahead and delete a
view for that you can use the drop
command so I'll write
drop view followed by The View name
let's say I want to delete customer _
details or custor details view I'll
write drop view
ccore
details let's run
it you can can see here we don't have
the custor details view
anymore all
right now moving to our final section in
this
demo here we will learn about Windows
functions Windows functions were
Incorporated in MySQL in the 8.0
version so Windows function in my SQL
are useful applications in solving
analytical problems so using the
employees table present inside my SQL
intro database so we'll find the total
combined salary of the employees for
each
department so first let me switch my
database to
SQL intro
database I'll run it okay I'll display
my table that is
employe so here we we have 20 employees
in our table using this
table we are going to find the combined
salary of the employees for each
department so we will partition our
table by department and print the total
salary and this we are going to do using
some windows functions in
MySQL so I'll write
select I want the employee
name the age of the
employee and the department of the
employee
comma next I'll
write the sum of
salary
over I want to partition it
by
department so I'll write Partition by
Department which is
DPP and I'll give an alas as total
salary so that it will create a new
column with the name total
salary from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time let's execute it and see the
result there you go so here we have
created another column in our result
that is total salary and for each of the
employees and the respective departments
we have the highest salary so in finance
the highest salary of one of the
employees was
$155,000 similarly if I come down we
have the highest salary from HR if I
scroll for further we have the highest
salary from it marketing product sales
and the tech Team all right now we'll
explore a function which is called row
number now the row number function gives
a sequential integer to every row within
its partition so let me show you how to
use the row number function I'll write
select rore number function
over
my column would
be salary so I'll write order by
salary I'll give
the alas as
ronam give a
comma and I want to display the employee
name and the salary of the employee from
my table that is
employees and I'll order
by
salary so let's see how our row number
function will create sequential integers
okay you can see here we have a row num
column and we have successfully given
row numbers to each of the records you
can see it starts from one and goes up
till
okay now this row number function can be
used to find duplicate values in a table
to to show that first I'll create a
table I'll write create
table let's say I'll give a random name
that is
demo and let's say we have in this table
the student ID which is of type integer
and we have the student
name which is of type
varar the size is 20 I'll create the
small table with a few records let's
create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so I'll write insert
into
demo
values I'll give one one the name is
Shane give a
comma I'll insert the second student
name one2 the name is
Bradley we give a comma
this time for 103 we have two records
let's say the name of the student is
her give a comma I'll copy
this and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated
103 next we have
104 the name of the student let's say is
Nathan then again let's see for
the fifth student which is Kevin we have
two
records I'll copy this and I'll paste it
here let me give a semicolon and we'll
insert these records to our table
demo all
right
now let me
just run this table for you I'll write
select star from demo
if you see this we have a few
information that are duplicated in our
table that is for student ID 103 and
student ID
105 now I'm going to use
my row number function to find the
duplicate records present in my table
I'll write select student _ ID comma
student uncore
name I'll give another comma and write
rore
number
over within
brackets I'll write
Partition
by store
ID
comma store
name okay then I'll
write order by store ID close the
bracket I'll give an alas as
rum from my table that is
demo let's just run
it you can see here okay let me
just delete n from here and do it again
all right if you see here there is just
one student in the name Shane we have
one student in the name
Bradley but here if you see for her the
second record it says two which means
there are two records for H and if I
scroll down there is one record for
Nathan and there are two records for
Kevin which means Kevin is also
repeated okay now we are going to see
another Windows function that is called
rank function in my SQL so the rank
function assigns a rank to a particular
column now there are gaps in the
sequence of ranked values when two or
more rows have the same rank so first of
all let me create a
table and the name of the table would be
a random name we'll give it as let's say
demo
one and it will have only
one column let's say variable a of type
integer we'll create this table first
okay now let's go ahead and insert a
few records to
our table
which is demo one so I'll write
value 10
102 let's say 103 is repeated I'm doing
this purposely so that in the output you
can clearly distinguish what the rank
function
does next we have
we have
106 and let's say 106 is also repeated
finally we have
okay let me insert these values to my
table that is demo one okay this is
done now if I write
select Vore
a and use my rank function I'll write
rank
over then
I'll order by my variable that is Vore
a
as an alas name let's say test
rank
from my table that is demo
one let me execute this and show you how
the rank function
works now if I run this there you go so
here if you
mark So for variable
a101 the test rank is 1 for 102 the test
rank is two but for this value which is
103 the test rank is repeated because
there was a repetition for
103 so we have skipped the rank four
here for 104 the rank is five now for
105 the rank is six now for 106 again
since the record was repeated twice we
have skipped the eighth Rank and our
rank function assigned the same value
which is 7 for 106 and for the last
value 107 the rank is
9 all
right now moving ahead we'll see our
final Windows function which is called
first
value so first value is another
important function in my SQL so this
function Returns the value of the
specified expression with respect to the
first row in the window frame all right
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
select the employee
name the age and
salary and I'll
write first
underscore value which is my function
and pass in my employee name
and then I'll write
over order
by my column that is salary
descending I'll give an alas as highest
uncore
salary from my table that is
employees so let me run this and see how
the first underscore value function
works all right so in our table Joseph
was the employee who had the highest
salary which was
$115,000 so the first value function
populated the same employee name
throughout the table you can see it
here now you can also use the first
uncore value function over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the
partition I'll write select empore name
comma I want the
department and the salary comma I'll use
my function that is first underscore
value followed
by the name of the employee inside my
first value parameter I'll write over
here I'm going to use partition I'm
going to partition it by department
since I want to know the employee name
who has the highest salary in each
department and I'm going to order
by salary
descending and I'll give my alas again
as highest
salary from
my table that is
employees so let's run this and see the
difference in the output okay so as you
can see here we have the employee who
had the highest salary from each
department so for finance Jack had the
highest salary from HR it was Marcus
similarly in it it was William if I
scroll down for marketing it was John
for product it was Alice who had the
highest salary similarly in sales we had
Joseph and in Tech we had Angela so this
is how you can use the first underscore
value function using
partition all right so that brings us to
the end of this demo session on our
tutorial so let me just scroll through
and show you what we did from the
beginning first we learned about
subqueries in SQL so we initially wrote
a simple subquery and then we used our
classic models database which was
downloaded from the internet I'd also
shown you the link from where you can
download this database here we used two
different tables and we performed a
subquery
operation we learned how to create
stored
procedures so we learned how you can use
the in operator or the in parameter as
well as the out parameter in stored
procedure after stored procedure we
learned another crucial Concept in SQL
which is called triggers now triggers
are also spefic speci kind of store
procedures so we saw how to write a
before insert trigger you can see it
here next we learned how to delete a
trigger we also saw how to work with
views in SQL so views are basically
virtual tables that you can create from
existing
tables we also saw how you can use views
using two different tables and an inner
join and we learned how to display views
how to rename view names how to delete a
view and finally we explored a few
Windows function to get into the
business analysis domain we bring you
topnotch courses to become a skilled
business analyst from the best
universities around the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
Now find the cost Link in the
description
Boxx is a journey that involves a
combination of skills Advanced
Technologies applications and processes
used by a firm gain business insights
from data and
statistics this is done to perform
business
planning in the analytics process data
is collected from various external
sources and is stored in a data
warehouse after this data collection the
process of analytics
begins here a more in-depth learning of
the data is done to derive possible
insight it from data in addition to this
all advanced datadriven capabilities are
developed which in turn provides
additional value to
business in the next slide we will look
at the places where analytics is
applied some of the common fields where
analytics is implemented are as
follows Financial
Services in in this field analytics is
used for credit scoring fraud detection
pricing and claims
analysis in retail it is used for
promotions replenishment demand
forecasting and Merchandising
optimization in healthcare it is used
for drug interaction preliminary
diagnosis and disease
management
customer retention capacity planning and
network optimization are the primary
applications in the field of
communications trading Supply demand
forecasting and compliance are the areas
of application in
energy in manufacturing it is used for
inventory
replenishment product customization and
supply chain
optimization
in the next slide we will look at the
topics that are covered in the first and
second
lessons in lesson one you will learn
what analytics is and understand the
process involved in
it the lesson will also provide brief
details on where you can apply analytics
and what insights can be derived from
this
application this helps you in
understanding a problem and knowing how
a data scientist should
act this lesson will also help you in
knowing how to collect data and prepare
it for your analytical
process in the second lesson you will
have an overview of all statistical
methods including descriptive
statistics probability Theory concepts
of test of significance and hypothesis
testing some business uses of these
statistic statistical Concepts have also
been provided via case studies for
better
understanding this lesson will give you
an idea of how you can derive some
meaningful pattern from the
data it will help you in finding the
distribution pattern that is hidden in
the data and in proceeding with further
decisions that are to be made at the
basic
level in the next slide we will look at
the topics that will be covered in the
third and fourth
lessons third lesson will help you
understand data exploration data
visualization and diagnostic analytics
and perform these using the r
tool case studies and examples have been
provided to help you understand the
concepts in a practical way and also
help you use the r tool
effectively the fourth lesson will help
you understand some predictive
techniques such as regression analysis
and models that could be built from
them logistic regression time series
analysis and cluster analysis will also
be taught with some example case
studies these predictive modeling
techniques will help you look at the
past data and identify the predicted
value that helps in making decisions
further all the working procedures are
explained using the r tool in a stepwise
manner with suitable
examples in the next slide we will look
at the career path of a business
analyst the of analytics has evolved
over time and the Advent of big data has
made analytics one of the most
sought-after skills in the industry
across
domains this course will help you take
the first step toward understanding
analytics and the way it interfaces with
the
industry the course will also help you
start thinking like a business analyst
career-wise you can aspire to be a data
manager data Miner or a business
manager the work of a data manager
involves data preparation deployment
Services report
Administration the work of a data minor
involves
exploratory
analysis descriptive
segmentation predictive
modeling the work of a business manager
involves campaign
management domain
expertise process and Roi
evaluation this includes Lesson Zero of
the business analytics with our tools
course offered by simpla learn
thank you for your attention please
continue your learning with lesson one
of this
course hello and welcome to one of the
business analytics foundation with our
tools course offered by simple learn
after completing this course you will be
able to differentiate between analysis
and
analytics understand what is analytics
learn the different stages in Analytics
know the popular tools used in
analytics understand the role of a data
scientist know the processes involved in
analytics Define a problem statement
collect and summarize data detect and
treat outliers in the
data we all know we are learning about
analytics then what is analysis is it by
any means different from analytics if
yes in what ways is it different in this
slide we see the basic difference
between analytics and
Analysis analytics is the science of
analysis wherein we apply methods of
Statistics Data Mining and computer
technology for doing an
analysis whereas analysis is the process
in which the complex data available is
been broken down to simpler forms which
provide more Compact and better data for
understanding in the next slide we will
see more into what is
analytics so what actually is analytics
it's the science of wisely acquiring
meaningful results from the given data
using various methods and Technologies
and by which a pattern of variation is
observed by studying this pattern we can
understand the future and predict the
uncertainty that is related to business
various sophisticated models and
techniques are used like statistical
mathematical and economical models so
how do you go about
analytics first you gather data for
example for a commercial entity you
collect data from Enterprise social
media internet forums Etc second you
Club all the data together and
consolidate and organize it in a form
from which you can analyze through
visualization statistics Etc which is
the third step in the
process in the next slide we will see
the different stages of
analytics there are major four stages in
any analytics work the first stage is
called descriptive analytics where data
or information is gathered and
summarized this stage usually caters to
questions like how many students dropped
out last year the next stage is called
diagnostic analytics where data data is
analyzed and insights are generated
which help in answering the questions in
the first stage here the question that
comes up will be why has the dropout
rate increased in the last one year with
the help of the analysis done in the
previous two stages the next stage tries
to answer unforeseen phenomena like
which students are most likely to drop
out the stage is called Predictive
Analytics finally the last stage known
as prescriptive analytics tries to
analyze the type of action required to
be taken to support or avoid the
unforeseen phenomena predicted in the
previous stage in this scenario
prescriptive analytics has queries like
which students should I Target to keep
them from dropping
out next we will look at a list of a few
popular tools used in
analytics these are some of the commonly
used tools for for analytical purpose to
get meaningful
results R Revolution
r r
Studio
Tableau saap
Hannah
w
kxen s
a next we will discuss the role of a
data
scientist so what is the role of a data
scientist in data
analytics a data scientist is somebody
who is inquisitive who can look at data
and spot Trends they come out with
unrevealed stories hidden in data that
helps in creating more useful insights
and thus help in solving business
problems a data scientist Works in sync
with application developer to get the
relevant data for analysis he or she
makes an analytical plan in such a way
that the results satisfy the business
needs a data scientist also comes up
with an effective data mining
architecture and prepares suitable
models they are responsible for
resolving data mining performance issues
and finally they should generate reports
that are affordable from a business
perspective next we will see the
methodology involved in data analytics
the data analytics methodology comprises
of six steps as can be seen in the image
the discovery step is questioning if
there is sufficient data to make an
analytical plan once we have the data in
data preparation all unstructured data
is converted into structured data so
that it helps in
planning model planning is choosing an
appropriate model that suits your data
model building is building the model
that is being specified in the previous
step the next step is to come up with
insights that help customers to solve
their problems that is to deliver
results the final step is to make the
model operational and put the findings
to use next we will discuss how to
define the
problem defining the problem statement
is an important step in analytics and
needs to be done before starting the
project at a high level the problem
statement should answer four basic
questions what is the problem
find the existing problem that needs to
be solved what is it not Define the
problem that is not being
caused why do we have this problem find
the root cause of the problem why don't
we have a solution this gives the answer
that is why the problem could not be
resolved in the next slide we will
discuss how to formally Define a problem
statement the techniques that are
involved in formally defining a problem
are are State the problem in a general
way that is State the problem in general
terms with respect to some practical
scientific or intellectual
interest the next step is to understand
the nature and origin of the problem its
objectives and the environment in which
the problem is to be
studied next all available literature
including relevant theories reports
records and any form of relevant
literature on the problem needs to be
reviewed and exam men the next step is
optional the researcher may discuss the
problem with his or her colleagues and
others related to the concern subject to
brainstorm
ideas finally rephrase the problem that
is put the problem in specific terms
that make it feasible and helps in the
development of working
hypotheses next we will look at ways to
summarize
Data before summarizing data the type
types of data need to be discussed data
can be two types qualitative or
quantitative qualitative or categorical
data refers to data that are descriptive
they are generally recorded in groups or
in descriptive language example dividing
people into high medium and low height
groups quantitative or numeric data
refers to data that are recorded in
numbers they could be either continuous
or discrete variables example the
measured height of a person in the next
slide we will discuss how to analyze
this
data summarizing refers to procedures
that are applied on the raw data to
convert them into an easily readable and
analyzable format the mathematical
summaries differ according to the type
of data numerical or categorical and
fall into into descriptive and graphical
categories seen here is an example of
population divided by marital status a
bar chart has been used to depict the
same data in the next slide we will see
the different summaries based on the
categories numeric data can be
summarized using the mean median and
mode values these are discussed in
detail in the following chapters along
with other methods for summarizing
categorical data can be summarized using
a frequency distribution table that is
the number of occurrences of a value for
all values graphical representations
help an easy visualization of the data
numeric variables can be viewed as box
plots and the categorical variables can
be viewed in bar charts or histograms
the visualizations will be discussed in
detail in the following
chapters in the next slide we will disc
discuss how to collect
data data collection is the process of
gathering data that is relevant to the
problem statement at hand the data AIDS
in proving or disproving hypotheses or
provides solutions to a research or a
problem statement regardless of the
problem the data collection process
needs to be well defined and
systematic in an effort to construct
accurate data the accuracy of the data
is the primary factor in deciding the
validity of the findings depending on
the method used to collect data the
observations need to be recorded and
organized in such a way to provide
Optimum usefulness the recording and
organization of data must also be
directly related to the methods of
analysis and use of the
data we will see the methods of
collecting data in the next
Slide the data collection methods fall
into two major categories primary and
secondary observations experiments and
surveys fall into the primary category
observations refer to measuring the data
and various attributes in experiments
the subjects are divided into groups
receive different external input and the
results are
recorded surveys questionnaires and
interviews help in recording feedback
and are used in studying the
characteristics of a population
data sources refer to data that have
already been gathered and are available
in a published format reporting refers
to cases where there exists a database
of information that can be legally
obtained next we will discuss data
dictionary a data dictionary also called
a metadata repository is a file that
describes the structure and content of
the data the data dictionary is a a file
or a list of files that contains data
about the database like number of
Records name of each field
characteristic and type of each field
description of each field relationships
between different
fields in analysis the data dictionary
helps in analyzing different variables
and the relationships and dependencies
between each
other in the next slide we will discuss
the final topic of this lesson L
outliers outliers are observation points
in a distribution sign deviates from
other observations if you look at the
graph it plots the marks obtained as a
result of a particular study time the
trend is that marks increase as the
student study longer except for one
marked point this could be a possible
outlier outliers could exist in a
distribution due to erroneous
observations or special circumstances
like a bulk sales order on a particular
day in a store outlier detection tests
exist to check for outliers that are
modelbased and generally look for
outliers based on mean and variance of
the data outliers can be excluded from
the analysis or included while using
algorithms that treat outliers as well
there are other outlier treatments but
are out of scope for this
chapter
let us quickly summarize what we have
learned in this lesson we have discussed
what analytics and Analysis are and the
differences between them popular tools
used in analytics what a data scientist
does the processes involved in the
analytics life cycle how to formally
Define a problem statement methods of
collecting and summarizing data for
analytics data dictionary and its
contents
what outliers are and how to detect and
treat
them the section will help you to check
your understanding of the concept the
last two decades have witnessed
extensive business infrastructure
Investments due to this the capability
of collecting data has improved across
Enterprises while some businesses
continue to operate in their traditional
ways in other businesses each aspect is
now virtually open to collect data these
aspects are even instrumented for data
collection
aspects like Supply Chain management
marketing campaign performance
manufacturing operations and workflow
procedures are a few examples
simultaneously information is also
available on events like industry news
market trends and movements of
competitors the wide availability of
data has led to increasing interest in
methods to extract useful information
from data science with this data
availability organizations in almost
each industry are focused to exploit
data for their advantage over
competitors earlier organizations used
to employ different teams of analysts
modelers and statisticians for manually
exploring data sets however now the
variety and volume of data have
outstripped the manual analysis capacity
computers have also become powerful and
networking has become widespread also
algorithms are being developed that can
help connecting various databases to
allow powerful data analysis as a result
of all these phenomena various data
science principles and data mining
techniques are coming into
existence a manager in an organization
needs to take several decisions on the
basis of the problem and alternative
courses of action available to conclude
the best option they need all the
information that is relevant and the
Criterion to choose the best option
here's a set of questions that can be
important for any business
executive some other interesting
questions that could be be important to
business executives are also listed on
the
screen let's first understand what
business analytics is it's a scientific
process that transforms data into
Insight it takes data from various
sources and various types and convert
them into insights that improve support
and automate decisions the techniques
used for this process are presentation
technological and quantitative in other
words it's a process that uses data for
better decision- making it's used for
fact-based or datadriven decision-making
this is generally considered as more
objective as compared to other
decision-making Alternatives business
analytics uses simple tools such as
reports and graphs and also complex
tools such as optimization Data Mining
and simulation in the graph shown on the
screen we've compared different data
analytics techniques in terms of
competitive advantage and degree of
complexity prescriptive analytics offers
the most competitive advantage over
other techniques such as is descriptive
and predictive however performing
prescriptive analytics is the most
complex data analytical technique we'll
look into details of each of these
techniques in the subsequent
screens let's now talk about the
features of business analytics or ba the
first important feature is the support
to various methodologies these include
Concepts from applied probability
Applied Mathematics applied statistics
and computer science since it's used by
organiz ations that are committed to
datadriven decision-making the data
produced helps in gaining meaningful
insights into better business planning
and business performance the next
important feature is decision support
systems in datadriven companies data is
treated as a corporate asset successful
analytics is dependent upon the quality
of data and analysts who know the
business and Technologies Solutions are
primarily used as decision support
systems or as their components the
solutions help Executives salespeople
and other organizational leaders to make
business decisions another important
feature of business analytics is
business continuity support as business
analytics supports essential business
functions and also supports tactical
decision-making with respect to
unforeseen events it also AIDS in
functions such as hiring reducing
attrition improving retention performing
staff deployment and deciding strategy
in many cases decision- making is
automated for supporting responses in
real
time this lesson will help you
understand the concepts related to
different types of business analytics
such as descriptive analytics Predictive
Analytics prescriptive analytics supply
chain analytics healthc care analytics
marketing analytics human resource
analytics and web
analytics descriptive analytics analyzes
the past events and predicts the
approach of future it analyzes the past
performance by mining the past data and
and look for the reasons why past
failures or successes happened almost
all management reporting such as Finance
operations marketing and sales uses this
analytics the related models quantify
data relationships in a manner that is
generally used for the classification of
customers and Prospects into various
groups for instance these models can be
used to classify customers on the basis
of their preferences and life stages
they can be used to create further
models that can make predictions and can
stimulate various individualized agents
some of the data techniques used by this
analytics includes reports data mining
techniques descriptive statistics data
queries data dashboards and basic wh if
spreadsheet
models Predictive Analytics converts
data into actionable and usable
information it determines the possible
future outcome of an event or the
possibility of a situation it includes
various statistical techniques from
machine learning data mining modeling
and game Theory and include techniques
that use models created from past data
to predict the future or determine the
impact of one variable on another when
it comes to businesses these models use
the patterns found in transactional and
historical data for identifying
opportunities and risks they allow risk
assessment by capturing relationships
between various factors the three basic
cornerstones of this analytics are
predictive modeling decision analysis
and optimization and transaction
profiling an example to use this
analytics can be to optimize customer
relationship Management Systems some
other examples include a company that
can create a mathematical model for
predicting the future sales by using
past data on product sales and a food
manufacturing company that can estimate
the measurement and quality of unit
sales by using the point of sale scanner
data from retail
outlets a few other examples include an
organization that can predict the market
share of a new product by using the
survey data and past purchase Behavior
using Predictive Analytics these
organizations can analyze the spending
use and behavior of customers this leads
to effective cross sales and high
profitability an organization must
employ an experts team or data
scientists to find and access the
appropriate data this team can work with
Business Leaders for Designing business
strategies by using Predictive Analytics
techniques such as time series analysis
linear regression data mining techniques
and simulation or risk
analysis prescriptive analytics uses
mathematical Sciences machine learning
business rules and big data for making
decisions and suggesting decision
options it specifies the best course of
action for a business activity in the
form of the output of a prescriptive
model it goes beyond predicting the
outcomes of future and also suggests the
actions to benefit from the predictions
it anticipates the reason of an incident
and not just what and when it will
happen it can also suggest decision
options on the method to take the
benefit of a future opportunity or to
mitigate a risk of the future the models
used in this analytics are called
optimization models and combine various
business rules mathematical models and
data the input can be internal data
external data and various other sources
here are some example Industries in
which this analytics is used the airline
industry can benefit by using Revenue
man agement models and past purchasing
data as inputs to get the best pricing
strategy across all flights similarly
the finance industry can use portfolio
models that utilize historical
investment return data to decide the mix
of
Investments other examples of
prescriptive analytics are supply
network design models in operations and
price markdown models in retailing in
operations supply network design models
provide cost minimizing plant and
distribution syst Center locations
retailing use price markdown models that
provide the timing of discount offers
and revenue maximizing discount
levels one of the traditional analytics
applications was in Supply Chain
management and Logistics it's used at
the core of companies like FedEx and UPS
it's used for efficient delivery and
optimal sorting of goods it's also used
for vehicle and staff scheduling vehicle
routing better inventory and processing
control and efficient Supply chains
analytic tools used in this area span
the complete analytics Spectrum for
instance it's been used by the women's
apparel manufacturer Bernard Claus Inc
the company used descriptive analytics
for presenting its supply chain status
to its managers another example is
ConAgra Foods a packaged Foods company
which used prescriptive and Predictive
Analytics for planning its capacity
utilization better by including the
inherent uncertainty in commodi pricing
the company received 100% return on
their investment in analytics in less
than 3
months analytics and Healthcare is used
to simultaneously control cost and
provide more effective treatment to
patients predictive prescriptive and
descriptive analytics are used to
improve staff patient and facility
scheduling they're also used to control
inventory purchasing and patient flow
for instance as per the McKenzie Global
Institute or MGI and McKenzie and
Company 14 study by better utilizing
analytics the United States healthc care
system could save more than 300 billion
each year which is equivalent to the
complete gross domestic product of
countries such as Singapore Finland and
Ireland marketing is one of the
expanding areas to apply analytics a
better understanding of customer
Behavior by using data generated from
social media and scanner data leads to
several advantages such as better use of
advertising budgets effective pricing
strategies improved demand forecasting
better product line management and
increased customer satisfaction and
loyalty one of the example is automobile
manufacturer Chrysler teamed with JD
Power and associates they developed
predictive models for supporting their
pricing decisions for automobiles say
they helped Chrysler to better
understand the ramifications of proposed
pricing structures the models generated
an estimated annual Savings of $500
million
the use of analytics in the Human
Resources area is relatively new with
the use of analytics the HR function
ensures that the organization employs
the required skill sets to meet its
needs hires the highest quality Talent
provides an employee retention
environment and achieves its
organizational diversity objectives
Sear's holding Corporation or shc is an
example in this area it created an HR
analytics team inside its corporate HR
function that used descriptive and
Predictive Analytics to support employee
hiring and tracking and influencing
retention web analytics is the analysis
of online activity such as visiting
websites and social media sites like
LinkedIn and Facebook it has huge
implications for promoting and selling
products and services through the
internet some points to remember are
that leading companies use descriptive
and advanced analytics to data collected
in online experiments for determining
the best way for configuring websites
position ads and using social networks
to promote products and services online
experimentation includes exposing
various subgroups to various website
versions and tracking the results these
experiments prove to be ineffective as
they allow the company to use the trial
and error method in statistically
determining what makes a difference in
their website traffic and
sales why is decision- making in any
business very important the goal of
business decision making is to high
Revenue low costs and low expenses it's
supported by business analytics in
various ways such as for increasing
Revenue while keeping selling expenses
the same business analytics suggest
changes in the Salesforce deployment it
can also be used if a company's
employees are leaving voluntarily for
higher paying jobs and there are high
onboarding costs in such cases business
analytics recommends raises that can
help retain existing
employees
business intelligence or bi refers to
reporting and analytics tools
traditionally used for determining
historical data Trends these techniques
and tools are used to transform raw data
into useful information for the purpose
of business analysis it includes a set
of processes methodologies Technologies
and architectures that uses the output
of the information management processes
the Technologies can handle large
amounts of unstructured data for
identifying developing and otherwise cre
creating new strategic business
opportunities bi enables queries by
which users can get results by asking
data related questions it allows easy
data interpretation of high amounts of
data while implementing an effective
strategy based on insights that can help
a business gain a competitive Advantage
bi includes tools that are designed to
present the results of analytics in an
understandable format they provide
historical current and predictive views
of business operations some functions
include online analytical processing
process mining prescriptive analytics
text mining business Performance
Management and
benchmarking data science includes
processes principles and methods to
understand phenomena through automated
data analysis it allows datadriven
decision-making or dddd which determines
the productivity of an organization DDD
is the practice of basing decisions on
data analysis instead of just intuition
organization ations get involved in DDD
to lesser or greater degrees which
decides the productivity of the
organizations the given image shows how
data science interacts with the outer
world let's now talk about the
importance of data science you can
consider data science a business asset
that is about data investment and
understanding of its fundamental
concepts is required for data scientists
and anyone working with data scientists
employing data scientists investing in
data heavy Ventures or directing an
analytics application in an organization
DDD and Big Data Technologies improve
business performance substantially data
science supports DDD and at times
performs such decision- making
automatically with respect to data
science the key strategic assets are
data and the ability to extract useful
information from data many businesses
use data analytics to get value from the
existing data and to generally consider
if the business has the right analytical
Talent incorrect data and unsuitable
data science Talent results in issues
such as poor
decisions Big Data typically refers to
data sets that are too large for
traditional data processing systems ITS
Technologies are considered as a popular
platform for data analytics and data
exploration and used to implement data
mining techniques and data processing
these Technologies are also used to
process data in support of the data
mining techniques and other data science
activities nowadays companies that
employ Big Data technologies have
started asking what can I now do that I
couldn't do before or do better than I
could do before therefore it's possible
the Golden Era of data
science different types of analytical
tools available are listed on the screen
these are open-source software have have
objectoriented design and can be linked
with General programming platforms they
also offer extensibility and various
other
features today we've got something
exciting lined up for you we know that
not everyone is a coding Wizard and
guess what that's perfectly okay in the
ever evolving world of it there are
plenty of opportunities that don't
require you to be a coding Prodigy so if
you are ready to explore the top 10 it
IT jobs that don't require coding skills
in 2024 you're in the right place let's
Dive Right In number 10 IT project
manager kicking off our list at number
10 is the role of an IT project manager
this job is all about coordination
planning and making sure that it
projects run smoothly no coding required
but excellent organizational and
communication skills are a must you'll
be the captain of the ship steering the
project to success as an IT project
manager you'll find yourself overseeing
teams budgets and timelines your ability
to juggle multiple tasks and keep
everyone on the same page will be your
greatest asset in this role your primary
focus will be on delivering projects
within scope on time and within
budget number nine it support specialist
next up at number
we have the it support specialist if
you're the go-to person in your family
or a circle of friends for Tech
troubleshooting this might be your
calling it support Specialists help
users with their Tech related issues
ensuring that everything runs smoothly
it's like being the hero of the IT world
without the need for coding as an IT
support specialist you'll need strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to explain technical issues
in a way that's easy for non- tees to
understand you'll be the first point of
contact for anyone experiencing it
problems so patience and empathy are
also
crucial number eight business analyst
coming in at number eight we've got
business analysts these professionals
bridge the gap between it and business
they gather and analyze data to help
organizations make informed decisions
it's a role that requires problemsolving
skills communication and a deep
understanding of both Tech and business
but not coding
expertise business analysts are like the
detectives of the IT world they
investigate processes identify
inefficiencies and recommend solutions
to improve business operations your
ability to analyze data and communicate
your findings effectively will be your
key strengths in this role number seven
cyber security analyst in the seventh
spot we have cyber security analysts
with the increasing importance of online
security this field is booming cyber
security analysts work diligently to
protect organizations from cyber threats
while you'll need to understand security
protocols you won't have to write a line
of code to keep the digital world safe
cyber security is all about staying one
step ahead of hackers and other cyber
threats in this role you'll be
responsible for monetary networks
identifying vulnerabilities and
implementing security measures to
safeguard sensitive data it's a high
stakes job that doesn't require coding
but Demands a keen eye for
detail number six data analyst moving on
to number six we find data analysts
these professionals play a crucial role
in turning raw data into valuable
insights you'll need to work work with
data tools and software but coding
skills are not a prerequisite if you
enjoy unraveling the Mysteries hidden
within data this might be your dream job
data analysts are like data detectives
they collect clean and analyze data to
help organizations make datadriven
decisions your ability to spot Trends
create visualizations and communicate
your findings will be your superpowers
in this role number number five user
experience ux designer at number five we
have user experience designers they
focus on creating userfriendly
interfaces and ensuring that websites
and apps are a joy to use while design
skills are essential you don't need to
be a coder to craft outstanding user
experiences ux designers put themselves
in the shoes of users to create
intuitive and enjoyable digital
experiences you'll be responsible for
wireframing prototyping and conducting
user research your goal is to make
technology accessible and delightful for
everyone without writing a single line
of code number four it sales coming in
at the fourth spot we've got it sales
Yes you heard that right selling it
products and services can be a highly
rewarding career your job will be to
understand your clients needs and match
them with the right Tech Solutions
coding nope not needed it sales
professionals are the bridge between
tech companies and their customers your
ability to understand complex Tech
Solutions and translate them into
benefits for clients will be your
strength building relationships
negotiating contracts and staying up
to-date with tech Trends will be crucial
in this role number three technical
writer now let's talk about number three
on our list technical writers hey that's
me technical writers like myself create
documentation manuals and guides to make
Tech understandable to everyone we
bridge the gap between the tech world
and those who need to use it all without
coding as a technical writer you'll be
responsible for translating technical
jargon into plain language your
documentation will help users
troubleshoot issues
understand software features and follow
best practices Clarity attention to
detail and a knack for simplifying
complex topics are your tools of the
trade number two it trainer in the
runner-up position at number two we have
it trainers these professionals educate
others on how to use various software
systems or applications effectively
teaching Tech is a rewarding career and
it doesn't require you to to be a coding
Guru it trainers are like Tech Educators
you'll create training materials conduct
workshops and help users become
proficient with the software they need
your ability to explain Concepts in a
clear and engaging manner will be your
superpower number one network
administrator drum roll please taking
the top spot at number one on our list
of IT jobs that don't require coding
skills in 2024 is the network
administrator these unsung heroes keep
the digital highways running smoothly
they manage networks troubleshoot issues
and ensure that data flows seamlessly
while networking knowledge is crucial
you won't be writing complex code
Network administrators are the backbone
of it infrastructure you'll configure
maintain and troubleshoot network
devices to ensure reliable connectivity
your skills in Network management
security and problem solving will be
your keys to
success and there you have it our top 10
IT jobs that don't require coding skills
in 2024 expanded to provide you with
more insights and
information remember the IT world is
vast and there's a place for everyone
even if you're not a coding wizard so if
you passionate about technology explore
these exciting career options
thanks for tuning in and don't forget to
like subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to stay updated with all things
Tech on our Channel until next time stay
curious and keep exploring the worlds of
it business analyst interview
questions my name is Richard kersner
with the simply learn team get certified
get ahead we'll go over some beginner
intermediate and advanced level
questions to expect in interviews when
you're you're looking at business
analytics let's start with the
differentiation between a risk and an
issue and this should be a very
fundamental question uh dealing with
business because in business they want
to make money and we really want to
understand where the split is on a lot
of these things so always ask yourself
where is the bottom dollar on this and
what does this mean uh risk is your
potential and an issue is something
that's actually happening uh so risk is
a potential problem that can be
predicted risk may or may not happen in
the future a proactive response plan is
formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there's no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on this is very
um company specific and so when you you
start looking for work you start going
in for interviews you should start
really asking yourself what are these
companies looking for that I'm
interested in clearly if you work with
IBM you want to have your tools that are
Central to IBM and the IBM setup same
thing with Google um with you know just
across the whole field uh some of the
more basic ones um obviously an Excel
spreadsheet which isn't on this list uh
but your python your SQL you should
really know your SQL is going to come up
in no matter what format you're in uh
your Tablo your exure your balsamic all
these are different platforms there's a
lot more out there but you should be
aware on which platforms your
proficiencies are on and those also that
you might not be proficient on but you
at least know what they do and what
their performance is so you can answer
questions and uh a lot of companies will
pay for you to be certified if their
platform isn't on your
list what are the various stages of a
business project
project and we look at uh project
initiation project planning project
execution project control and monitoring
project closure and it's really
important to understand any one of these
in a little bit more detail than just
knowing the list what is feasibility
study a feasibility study is a method of
gauging the success rate of proposed
Business Solution it enables business
analysts to discover new business
opportunities
and uh really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at a for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility uh that is a
very central question that comes up in
most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done what is business model
analysis business model analysis is a
technique that helps you analyze if a
business is financially economically and
socially viable or
not I know a number of contractors that
this is their sole career is to go in
and analyze ski resorts in Colorado to
find out whether it's going to make it
this year or not and what they need to
do to fix that uh so it's a very
high-end job Niche where you really need
to know your stuff and understand what
it
means what do you understand by
requirement differentiate between
requirements and
needs we look at requirements a
requirement is a targeted solution that
is required to achieve the set business
objectives business requirements are
data used for business processes needs
needs are the highlevel representation
of the terms and the result business
needs include identifying and
comprehending the business's goals and
articulating its strategic direction and
you can think of needs are what do we
need to succeed requirements are well
these are the things we need to put into
place this is what's required to achieve
a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip um PIN
codes from different countries using
those codes find the city and the state
names using
Excel and so if you're given a list of
zip codes PIN codes of various cities
from the US and India here's how you can
find the city and the country names
select all the codes go to the data tab
under data types select geography click
on the insert data option choosing City
from the field list click on the insert
data option and select state from the
field
list really you do need to know your way
around Excel no matter what other
packages you're working with uh Excel is
such a base package in business analysis
uh so much people are given that back
and forth still it's still kind of a
baseline below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in India
you can use the sum IF function to find
the total revenue generated from India
you can see here equals sum if and then
of course B2 to B100 India L2 to
l101 and that will give you uh the sum
you can also use a filter option to
filter the data only for India and use
subtotal by pressing alt plus equals
nice sh uh hot key to remember
there create a highlight table to
visualize the revenue generated from
offline and online sales for different
items across the region using
tblo now not all companies use tab blue
uh but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use you
drag the region onto columns drag the
sales Channel and item type Fields onto
rows select the total revenue column and
drag it on to colure and label cards
select Square as the mark type
drag the total revenue filled onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows Place audium type column onto
Coles under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select
Asia uh so one of the things about tblo
is it looks real complicated but it's
all drag and drop and so you should know
your way around about doing some very
simple drag and drops for doing your
query and summation and below is the
result Ed plot so let's look at some
more questions but let's jump to a
little more intermediate level uh
differentiate between software
development life cycle and Project Life
Cycle so we're looking a little bit more
hierarchial towards the top of the list
software development life cycle helps
with the development of software
products it consists of a single
software across multiple phases here
phases include requirement Gathering
coding operations maintenance and
documentation where the Project Life
cycle this enables you to develop a new
product in the business Project Life
Cycle consists of multiple software and
one customer scenario phases here are I
idea generation screening development
testing and Analysis how do you perform
risk management in your project so again
we're dealing with intermediate not just
how to pull tables across we going to
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced assessed
and mitigate it having the appropriate
risk management plan decreases losses
and optimizes decision making to enhance
the organization's performance how does
risk mitigation differ from risk
avoidance risk mitigation risk
mitigation is a plan to be executed when
a risk occurs when a risk occurs there
might be a business impact in the cost
incurred is high risk avoidance whereas
risk avoidance is carried out to avoid
the risk from occurring meanwhile the
business impact here is zero and the
cost is fully eliminated and you could
think about a brick and mortar store um
and they have shoplifting um you want to
mitigate as you want to avoid as much
shoplifting as you can uh but you can
only Frisk people out the door and have
security so much before you start losing
customers and so when you mitigate it
you're going to have to pay for your
lost merchandise where you avoid it you
have your security cameras and people
watching to stop uh people from uh
stealing things risk in this case can
mean loss of money spent uh badly spent
on equipment certifications there's all
kinds of areas where you want to
mitigate and avoid risk what are project
deliverables project deliverables
represent a collection of measurable
services and goods that are to be
delivered to the enduser in the project
completion stage this is so important we
start talking about any of our um uh uh
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to
know differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model uh two of our biggest or
most uh basic models used today the
agile model which is slowly taking over
especially in software uh the agile
model is adaptable to requirement
changes and has an incremental
approach in the agile model model
testing can be performed in every
phase with the waterfall model the water
Farm model is referred as a structured
software development methodology changes
in requirements are difficult to
implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
Final
Phase and you can look at this as um a
lot of the software today has to be
ready to change quickly when the
waterfall uh setup you're not looking
for fast changes you're looking for very
solid uh it's going to work no matter
what kind of view this is something that
we can build it isn't going have to make
major changes but it better work
correctly describe the different
analytical techniques like Moscow and
SWAT Moscow analysis it is a
prioritization technique that highlights
a requirement significance question like
is it a must have or a should have could
the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked
here in the SWAT analysis it discovers
the strengths and weaknesses of a firm
and evaluates them as opportunities and
threats SWAT analysis consists of
strengths weaknesses opportunities and
threats and you can kind of think of it
as like the SWAT team coming in um to
you know you're worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing
where in Moscow really what is um what
can we get out of this you know is is
this do we have to have it to succeed is
it going to be useful in the future uh
so you're looking more for a general
value attached to it list various
components of strategy analysis for
developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
Vision objectives Mission strategies
action plan what is
benchmarking benchmarking is a process
of evaluating an organization's measure
like the quality of policies programs
Etc against the standard
criteria it's so important to have that
Baseline of what are you measuring
against the Baseline might not even be a
very good one but you can't measure
something unless you have something to
measure it against it helps with the
measuring the performance of the company
you can recognize the areas of
improvement in a company and analyze how
other companies achieve other
objectives what is the best approach to
work with difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders
are before I even jump into this I have
a friend who is working with uh some
very highend individuals who took their
private plane uh and he was supposed to
meet them at the in location when he
arrived they had been an a fist fight
while on their private plane the
stakeholders had so much difficulty with
some particular aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen and of course you want to just
assume work with anybody but you want to
listen patiently to the stakeholders
point of view respond to them politely
and
diplomatically have a one-on-one
discussion to make things more precise
comprehend their worries and be
transparent make sure to continuously
engage such difficult
stakeholders and I'm going to highlight
the last one because if you're working
with somebody who's difficult ult and
you just try to ignore them um one of
the things is that whatever problems are
arising they're just going to explode so
that is so important not to exore the
ignore somebody who's being difficult uh
but the rest of it is stay focused stay
focused on what you're trying to
accomplish uh be goal driven this is a
great time to be goal driven not driven
by emotion or the problems that arise or
how the person
communicates name the different types of
agile
methodologies scrum uh you go get scrum
certified important thing to look into
if you haven't learn software
development and extreme programming XP
featur driven development FDD Crystal
canb Dynamic systems development method
dsdm if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skillup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to no more there is an agile
just a ton of different methodologies so
knowing at least a few of them inside
and out and having a kind of a general
idea that the other ones are out there
is important so you at least know what
we're talking about when someone comes
up and talks about
agile describe the Gap analysis Gap
analysis refers to the analysis of
differences between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted
system the Gap indicates the amount of
work required to get the int result Gap
analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed
functionalities uh you can see here we
put together an action plan to go from
the current state to the desired State
how do you import text file data into
msxl and remember Excel is one of those
things that has been around forever and
even though it's like the bottom barrel
of a lot of uh analysis that we do most
of our data starts in an Excel
spreadsheet um you know or comma
separated variable file that you then
end up with an Excel spreadsheet uh
given below is the employee text file it
has information about name age and
Company and here's how you can import
this data into Excel go to the data tab
click on get data dropdown under from
files select text CSV select where the
text file is located in your system and
click on import click on low data
imported into Excel you've been given
sales data that has information on the
cell of different items across the world
below is the data create a pivot table
to analyze the profit of all the items
in each region now remember a pivot
table is a table of Statistics that
summarizes the data uh of a more
extensive table so it takes a full data
sheet and we're just going to bring
we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means and if we want to go ahead
and do this what we do is you go ahead
and select a cell in the table go to
insert and click on pivot table in the
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table drag region and item type onto
rows drag total profit onto values sort
the sum of the total profit column using
the sales table find the percentage
contribution of Cosmetics to the total
revenue and total
profit create a pivot table by dragging
item type onto rows select the revenue
and profit column under values right
click on the revenue value under show
value as select percentage of grand
total right click on a profit value
under show value as choose percentage of
grand total and you can see here when we
do that we end up with Cosmetics made a
14.03% contributions to the total
revenue and an 18.94% contribution to
the total profit how do you create a
dual axis chart in tblo drag the order
data onto columns and convert it into
continuous year drag total revenue on
rows and total profit to the right
corner of the The View until you see the
light green rectangle synchronize the
right Axis by right clicking on the
profit axes under the marks card change
some total revenue to bar and some total
profit to line and adjust the size and
color they're lots of fun to play with
as you start getting into
these using the sales data Create A View
to show the total units sold and the
profit generated from each item which
item sold the least and has least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an next file
data in tblo
desktop drag units sold onto columns and
item type column onto rows place the
total profit column under color and
choose the desired color palette sort
the unit sold axes in descending
order you can see here it produces a
very quick um bug figure shows the fruit
sold and the least and had the least
amount of
profit create a map to show the unit
sold and the profit generated from
different Middle East and North Africa
items drag country onto the detail card
place a total profit column under the
size drag unit sold under color in the
filters card drag the region column and
select Middle East and North
Africa Bahrain had the maximum number of
units sold at the same time Iran made
the full amount of
profit create a visualization to analyze
the total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and
2017 drag the unit sold field on the
columns drag the region and item type
fields on to rows under the Cure card
place a total revenue column drag item
type onto filters and choose clothes
meat and baby food drag the order date
column onto filters and select 2016 and
2017 meat had the highest unit sold and
made the maximum profit now with any of
these Tablo it's good if you have your
own hands on for this
um so that's an important thing to note
we kind of zoomed in on tblo again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with tblo but
you're able to do this in another
package uh that's a good thing so at
least you know what we're talking about
and you've had that handson let's go
ahead and jump to some advanced level
questions what is requirement
prioritization name the different
techniques used for it requirements
priorization focuses on allocating
requirements depending on the business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business
needs there are several techniques used
for requirement
prioritization we had Moscow Technique
we mentioned that earlier the
requirements are grouped based on must
mandatory should high priority could not
necessary but prefer
and wood suggested for the
future ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its
importance of course this is at 100
um oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the $100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no uh notional $100
to distribute among the requirements so
the $100 method is pretty similar to
what the ranking method is top 10
requirements in this approach from a
large set the stakeholders simply pick
their top 10 requirements this is very
popular um there's a lot of help books
out there about getting things done they
say write everything that you want to
accomplish um put them on 3x5 cards and
narrow it down to five do those five
because once you've conquered those five
then you can move on to the next
ones name the critical agile metrix that
should be considered by a business
business analyst Sprint
burndown uh so the Sprint burndown is
the chart we use when you're tracking
usually it's in scrum is where that
usually comes from the scrum uh setup uh
but it's a chart of the work to be
completed and what's still going on uh
you have your work category allocation
the
velocity the cumulative flow diagram
defect removal awareness time coverage
defect resolution time explain BP
pmn bpmn business process model and
notation Gateway controls the flow of
interaction and sequence of processes it
is a flowchart technique Which models
the end to-end business process step the
four essential elements of bpmn are flow
objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations swim Lanes pool or Lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about Gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews uh don't know how many times
I've been on the phone calling uh
competition um potential clients to ask
questions uh so one of the elicitation
techniques is to ask questions if you're
going to call clients to ask questions
it can a lot of terms also turn into
additional
sales document analysis focus group
prototyping brainstorming my favorite
brainstorming um all these are important
I I just kind of highlight a few of them
that I tend to get stuck in observations
and
workshops again workshops are a great
sales technique also so as you're doing
your business analysis and you're
bringing people into a workshop and do
observations in the workshop and working
specifically with these people they turn
into potential business growth um I tell
you what if you're a shareholder and
someone's doing a business analysis and
they turn around and generate a $30,000
sale for your company um they're in you
know you've already earned your you've
already earned your pay and you're doing
what you like which is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
Survey uh questionnaire and Survey is my
least favorite but they are the most
popular because they're the easiest to
pump
out list of documents needed by a
business analyst initiation document
project Vision document use cases system
requirements specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability Matrix
functional requirement document use case
specifications document gap analyst
document describe how you would approach
a
project here's a basic project approach
outline which you can use with with
respect to different
situations identifying the project goal
formulating the work plan defining the
requirements collaborating with other
teams tracking the project documenting
the
progress and really when you um start
designing your project
approach encompassing all the things
listed in here is so important with the
shareholders uh if you I mean it's great
if you can identify your project goal
and that's probably the most important
thing because if you don't have a goal
you might as well walk away um but if
you don't have the rest uh well how are
you formulating the work plan defining
the requirements um collaborating with
other teams that is such a a big step uh
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top differentiate an alternate flow and
ex ception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic
flow basic flow represents the operation
of activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case different steps
are used to complete the goals of a use
cases exception flow refers to the
various steps executed in case of errors
this does not lead to achieving the
required goal of a use case critical
aspects of creating analytical reporting
analytical reporting is a type of
business reporting which provides data
analysis information and recommendations
it enables people to use data to make
decisions to create analytical reporting
the following points should be kept in
mind comprehend business analysis
display your analysis skills think
critically and I'm going to throw in
here uh the term from Big Data map and
reduce uh really when we're doing a
business
analysis you don't want to give them a
massive amount of information you want
to reduce it down to something that they
can see in a single graph uh a very
simple set of notes um and you need to
think critically you need to really make
it uh what is it that the shareholders
want that's going to make them
understand why this is important to the
business and what does the business get
out of it what is Canan can band helps
agile teams in visually managing work
through processes it works as a
scheduling system in agile just in time
production the can band methodology is
all about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of work
the can ban board describes a current
development
status and of course when you're working
with can ban you got to be very careful
about uh uh inspiring versus coaching
versus
micromanaging it really can end up in a
micromanaging setup where you want to
you want to watch out for that but you
also need to track everything a basic
canb board has three-step workflow has
the to-do in progress and done however
depending on a team size structure and
objectives the workflow can be mapped to
meet any particular team's unique
process State the key differences
between BRD and
SRS BRD business requirements documents
is high level functional specification
of software BRD is a formal document to
describe the requirement provided by the
client business analysts create this
post their interaction with the clients
SRS system requirement specification is
a highlevel functional and Technical
specification of software SRS describes
the software's functions and
non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas SRS is
created by the systems AR Architects
what is parito analysis the perto
analysis helps in crucial
decision-making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most relevant
and the least decision concerning the
overall goal is also known as the 820
rule as per this rule 82% of the
Project's benefit arises from 20% of the
work vice versa 80% of the case problem
can be due to 20% of the causes
differentiate between the V model and
the fish
model when we talk about the V model it
is an sdlc model where the execution of
processes happens sequentially in a
vshape at every stage the same person
reviews but other testers will do
software testing in the last step V
model consumes less time and
cost the fish model is similar to The V
model but with more multiple
verification
teams every stage is tested by another
team team for completeness and
correctness the fish model is
comparatively very costly and time
consuming which makes sense cuz if you
have uh multiple tests on each stage for
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all
that given the cells data create a chart
to show each Region's country that made
the highest revenue create a pivot table
by dragging the region and Country onto
rows place a total re new column under
values right click on the country value
select the filter options and choose top
10 choose top one as shown above and
click on okay and you can see here is
the pivot table that you will get using
the sales data find all the countries
where the total units of fruits sold
offline were less than 3,000 you need to
use an advanced filter option in
Microsoft Excel to solve this
problem below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select Advanced filter option choose
copy to another location give your
criteria range and the copy to location
click on
okay here's the final result as we can
see below let's create a pivot table to
find which countries from each region
made the lowest amount profit create a
pivot table by dragging the region and
the country into rows Place The Profit
column under values right click on any
country value select the filter option
and choose top 10 choose bottom one and
click on
okay and then let's create a filled map
to analyze the total revenue and profit
generated from beverages in North
America using Tabo drag country under
detail card place a total revenue column
under the text drag total profit under
Cure in the filters card drag the region
column and select North America in the
filters card drag the item type column
and select
Beverages and you can see from the below
map you can see the Greenland and the
maximum revenue and profit generated
from beverages in North
America who
knew using table how will you display
the top five and bottom five items based
on
profit drag the item type filled under
rows and total profit onto columns right
click on the item type column to create
a set give a name to the set and select
the top tab to choose the top five items
by sum total
profit create a set for for the bottom
five items by some total profit select
both the sets right click to create a
combined set give a name to the set and
choose all members in both sets drag the
new set on the filters and the total
profit onto
calore the above graph depicts the
Cosmetics made the highest profit while
fruits made the lowest and really when
we're talking about tools like
Tao um or if you're targeting companies
working in r or you're targeting
companies working in Python
you should be able to quickly do these
kind of displays in any of those
packages that you're focused on uh tblo
is one of the biggest ones out there
right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also um very robust and
easy to use and uses less programming on
the back end uh so just a quick side
note on there roll your sleevs up if you
if this does not look right to you
you're not able to get through some of
these things make sure you are if that's
what you're targeting in a company for
an interview
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here h